foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
instructions
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun and look at
the intense focus on magnus's face what
a performance has been
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
the tournament and it is yours and fun
for race winning the dramatic Armageddon
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps
the Dutch referred to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
welcome back to Vikings a this is day
three of the Tata steel chess tournament
2023 I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me my friend International
Master Tanya sachdev Tanya we saw some
Fighting Chess in round two two decisive
games you excited for day three
super excited Robin it's such a pleasure
to be calling out the action in this
exceptional tournament we've got 14 of
the biggest brains in the world fighting
it out battling it out currently in
waikanse and you've got to prove your
metal to be there right now the chest
that we've been seeing has shown just
that it's been incredible so far the
players have been making it easy for us
with their brilliant play Robert uh
we've had a niche with his explosive
tactics Magnus and not abec showing some
incredible technique and of course the
resistance on display by Arjun and
Parham yeah that's a great summary of
yesterday's action two wins won by
Magnus in that end game he ground down
Vincent kymer and then Anish Geary with
an explosive Victory tactus Galore
against gukesh so with those other five
draws some of them very very hard fought
there we do have four co-leaders so
Tanya as we head into the third day of
action we know who's at the top who's in
good form it is Magnus Carlson Anish
Geary dingley Ren and abusotave at the
top with one half of the two down at the
bottom unfortunately gukesh hasn't
scored a single point yet but it's a new
day it's a new opponent and maybe he'll
be able to strike back
the case indeed needs to stop the
bleeding and start scoring already where
all I can say about this big round three
coming up is Robert to everyone who's
joining us on YouTube and on Twitch get
your popcorns ready because we've got
some amazing fixtures and big matchups
coming up
oh we certainly do so while you've
mentioned let's bring it up for
everybody to see because every round has
seven matchups and they're all going to
be interesting in their own way we start
the top with Richard's report against
Wesley so it's two players of completely
different styles and to this point in
their careers it has favored Wesley so
head to head he has two wins he has
never lost to Richard but maybe Richard
with the white pieces will feel inspired
and have a shot at taking down Wesley so
the game there for Richard and for
Wesley Wesley's been pretty solid so far
but the other huge matchup is Fabi
taking on Jordan now these are two
world-class players they've had a couple
of shaky years in classical chess and
they want to establish especially I
think for Fabiano caruana he wants to
establish himself once again at the very
top uh so definitely currently looking
for a win in the start of Steel Masters
both those players would love to get a
victory and head toward the top of the
standings and the next matchup is
somebody who would love a win more than
anybody is gookesh he takes on Abdul
sitarov and this is a matchup of the
young generation of the teenagers
abdusitar of doing very well so far but
with the black pieces Tanya what do you
expect in this one
I think it's going to be more about
dukesha's mindset today he's had two
difficult losses he needs to keep them
in the past the one thing that stood out
in this event for good cage has been his
openings have just not worked he's got
to show some great prep and get his kind
of positions again not against
norderbeck this match is special in so
many ways Robert it's a grudge match
ever since uh the 2022 Olympiad where
gukesh took on Nader back had a great
position from the start got over
ambitious pushed too much the tides turn
nordeback went on to win that game
Uzbekistan went on to win that gold and
ever since then when these two players
mate it is fire on the board wow you got
me even more excited than it already was
for that matchup and I'm also excited
for the next one
gets the white pieces against Nish Geary
Anish had a very quick game yesterday
almost a miniature win against gukesh
that was a great tactical display and
Parham on the other side he had a very
long game a grueling draw he was a
surviving playing perfect defense
against dingley Ren so as we talk about
that game from yesterday it took almost
seven hours Tanya they still had the
energy to go over the game but what do
you think about today does Parham have
enough left in the tank with the white
pieces to take down Anish giri he has to
find it in himself to do just that he
starts with the white pieces and stamina
energy is gonna play a big role given
the time control of this tournament uh
that said having quick games can have
its own drawback Parham feels himself
already in Rhythm for the tournament
he's played these long games he's played
great openings middle game and end game
Anish meanwhile has had explosive around
so far I think Parham hopefully he got
some good sleep for this one
he needed after that really heroic
defensive task we will talk about Magnus
Carlson versus dingley run in great
detail but before we do progdananda
Vincent kymer another matchup of
teenagers so Tanya who do you think has
the edge in that one
two big players from that country Prague
from India Winston from Germany these
two have been making that market in the
elite World amongst the established
a-listers but they also want to prove
something within themselves we talk
about a clash of generations but this
one Clash of the two prodigies equally
exciting tough to pick a favorite here
and the same in the last matchup between
Argent era Garcia and levona ronian they
have duked it out online for the last
couple years now we'll see them over the
board and Arjun two solid draws to start
with the black pieces Lavon he held that
first game against Magnus yesterday he
didn't really get much with white
against Prague Nanda but we'll see what
happens in that one so Tanya I think we
have to dive in to our featured matchup
of the round how could we not it's
Magnus Carlson the number one rated
player in the world for over the last
decade taking on the number two player
in the world in dingley Ren so Tanya
take it away we got two of the best
players on the planet
it is all eyes on this game Robert
Carlson taking on thing it is wall
number two one versus well number two as
you mentioned the only two players
who've crossed the 2800 Mark currently
this is the only possible matchup in the
Chess World between two 2800s it's
happening today it's happening right now
I think many fans many chess lovers
across the world would have loved to see
a Magnus vs ding world championship
match that's unlikely to happen ever but
today these two face off each other in
what is the Wimbledon of chess
yes and Magnus Carlson said he's no
longer thinking at least actively
thinking about 2 900 but he may change
his thoughts if he can beat dingley run
today ding is preparing for the World
Chess Championship that's a distraction
when it comes to individual games
beforehand you want to save that
preparation you say all playing magnets
I want to do my best but I also don't
want to give yanapamishi any insight
into what I'm working on so we'll see
how this one goes today Magnus Carl's in
the eight time Vikings a champion dangly
red would like to win his first so as a
reminder to everybody these matchups
they're long they're grueling they can
last seven hours plus but right now we
see the players seated Tanya there's
gookesh and nordi Beck Abdul sitarov uh
both players they're gonna be hungry for
Success over the board
this is such a huge game and especially
for the rest of the tournament for
kukesh with two losses already he can't
afford a third loss in a row that's
super hard to come back from not a bag
at one and a half out of two Robert he's
had a solid start he is in form gakesh
currently struggling with that he's got
to find the mental energy and the
strength to play for a win in this one
with the white pieces make the most of
his chances but most importantly stop
the bleeding yes that what is what he's
looking for and this event is 13 Rounds
so he may have lost the first two but he
still has 11 left to play and 13 players
receive invites directly in our generic
guys he won the Challenger section he
qualified for this event the scoring is
typical of most chess tournaments one
point for win a half point for a draw
none for a loss and if we do get it
tight when all said and done we'll get
tie breaks 100 minutes for the first 40
moves you get the 30 second increment
from move one and you gain 50 additional
minutes once you reach move 40 and then
if you get to move 60 if the games go
that long another 15 minutes we saw that
happened yesterday in that matchup
between Parham and dingley ren but today
is a new day dingley Ren is seated at
his board his opponentless for the
moment Magnus as per usual not showing
up before the clock hits the hour
we've often seen him just arrive in the
nick of time and sometimes even later
who can forget the video from the world
rapid and Blitz uh in the blitz section
Magnus for three minutes actually came
to the board with just 30 seconds on the
clock so you just never know with him
but very rarely do we see him just
seated there and have time before the
start of the game I think he likes to
arrive just at the moment when games are
about to lift off we see gokish and not
a back ding ready to go the fans are
ready The Spectators uh the hall is full
the amateur section is being played we
can see the spectators they're all lined
up they know it's a huge day if anyone's
been planning to be at why can't they
for the Tata steel Masters it's round
three it's the day that you want to be
there and we see the Bell over there the
gong there's a special guest every
single round who gets to start the round
by hitting that and I don't know who it
is today but it's always fun to see the
fans watching the action unfold there's
the challenge intersection right behind
Anish girian Parham maksudu some
familiar faces in the Chess World and
they believe that's Valerie image over
there uh they're a little far away for
the moment but very strong players who
would love to join the Masters
Tournament a year from now there's
Leonard I see Leonard taking photos uh
we have so many people working hard to
make sure that everything is set and I
just saw a certain Magnus Carlson walk
through the camera heading towards his
board
he has arrived and as you were
mentioning at the Bell the gong is ready
to be hit and the games are about to
start very often what is amazing about
Tata steel is that they've got esteemed
guests to announce the start of the
round but sometimes they also invite
young talents and players from the local
community to come and ring that Bell and
that's a huge inspirational moment for
them and that's what this tournament is
about about sharing the stage with these
World Elites the amateurs looking up to
make their way there and we've got
handshakes we've got a liftoff Robert
with ding pressing the clock it's go
time it certainly is and Magnus Carlson
gets the white pieces he's just writing
down the names he's getting settled
before he starts making moves on the
board and what you said is very true
it's great to see young players they get
to take in this atmosphere one day
hopefully they will be playing in this
very tournament I love seeing that in
sports when someone has a photo with you
know Ronaldo or Messi and then
eventually they play against those
Legends so in the Chess World that
remains uh something that we would like
to see and we'd also like to see this
one unfold here as Magnus plays the move
d4 on his first turn
starts with the Queen spawn opening and
immediately gets up uh and meets one of
the esteemed guests there at the Tata
steel event we also see Fiona there at
the background D4 played it could very
likely be that Magnus would be happy to
take it to a Catalan of course it
depends on how ding wants to respond to
the Queen's Pawn opening we see the
night has been taken out night after
this might be heading to a Catalan okay
and you know what's fun oh and then
the London system so uh instead of the
cattle we get to London and I was going
to say that Magnus has been dingling
around one time and it was in the
Catalan but Magnus was black in that
game so perhaps for Magnus he is happy
memories against ding from the black
side of the Catalan and sometimes that
does play into the psychological
psychology excuse me of the player so a
London Tanya on the highest stage
between the two top players in the world
Eric Rosen is somewhere and clapping his
hands celebrating and I'm sure he'll
analyze this game in great detail later
this is the win for all the London
lovers I mean I could have uh predicted
many openings today but this one would
not have made it to my list Robert I am
surprised with magnus's choice but I
love it it just means that he just wants
a game uh he wants no theoretical big
lines here in this one thing Lauren uh
slowing down already because he's
equally shocked at what he's seeing on
the board a London by Magnus sure if it
was Blitz and Rapid we've seen that
happen many times but in a classical
over the board again event playing
against the world number two
I am surprised
surprising for dingly run as well he is
sitting and thinking and the reason why
is in response to the London system
there are many different options uh
there's a bit of a peaceful option with
E6 and Bishop D6 to follow just trying
to challenge and trade those dark Square
Bishops you can throw your Pawn forward
with C5 but in the current position that
square is not defended so sometimes you
have to worry about am I going to get my
Pawn back or am I going to get
compensation around that pawn because
when the pawn takes on C5 that later
gives the E5 Square to Black potentially
so this moment here isn't just dingly
Ren being unfamiliar with the opening
and he does in fact play the move C5 as
we're talking about it it's just which
style does he want to employ and he
chooses the most aggressive way Tanya
indeed this is the most combative reply
to the London system and ding took his
time because
very often this moment move number three
from black is what determines the kind
of positions whether they'll be
strategic battles or more open complex
tactical middle games gets decided E3
let's start by Madness he's of course
prepared for this answer of C5 and now
I'm expecting ding to open his own
Bishop on f8 E6 is a move that's often
played here you defend the C5 Pawn you
clear
yeah the C5 Pawn uh you know wants
defense there and that would uh help
that out Knight C6 is often played as
well in addition to Queen to B6 going
after the pawn on B2 that's the downside
of playing the London system is that
there is a bishop out on F4 so when the
bishop has removed itself from home the
B2 Pawn becomes a potential Target so
we'll see in this game you know what the
players are aiming for that's the big
question it's not a lack of familiarity
it's not a lack of experience in each
and every individual game uh the players
are trying to figure out what direction
is best against their specific opponent
and Magnus playing quickly so after E3 I
do expect Knight C6 as the standard
reply and often times after Knight C6
white plays with C3 we get the Triangle
Pawn formation uh we have a great Pawn
chain in both directions the bishop sits
on D3 here White Castles and just tries
to play a bit of a slower approach and
try to control the center of the board
so let's go to our bird's eye view we
have all games going on at once here and
we'll just go around the horn a little
bit
seed see see that in the bottom right
only two moves by white have been played
in the matchup between Vincent kymer and
prognanda in second from the right again
just two moves by white black has played
only one himself and as we look you know
the middle and the bottom row that one
is the farthest along and as I see that
position it kind of reminds me of Magnus
Carlson's many games in this variation
including as Fabiano caruana from the
World Chess Championship so
uh Around the Horn here just different
types of positions all around the
players just getting you know at their
Boards of trying to figure out this
opening stage of the game because we we
often take that for granted that every
single player has memorized 30 moves and
that they can do that no matter what the
opening is that's not the case that's
not true and so it depends on the
opening and if they prepared it for that
specific day and we see
let's choose let's see which what game
do I want to analyze right now let's go
in fact to that game
I was mentioning that reminded me of
actually before I go there I'm gonna
switch games really quickly to the one
between five and a carwana and Jordan
Von Forest because the last move that
was played I was gonna go to the middle
in the bottom row but instead I'm going
to the game between Fabiano caruana and
Jordan Vaughn Forest uh because if we
can
uh look at that game a big move was just
played by the Dutch player former
champion of this event he just decided
to strike with F7 to F5 so a big moment
here F5 played protecting the Knight on
e4 but perhaps weakening the king
and yeah it's a
uh time you back
got here and I lost everything and I was
like not right now not when we have a
London on the board at the most
important round of the waikansea but
everything's well what has been going on
and what have I missed
well you joined back at the right time
because F5 was just played by Jordan Von
forest and this might already be a
novelty like looking in the database
here not seeing any games and we're on
move seven and it was a Petrov now five
minute caruana has been sort of the king
of the Petra for many years but if we
just look through this game normal
everything is nice and normal D5 Bishop
B3 and then Bishop E6 already that's a
very rare move just played a couple of
times and after Castle's F5 is Jordan's
choice so Tanya we've seen Jordan
display tremendous opening ideas
Novelties and that helped him win this
Tata steel tournament a couple years ago
but what do you make of this one it
feels very weakening or at least it
gives white control of certain squares
you know you make a move like F5 in the
opening and it's so double as it goes on
to show that you're ready for an
aggressive fight but yes very early on
you are creating weaknesses in your own
camp and you know what it's the kind of
move which uh which they say don't try
this at home but we're talking about
Jordan van Forest here this is the guy
who comes up with the most creative
opening ideas he and Richard Rappel
we've seen that about him Jordan when
you mentioned uh one the Tata steel
Masters in 2021 we saw him employ all
kinds of offbeat openings and ideas he's
doing just that and with the black
pieces when you're playing against an
opening specialist like Fabi you want to
try and confuse him as early as possible
and that's what he's going for
yeah it is confusing because it gives
white control of this juicy E5 Square
when your pawns two squares apart like
this look at the square in the middle
that is White's for the taking
potentially but black does have
Firepower at night can come to D7 a
bishop to D6 and then black can fight
back now the E4 Square looks like it's
under Black's control but if this Knight
moves out the way this Pawn will go up
to F3 and kick the Knight out so that's
a long-term thought that white has to
keep in mind now E5 is one square E6 is
potentially another that white can use
because there are no pawns helping
defend the square but that would require
the smoke to clear it would Knight will
be forced out of E4 just to get a rook
it's the E file on an open line so I
think Jordan he's playing this sort of
tricky opening and it's not actually
very obvious how Fabiano should respond
right now and that's what he's counting
on right objectively it might not be the
best way in the Petrov to handle what
white has done you know you give up this
E5 Square forever there's no Pawn to
push any piece out of there while your
own E4 square is a little shaky but Fabi
needs to figure out how does he make the
most of this weakening move F5 and it's
important he does that soon because
black has a clear plan you want you know
where you want to place your pieces the
Knight on B8 will land on F6 the Bishop
from f8 can go to D6 you go shot Castle
the next few moves are flowing and
definitely Jordan knows what he's doing
meanwhile Fabi needs to decide does he
want to put the C Pawn on C3 or does he
want to play C4 more aggressive
challenge the center The Rook will come
to E1 where does he want to develop the
Knight on B1 whereas the bishop on C1
want to go so there are a lot of
questions here uh Robert that Fabi needs
to answer and that's why he slowed down
he is taking a thing think he's as
surprised as we are
yes and I like what you're talking about
on the queen side with C3 or C4 because
just like in the position in the London
if Queen B3 happens at the correct
Moment The Pawn on B7 is loose that's
the downside of developing your queen
side Bishop like this so early is that
if a queen gets the B3 there could be
some problems on the queen side for
black so we'll see how Fabi handles this
we're gonna zoom out because he is in a
deep thing trying to figure out what is
best to do so we can go to our bird's
eye view and get a sense of all of the
action that's taking place seven games
going on at the same time so uh as we
look across the boards here the openings
they're underway the games are taking
shape and Tanya that London in the top
left hasn't progressed too much but one
game that is far along it seems is the
one in the bottom left so Parham and
Anish they've made quite a number of
moves just because it's a standard
looking position
very interesting Parham has been talking
about his opening preparation and
mentioning that with the black pieces he
feels quite comfortable he's put in the
work and in his game against ding was
quite well prepared till a certain
moment and he was happy about getting it
with white he starts with the Italian
now this is not a new position this is
something that we've seen time and time
again with the Italian or the Geico
piano is just such a complex and a rich
opening it's all about little moves here
and there and what do you start with it
just changes everything and no matter
how much you know about the Italian it's
not enough these are the famous words
spoken by Levon who's of course quite a
quite a master of the King's Pawn
opening and uh Robert the live board
that we have in front of us Anish has
chosen to immediately counter White's
Italian Bishop on C4 let's take it from
the top and see how we got here
absolutely E4 E5 so we had the Italian
Bishop to C4 black file with Knight F6
that allows white to play the fried
liver going after the F7 Pawn but at the
highest level you don't see this very
often instead players typically play
this D3 move because in these sharp
variations after D5 Pawn takes Knight A5
Bishop B5 check this is all Theory so if
you want to study this variation there
is a lot of material out there that can
help you the bishop often slides back to
D3 and it's a position where white is a
pawn a head but this bishop is awkward
because the bishop on C1 is not getting
out on this diagonal the Knight on G5
can be kicked very easily black gets a
bunch of time and when we cut the board
in half black actually has even though
it's down upon in total is up a pawn
over here on the king side and
oftentimes the pawn goes forward once
the Knight moves out the way so uh black
gets activity for that pawn and in this
game we saw just D3 calm chess from
Parham he did have that long game
yesterday he knows that a niche is well
prepared and we get very standard moves
including trying to A5 taking away this
B4 push
a5e is very committal it is one of the
topical trendy ways to counter the
Italian and as you mentioned it's
directed against the plan of white
expanding on the queen side with B4 A4
A5 but along with that you know chess is
a game of given take rob you get
something but you give up on something
and the drawback of A5 is that it
creates a weakness in Black's Queen side
and that is the B5 square and this can
often be used by the white bishop or the
Knight to create activity and as we see
that is exactly what a niche what Parham
has done after Bishop E6 he doesn't want
to trade off the Bishops he takes
advantage of Black's move A5 goes Bishop
to B5 keeps the light squared Bishop
alive at some point he can be dreaming
of Bishop A4 Bishop C2 also black needs
to be careful after Bishop B5 if we just
back up to what Anish just played white
has a devious threat in this position
because black has already played Bishop
B6 if it was white smooth Robert White
just wins he wants to go D4 hit the
bishop on C5 with the tempo you move the
bishop away you go D5 you Fork the
Knight you Fork the bishop you win a
piece which is why preempting that Anish
made the typical move Bishop A7 just
falling back
yes because D4 does not come with that
very important Tempo and then you you
see that D5 is going to happen and black
would deal with that accordingly so the
bishop is safe and sound A7 and it's
easy to forget about this piece because
it's far away that's the beauty of a
bishop it's a long range piece it's sort
of sniping all the way to the other side
of the board and that F2 Pawn could be
tender if white isn't looking out
carefully so we're in a position that
hasn't played several dozen times and
these players they've studied the ins
and outs of the Italian because a
position may look familiar but it's
slightly different and that little
wrinkle could make all the difference so
I believe that whites typically plays
Knight to D2 often brings the Knight to
F1 and either to G3 or to E3 depending
on what kind of setup black employs so I
think that we're at a calm start and
that's probably the best choice for
Parham given that he is likely a bit
fatigued and a niche is extremely well
prepared so just get a position let's
just play chess us not rely on
Preparation because Anish Geary is
really really good with his preparation
the Italian is such a tricky opening
Robert you often feel that nothing's
happening until it does and then
everything explodes I just want to break
down this very important point in these
positions with black Anish in the
Italian what you really want with the
black pieces is to get a successful D5
in you were mentioning White's idea
Robert of transferring the B1 Knight to
the king side trying to eye those lights
quests meanwhile Black's aim in life
against the Italian is to get D5 you
want to get that Central break in very
often the knight from C6 also goes back
to E7 comes to G6 on the king side
eyeing the same squares that white
knight wants so it's really a slow game
that develops and eventually explodes
into a crazy middle game and that's what
I'm looking forward to uh with this one
we will come back to this and see how it
develops but let's zoom out for a moment
and get an update to an opening tour of
our other matchups for sure so let's uh
take a step away from this matchup for
now and as we see the seven games in the
well the Magnus game it looks like the
thing is not moving
um so it seems like ding is uh he has
actually just made a move uh E6 it
appears and maybe it's Magnus who's the
one who's not moving that's uh
surprising that these players are
playing quite slowly out of the gates
right you expect the first five moves to
be played instantly it said they're on
move four in the top left nothing major
happening at the moment but a big
decision in the bottom right we see the
move F2 to F3 so Ben Feingold probably
not very happy to see that he says never
play F3 and the reason why you don't
play F3 is because it weakens your king
so
uh if we go right into that game between
Prague Nanda and Vincent kymer uh
several moves have in fact been played
uh from that position uh you see that
the pawn is on e4 for white so a huge
Center for pragnanda but Tanya black
what does he have he is facing a bishop
pair but oftentimes you have a very
solid position I tend to prefer these
from the white side what about you
I kind of play this a little bit with
black it's not my main opening against
the nimso queen C2 but let me tell you
yes it looks like white has got all the
space out of the opening why it has got
the two Bishops but on the other hand
what black has achieved is a tiny tiny
advantage in time and in development
Black's already castled uh the pawn is
on B6 so the Bishop from C8 is eyeing
the B7 Square for development at some
point really soon black will strike in
the center because white needs time to
finish development so what I'm expecting
Vincent is to take a setup with Bishop
B7 Knight comes to D7 the pawn goes to
C5 maybe we can just show that Robert uh
the way that black wants to finish
development Knight D7 Rook C8 taking
advantage of that Queen on C3 and with
that black will be able to make the most
of the time that white has lost in
gaining the space with all these pawn
moves I mean what do we know about
openings right develop your pieces put
your king to safety don't get your queen
out early on but it looks like in
getting these trumps white has
disregarded all these rules so black
gets some time and time is off the
essence can't allow white to continue
development can't allow white to do
everything normally what black will be
worse but I think Vincent is going to
strike in the center before white gets
everything he wants yeah that's what
absolutely must happen because if visit
doesn't start putting pawns forward and
threatening a white center and you give
white all the time in the world you see
a bishop coming to E3 this bishop to D3
a knight into E2 maybe even an attack
going up the king side because white has
a very healthy Center for now three
pawns more advanced than any of Black's
pieces taking up space and by the way
prognan is playing this very quickly so
I feel like Prague is at home in the
position it hasn't been played you know
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
times I don't believe especially with
this bishop coming to B7 if we just go
back a few turns Tanya
um at this point here D6 is a popular
move the most popular though is B6
getting the bishop here right away and
delaying your deep Pawn push but after
D6 and F3 wait this is where we're in
newer territory because it's a very
committal Choice by Prague and in fact
the most popular move is Queen to E8
seems very strange why would you a queen
to E8 is your idea to play Pawn to E5
and if so why wouldn't you just bring
your Rook to E8 and I think
the difference tends to lie in the fact
that if you play E5 at this point
um The Rook on E8 not doing the you know
the most here that even if you end up
taking on D4 your pawns are very healthy
and so the move Queen to E8 instead it
seems like well what has changed after
E4 if we do in fact play the move uh E5
like what has happened here uh the there
often are differences where there's no
pin on this Knight and that can be
extremely important uh so it's hard to
explain all the subtleties uh with a
move like Queen to EA just seems awkward
but in the event of D5 The Rook is
better placed on f8 for when you strike
with F5
that's a really good point because F5 is
such a thematic idea once the center is
closed but there is still some time for
that to happen instead Winston continued
with a different part of development he
did make the move uh Bishop to B7 after
white has expanded the center at some
point he'll have to take a call is he
going to provoke white to go D5 with the
break of C5 or E5 both have their own
advantages and disadvantages I am
expecting him to first before taking
that decision Robert to 97 put your Rook
to see it maybe take your queen out to
E7 or E8 as you pointed out and then
take a call if you want a break with C5
or E5 but we will see one of these
breaks in the game yeah the problem
though is even when you get the break
why can't my Bishop D I'll just put a
few moves on if you had Bishop D3 and
black plays C5 one of these Pawn breaks
and white just plays Knight E2 if you
take on D4 this doesn't necessarily help
black as much as you would hope because
if their Knight takes D4 or this Pawn is
more approachable it's on an opening
file here The Rock will eventually come
to D1 now we have the bishop pair for
white and there's more open space and
that's what Bishops need they don't like
closed positions they want an open
position and the dark Square Bishop is
unopposed on this board so I just really
love these positions from the white side
I think that Vincent he needs to remain
solid but if you remain solid you don't
have an activity if you try to get
activity then maybe you have a long-term
weakness to figure out so that's the
give and take of Chess especially when
you're pushing Pawns
a very complex middle game will come
about in this one drop it and we'll see
the parts that Winston takes
all the all the drawbacks in Black's
position currently the one big thing the
one good news is that it's a very solid
setup for Black and practically not so
easy for white uh to take advantage of
when black has created no weaknesses uh
I still think this is going to be a
complex middle game both players are
taking their time to make their moves
decide their setup while they take these
decisions let's uh let's zoom out for a
moment and take a look at some of the
other games that are going on and all
the action because the opening is pretty
exciting in all of them Robert and the
one game that catches my eye right now
is the Arjun Levon matchup now there's a
lot of history between these two level
for Levon Arjun is often times in Rapid
in speed chess format been and Kelly's
heel for Levon they've traded several
punches and blows uh Arjun has been a
difficult opponent for lab but now he
faces uh Levon the giant the very very
strong Lev in a classical
OTB event that's not happened too often
so it's going to be interesting to see
how these two players proceed and the
middle game that we have coming on is
already a fun one do you want to dive
into that let's do it so we can go into
the game between uh levonne and Ronin he
has the black pieces taking on Arjun
aragaisi and both of these players have
started their tournament with two draws
they have one point out of the two games
um Levon really good first game where he
drew Magnus Carlsen he survived what
looked like a you know tough position he
made it look easy and Arjun with the
black pieces two in a row against Prague
Nanda and Wesley so has looked like you
know he is not going to be losing many
games in the future so where we are
right now Tanya it looks like two pawns
have been traded for each side it's the
position is opening up the king is still
on E1 but there are no black pieces to
attack it with and one other thing I'm
noting is this bishop on C5 is a little
bit loose so Lavon has to keep an eye on
that because maybe a knight takes B5
will happen and your Bishop is under
attack
it's definitely something to be careful
about because uh the last move by left
was pawned to B5 attacking that bishop
and C4 if you just back up for one move
uh Robert Arjun in response to B5 fell
back with the bishop to E2 and now the
natural developing move would be put
your C8 Bishop to B7 but then you've got
to calculate that Knight B5 and then you
have Bishop on C5 hangs and you can very
well just end up being down upon and I
see our eval bar it agrees with your
point that Knight B5 is a massive threat
which means that Lev actually has to
still spend a move before he completes
the development one very thematic idea
is to retreat with the bishop you need
to decide do you want to keep the bishop
on the A7 G1 diagonal or even go back
Bishop E7 the reason I don't like the
move Knight to D7 defending that Bishop
on C5 is two reasons one you allow a pin
along the D file white gets the option
to go rip T1 uh pin that Knight create
pressure on it also very often you want
to be flexible with that Knight on B8
you might want it on C6 you might want
it on D7 it's a decision that you want
to delay I'm expecting Lev uh to retreat
simply with the bishop but the big
question is which square is he going to
choose
um I feel like that was a question posed
to me I'm choosing E7 because the if I
go to A7 right look at this Pawn chain
here that Bishop looks a little bit
silly it's staring into a very strong
Pawn chain that's not going anywhere so
at least when I go to E7 I'm closer to
my king side in particular Knight and F6
if it ever gets pinned and I feel that
B4 potentially is in the future at least
I can open up that side of the board so
I would choose Bishop E7 it feels more
compact it feels like it's a square that
does a little bit more for black in the
long term and I agree with your points
completely about where this Knight
should go uh Knight D7 it looks just
like a developing move with Bishop B7
next but if we actually play the move on
the board with Knight to D7 it's not a
problem but movies like Knight E4 can
also be annoying now I'm really
attacking your Bishop twice and if you
take on e4 thinking you're just swapping
look at the Evo bar starting to creep up
and the reason why is because of what
you said Tanya comes to D1 Whitey's just
a little bit ahead in terms of activity
and the D file is super important it's
an open file The Rook on 8 is under
attack which you don't have time for
Bishop B7 just yet you have to make this
awkward move Rook A7 it's a Tempo
wasting move and then when you play
Bishop B7 your Rook looks silly and
stuck on the sideline so um these
intricacies are super important so I'm
totally with you Tonya Knight to D7
feels just a little bit imprecise and I
don't think that Lavon will end up
playing it I think he will Retreat his
Bishop to E7
I agree with that also because of
concrete reasons here if you put the
bishop on the A7 G1 diagonal let's say
you go Bishop A7 or Bishop B6 white
again gains a Tempo with Rook D1 and you
don't have a nice Square for the queen
because don't forget there's a massive
threat of Bishop D6 as well you can't go
Queen E7 you end up losing material
immediately it's the same story if you
go Queen to E8 so Robert Bishop E7 is
the move that I am expecting black still
needs a couple of moves to finish
development get that Bishop out to B7
take out that Knight to C6 put your Rook
on C8 and then you feel the harmony
there's still time for that will Arjun
find his initiative before Levon is able
to equalize out of the opening because
remember it's a symmetrical Pawn
structure the central pawns have been
traded so once again it's all about
peace activity in this one it certainly
is and I just want to make one small
point that after B5 uh Bishop to E2 was
played this bishop had several choices
it wasn't just e2go you could only
Bishop D3
potentially putting pressure on the H7
Pawn you could do the same thing that
black can do in the lines we're just
talking about you can go back to A2 but
the bishop 182 is staring into the same
brick wall the bishop on A7 would so
Argent takes the choice of E2 versus say
D3
um I'm curious about that I wonder if
after the game it would be so
interesting to hear his insights of why
he didn't put on what seems like a way
more active square but it does get in
the Rooks away potentially
um but I would be very interested to
know the distinction between those two
lines
there are a lot of differences between
putting your Bishop on D3 and E2 and I
think it's a matter of taste rabbit for
some players Bishop D3 you either 87
Pawn you're trying to create an attack
it would be more it would be more
attractive but then you have to be okay
with also not defending that Knight on
F3 so let's say if you were to put the
bishop on D3 black develops his Bishop
on B7 at some point then you're already
threatening to take that Knight on F3
let's just back up and put the bishop on
D3 and yes right now maybe Knight B5 I'm
not sure if it works or not probably not
because the D3 Bishop is still hanging
but you have to be okay with losing a
Tempo to save your Pawn structure not
just that you want your Rook on D1 you
want it on the open file so even though
yes you gain an attack on the S7 point
you lose out on a lot of factors I do
you see the eval bar does like Bishop D3
but I think from a personal perspective
Bishop E2 feels more natural in these
positions you are threatening uh the
Knight B5 trick if the bishop is not on
D3 as you're pointing out in this case
the bishop on D3 would just hang
well yeah that was your point it's a
really really astute observation so
Bishop E2 opens up Knight takes B5 as a
threat and that may give Arjun the time
to get the initiative that we know he
wants he's a very active player and so
we'll see how this one continues Lavon
is just spending his time making sure
that he doesn't blunder and it's
important even at this early stage to do
just that because you don't want to hang
a knight takes B5 that one's obvious so
I'll move my Bishop away to A7 but as
you were just saying Tanya Rook D1 the
D6 square is vulnerable and white would
love to plant a bishop there so Bishop
E7 to my eyes looks the safest uh it's
not the end of the story just yet but I
do think that Bishop E7 will keep
levon's position uh Compact and solid
and help him try to continue maintaining
his equality so let's zoom out for a
second
uh Lavon he's on the clock he will
consider his options and the game
between Magnus and dingley Wren has
changed a little bit where Magnus did he
gave up his light Square Bishop for a
night on C6 at the top left uh game on
the screen here and there's you know
just action happening all around we see
in the second row second from the left
five minute carwana he put a knight on
E5 and then took a knight that was on D7
about Jordan run Forrest continues to
play extremely quickly so a Tanya which
of the games that we haven't looked at
do you think we should Venture into
you're absolutely right it looks like
all the players are in a big fighting
mood today just looking at the openings
it's tough to pick one uh but the one
that catches my attention right now has
to be the Fabi game uh do you want to
just quickly jump over to Fabi versus
Jordan One Forest Fabi with the white
pieces Jordan has made this committed
decision of going F5 already a set of
minor pieces has been traded black has a
knight on e4 and it looks super pretty
but it can be kicked out any moment with
F3 so it's not something that you can
rely on this is where we left it last
Robert and after we need to Bishop E7
trying to finish development Bobby jumps
in with the Knight to E5 and Jordan
immediately challenging that uh with
Knight D7 and after the trades of the
night 97 Queen D7 what's interesting is
that Jordan can still decide whether he
wants to go long Castle or short Castle
very good point because Cass and
kingside we usually do by default there
are fewer pieces in the way but castle
and queen said is an option and one more
thing I I want to point out is in some
positions let's say I Castle uh oh it's
white uh White server F3 I was going to
just say at some point that if you take
on e4 and I take back this bishop can be
trapped in some of these positions so
it's something to keep an eye on I
understand in this current one it
doesn't work out uh there are queen H5
checks and queen to E5 it saves the day
just to actually show you this tactic
that after G6 is Queen E5 hitting a
loose Rook freeing the bishop white
woodwind material but the point I was
trying to highlight here is that if this
King were already castled then this
bishop would be trapped on D3 so there
are positions where you actually leave
your Knight hanging on e4 in fact after
d takes E4 if I took this way it shows
just that I took with the wrong Pawn but
Queen 64 is check so if you think you're
escaping no you're just losing more
pieces so
um I just wanted to highlight that point
that the bishop on D3 can be trapped and
so you can leave your knight thanks to
these Pawns
that's a Super Bowl point you make that
very often our first reaction is just to
retreat with a piece that's been
attacked but very often there are
offensive ways to defend that piece and
to just showcase your line uh let's make
a move by black let's go shot Castle
because then suddenly it is possible to
do all of that that you're saying fe4
and now we can pick it up with the F
Pawn there's no check on H5 and the
advantage of shot Castle is that after
fe5 let's say you go Bishop B4 Black's
got the Intermezzo Rook F1 and it
becomes a big mess
and we can see I mean even in this
position it's a huge Advantage for black
it's kind of surprising but maybe just
simple chests like this bishop has to go
all the way around here and Bishop G4
comes to mind keep bringing pieces in
we'll take bring the Rook over white is
up a knight for one Pawn but lacks
development so I would not have assessed
this is so good for black I I just don't
uh no you know for sure but now we know
because the engine's telling us this
that it's crazy to think about that it's
a night worth three points for a pawn
worth one but because white lacks
development and this is why we tell you
to get your piece out connect your Rooks
that this makes up for the material
deficit pretty wild to think about but
that is for sure what Jordan has
prepared if he castles here uh Tanya we
know that he has worked this all out and
I think that it would I would do if I
were Jordan if I was trying to trick
Fabiano I would spend a good deal of
time right now let's say he's already
studied this position but he spends 20
minutes on a move like Castle
um 5.0 is not going to be tricked he's a
professional player he's going to assess
the position as it arrives on the board
but you know what I mean like if you
spend a bunch of time and you're like
okay I'm gonna cast so I think this
works out and you think oh something
like this I'm gonna get the second pawn
and that's better for white that
wouldn't work out but F takes E4 if he
knows with certainty that it's good for
black and castling is the best move
maybe invest a little bit of time just
uh
give Bobby a false sense of security
that Jordan is finally out of
preparation I don't know maybe I'm just
playing mind games here that won't work
I'll be honest the Robert I was so taken
in with your idea of sacrificing a beast
that I didn't even realize that if you
don't play the move A6 as you were
pointing out in your line white will
actually have the Bishop from D3 the B5
square and I think that makes a lot of
difference I think it's and I'm shocked
to see that after blundering this line
away the computer the evaluation bar
still doesn't move at all that's an
absolute shocker uh I think it's
impossible to make the move shot Castle
unless you've prepared it at home you've
seen it it is so counter-intuitive
because of course the idea relies on the
light Squad Bishop not having a square
so you need to make the move A6 or C6
for these ideas to work and it's
completely crazy just how the computers
are able to still keep the evaluation as
balanced just based on initiative and
development right and you know I all
jokes aside about playing mind tricks
and mind games uh these players they're
just trying to evaluate the line that
they have for them at the board so in a
different position that might work out
but because castling looks very strange
with the B5 Square open I think Fabiana
will quickly suss out that yeah this is
still preparation I don't think I'm
gonna take this Knight just yet uh I'll
continue his development before trying
to take this Knight and the Knight will
likely have to retreat so this game is
interesting but it's going to be
Jordan's task to figure out how he's
going to reply which direction his King
is going to go to eventually so why
don't we Zoom back out to the full seven
board View and let's go to the game
between Richard report and Wesley so
because that one looks very interesting
to me it's a position where report
that's in the a second from the right on
the bottom he is up a pawn because it's
a caracon a a pan-off position and it
started with C4 on the first move and
that's what's interesting about Chess
openings is that there could be
transpositions and C5 Knight C3 G6 this
looks nothing like a caracon but after
E3 and D4
we get a position just I'm gonna pause
right here and go back to the beginning
and show you that after E4 C6 you can
get that same exact position if you want
you get D4 D5 takes takes C4 Knight F6
Knight C3 and G6 and then white goes
Queen to B3 and we get to the position
that we have in the game so it's this
was not Wes's intention I don't believe
he's not a caracon player but now we're
in a caracon so that's a
that's kind of funny
yeah you have to be prepared for these
surprises especially when you're playing
a player uh like rap like Richard rapper
who you know will create something out
of the opening that you're not expecting
at all and Wesley we see has taken his
time to deal with the surprise as you're
mentioning a different start you don't
expect a Carol out of one C4 but here it
is on the board and you kind of have to
be ready to play any sort of a position
we see Bishop E2 by Richard rapper so
trying to finish development also if we
just take a quick count white is upper
Pawn already
yeah it lights up a pawn in Bishop E2
what's the point Bishop F3 let's protect
this Pawn I've had the white side of
this position before and it's not always
easy for black to figure out what to do
when you're prepared in the caracon
Wesley so is not playing the caracon
these days and now he's to figure out um
am I just going to be down a pawn for
the next you know a bunch of moves or is
there a way to get it back in this
specific position there's the move
Knight B to D7 this is also the move
Knight to A6 both of these are viable
opening ideas
and Wesley might not know about Knight
A6 it looks kind of strange and that's
not criticizing him or his opening
knowledge he doesn't play the karakanas
Black so Knight A6 looks weird but it is
a move that has been played Knight D7
looks much more natural Bishop F3 can be
played Black plays Knight B6 and as we
see there's a fight at the D5 Square for
white you have three pieces defending
for black you have three pieces
attacking for now white wins that
Showdown and after Knight E2 potentially
F4 you might not actually get that pawn
back and you have to play around it so
it's a fascinating opening discussion
that we're having here and unfortunately
for Wesley he's not a caracon player at
least not recently
it's going to be interesting to see how
he handles this uh situation as you're
pointing out that there is this idea of
going Knight A6 Knight C7 through which
you can also attack the D5 Pawn or you
get the Knight wire D7 to B6 but once
again it's not clear how you're actually
winning that pawn back considering that
white has got a defense with Bishop F3
very often in these positions black also
can think about offering a queen trade
you can go Queen B6 and what's the point
of that not currently but once you've
developed your knight the idea of
trading the Queens is you get rid of one
of the Defenders Robert and then the
Rook from f8 can jump over to d8 so
imagine 97 Bishop F3 Queen B6 you trade
the Knight comes to B6 Knight goes to E2
and then after Rook d8 you're again able
to put
threats on the D5 pawn and try and win
it so a queen trade offer is what I'm
expecting from Wesley at some point yes
and well you could figure this out and
if that's what black wants white might
not want himself and the bad thing about
a queen on B6 is the Knight can't get
there and you don't have as much
Firepower against the pawn on D5 so
white will probably sidestep it maybe
even with Queen to D1 Knight to E2 and I
just get the sense that Wesley is
extremely uncomfortable here I know what
it's like and we all do to be taken out
of theory and out of our prep but he
does play Knight A6 so uh wow he finds
it he finds it and the good thing about
having your knight on C7 as uh compared
to B6 is that you can play this move B5
it's a move that black often throws in
to wreak havoc on the queen side with
this bishop coming to F3 in the Knight
to C7 there is an opportunity with Rook
B8 and B5 to play B4 and kick this
Knight out so it's a long variation
there's a lot to talk about but Wesley
he is not fooled he figured it out so
good on him these two players unfamiliar
territory perhaps but a great opening
display thus far so we are going to
head on to our first break as the
players are breaking down these opening
positions and when returned we'll dive
right back in seven games are in session
it is 14 of the best players duking it
out for the Tata steel Chess Masters
we'll be right back
speed chess championship title Tuesday
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
and compete by voting for your predicted
results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun and look at
the intense focus on magnus's face what
a performance it has been
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
the tournament and it is yours and fun
for race winning the dramatic Armageddon
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steep in Prestige and Legacy and does so
again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
everybody two Vikings a it is the third
round of the Tata steel Chess Masters
tournament I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me International Master Tanya
Tanya we just had our first break and in
the opening stage of this round we've
seen some interesting opening displays
an extra Pawn for Richard Porter as
Wesley so is forced into a caracon but
in other games we've seen uh just a bit
of a slower approach and as we have all
seven on screen in front of us like I
look at the top right in between gookesh
and Abdul sitarov not much has happened
not a single Pawn has been traded uh
just the dark Square Bishops hmm Robert
to me it looks like the players have
come in with renewed intensity and
energy because as we can see from our
zoom out view of all the boards we've
got really fascinating opening outcomes
take a look at the Fabi van Forest board
at the bottom left the second board this
was a line that I thought I blundered
into and after F3 indeed Jordan has made
the move shot Castle so in fact
sacrificing that Knight on e4 these are
ideas we were looking at we will Deep
dive into this and just next to that
things are getting crazy as well in the
Parham Anish board we see a G5 G5
hitting that Bishop on H4 and we know
that that is a very aggressive way to
play the Italian now I have to say the
one thing that stood out for a niche so
far in the tournament has been this
slightly out of character very
aggressive play by a niche he's not
going for the safety first approach he
he is playing lines and openings and
taking middle game decisions that just
spread absolute havoc and I'm loving
this side of a niche yeah well why don't
we go to the game between Anish and
Parham Parham with the white pieces and
the first move Advantage but his clock
seems to be a disadvantage at this point
so we will dive into the game between
maksudlu and giri and that was a big
move that last move from black we've
seen the bottom left-hand side of our
screen we saw the move G5 that is such a
committal decision because the black
king is on this side of the board and
the reason why Parham is thinking is
like do I sacrifice a knight on G5 and
after Pawn takes I take with my Bishop
here I have a pin against this Knight
the king is open that's the big question
that has to be asked but I trust Anish
giri he's not playing G5 and falling
Victor to some huge attack I think he
has prepped this out especially with all
this tension aimed at the D4 Square I
don't think that white can get away with
the Knight sacrifice on G5 I just at the
very least I do not think it will lead
to a winning position
a lot of our chat there showing support
for Anish let's go Anish Anish is
literally playing Blitz he is showing
immense opening preparation he's making
the moves fast he's playing aggressively
I love it you were mentioning the
sacrifice on G5 and I think all of us
when we play this kind of a move that's
the first thing that comes to mind it's
what we are all scared about you open up
the king you get two pawns for a piece
but Black's King is exposed you have
this deadly pain you're threatening
Queen to F3 you have these ideas of
reinforcing attack on F6 but very
importantly Robert and in a very
thematic way one of the ways in which
black gets out of trouble here is an
unexpected quiet move King to G7 and
it's the king that comes to rescue the
Knight on F6 it looks strange but it
works to Perfection and Black's idea now
that the Knight on F6 is defended is
sometimes to go Knight E7 Knight G6 if
the king requires reinforcements or you
can also go Rook to h8 and start coming
up with The Rook to H5 sometimes at the
right moment to try and defend that
Knight on F6 but most important to
notice that the sacrifice doesn't work
if black knows how to handle it and the
key defensive move is King to G7
absolutely and you know in the back of
your mind you have to keep looking at
this Pawn on D4 and behind it this Pawn
F2 it does give black some tactical
opportunities against the white king and
we just saw Parham move he did not
sacrifice the knight uh he instead
played the move Bishop back to G3 and
just to just finish the line here
quickly Queen F3 does go after this
Knight on F6 but you don't have a
follow-up you can't bring another piece
to attack this Knight on F6 that's the
problem and the King on G7 is doing some
great work protecting this Knight so
let's say you move this Rook even say
Rook to G8 um or Rook to h8 if you want
to go Queen G3 to get some kind of
Discovery you don't even have a good
Discovery so I actually think you could
take on D4 but also play King to f8 and
now my Rook hits the bishop my queen
defends the Knight you're just not
getting what you need you don't have the
queen side in play and more Firepower to
attack this Knight so I do believe that
para made the right decision after a bit
of a think Bishop to G3 but that's also
a bit of a small victory for a niche he
has shown great preparation he's played
G5 and if I'm remembering correctly
Tanya in his match against vidit when
that was live in India they were in a
boxing ring that was super exciting they
actually played a game just like this
and it was a great position for black
and I and
um it was a win for black in that game
the G5 and E5 pawns make the bishop on
G3 look a bit silly
um you were there for that much Robert
so and it was such a Monumental one the
first time ever did that match that
happened in India Anish went on to win
against with it in uh in a hard-working
a tiebreak it was just so intense that
entire match and you're absolutely right
this opening was played in a similar
setup and it's very important that white
knows how to handle this you don't only
not sacrifice it a yes your Bishop on G3
is a little dead but very often that's
temporary because the E5 Pawn is shaky
black often needs to take a decision on
that also the drawback of 86 G5 it looks
aggressive it looks cool but it is a
long-term weakness you have every pawn
move in chess creates weaknesses and it
is over ambitious play it is over pushed
and it has its own set of drawbacks now
Bishop G3 rookie 8 I like it keeping the
tension on the board eyeing that pawn on
e4 black has an immediate threat now you
want to take D4 you want to pick up that
upon an E4 which actually forces White's
hand here to take a decision on the
center you don't have the option to
continue development with Knight to D2
because let's say you go on id2 then
suddenly you lose control over the D4
pawn and black can actually play e txt4
and activate that Bishop on A7 win upon
it's well explained there so that means
that white has to make a choice the E5
Pawn is defended by one two three pieces
and attacked by one two three pieces in
return so white can remove the guard by
taking the Knight on C6 but this doesn't
amount to some kind of Pawn advantage
that you would hope for if you take on
C6 and the bishop takes back look what
has happened the bishop and Knight stare
at this Pawn on e4 so while you take E5
I can scoop off your E4 Pawn the bishop
on A7 is nasty on the diagonal the
Knight is threading the bishop on G3
just to win it directly because the pawn
F2 is pinned and while it looked like
Black's King is the one that might fall
victim to an attack here it's the white
king that's in trouble so you're trying
to remove the guard you're trying to win
the pawn E5 you're not getting away with
it and anisha's last move Rook to E8 it
actually defends that pawn tactically
and the pawn E4 is a big Target as you
were saying and making the move D5 just
to defend your Center that doesn't look
right it doesn't sit well with me to
open up the bishop on A7 the Knight
simply goes over to E7 the Knight can
come to G6 and maybe even this move F5
is in the future The Rook will likely
slide back to f8 at the right moment
because not doing anything on E8 but
when the Knight gets out the way F5
looks like it is very strong whose
Bishop is better the A7 or G3 the answer
is very obvious
it's very obvious it's very clear and
you never want to activate the A7 Bishop
unless you get something tangible in
return and D5 is not a move that you
would play or be happy playing allowing
97 the king Knight to come on the king
side it would result in a devastating
attack I really think that Anish is
putting the pressure on every move that
he's made has a threat in the position
starting with A5 he first stops B4 then
he goes G5 hitting that Bishop on H4
then rookie it hitting the center it's
like he's playing all over the board
he's playing a bit on the queen side
then on the king side then in the center
and D takes E5 is the decision that
Parham takes I think he's feeling the
pressure he wants to try to settle the
situation down in the center and uh
Robert it will be now up to a niche to
decide what he wants to recapture with
95 comes to mind to try to liquidate
things as you pointed out D5 also is
practically possible two Pleasant
choices I would say with a knight for
sure because after Knight takes E5 we
see a bishop stare down and if white
decides I'm just gonna trade that Bishop
off the board after Queen takes D7 and
if we do in fact get these trades here
we're talking about this bishop on G3
the position is objectively equal we see
the evaluation bar off the side but I
just like the long-term advantage of a
strong Bishop here against a
questionable Bishop on G3 Knight H5 will
be available if you're you know
leave it here for so long that could
even hop into F4 so I I understand it's
equal but I feel like it's easier for
black to play in this position with the
Rooks connected and the superior dark
Square Bishop I just think that I would
prefer to have black in this game
very well explained you just simply
compare the pieces and you know the ones
that you want to get rid of you want to
get rid of White's active Bishop on B5
you want to get rid of White's developed
Knight on F3 and you want white to stay
with the undeveloped Knight on B1 and
the bad Bishop on G3 Knight E5 I like
the move I like the way Anish has played
this opening and I think we can conclude
uh this position this opening outcome as
one being of success for a niche we'll
see how Parham tries to create chances
here with the white pieces currently
looks like black is out of the opening
without any problem let's zoom out for a
moment because there's fire on other
boards as well Robert
yeah there isn't we by the way we did
just see the trade on B7 so Parham even
though he spent more time I do believe
that he's familiar with his position and
he understands that uh taking on D7 just
offering the trades is going to be okay
for him it may not lead to an advantage
and that could be a bit disappointing
but especially after yesterday's long
game then he would like to just make
sure that everything is fine in his
position so we have all seven uh boards
in front of us we can see that in the
top left Magnus Carlson and ding Loren
much has changed there we haven't looked
at the top right games in gukesh and
abusatara but really it's a locked
position so when things open up a little
bit more maybe we should head into that
one I'm looking at the bottom right and
the pawn was just taking on D5 but the
pawn structure is such that uh Prague
has all these light Square pawns against
B7 looks uh pretty nice for him and well
I think we have to go to Magnus versus
ding we haven't been there in a long
time and the position really is a lot
different than when we were looking at
it earlier
let's definitely get a check in on that
also let's point out that currently uh
Jordan is sacrificing a piece on e4 but
we will come to that once we're done
with this one wow that's a complete
structural change from the London that
we started with let's back up a few
moves Robert from when we visited this
game last and go through it yeah we saw
an offer of a trade for the dark Square
Bishops Bishop B5 check Magnus actually
really likes these lines we're taking on
C6 so he does it immediately not even
provoked to do so and he quickly trades
and plays Queen A4 if black is not
careful Queen A3 could be very annoying
in some variations but after black
castles here if you try Queen A3 the
Knight can help defend this Pawn 94
Knight D7 more likely Knight D7 to keep
the pawn safe and then uh black will
just work around it so castles you see a
swap and then C5 so the move Queen A3 it
does pin the pawn but it doesn't win the
pawn as I was mentioning Knight E4 not
only Elite protects the pawn it protects
the queen which opens up C takes D4 as
Black's next move so Magnus instead of
Rook C1 anticipating that this file
would open up and we just see this
position here after a swap on B3 so
Tanya we see the evaluation is level
white has C file for now but I think the
biggest Dynamic is Knight against Bishop
so would you actually prefer Magnus
position here or do you see it like the
engine does as being completely equal
I think black's got his own trumps here
ding's got a lot to play for as well yes
you've got the C file and currently a
nicely placed Queen on A5 the open a
file as well you've got a weakness on A7
but you also have a weak B3 pawn and
black can with the Rook on f8 slide down
to be it start putting pressure on this
Pawn as well at the knight from F6 can
jump to E4 a nice little post there
I get it that white does have things
working out but I don't think black's
worse I understand our evaluation bars
saying this is even and I think the big
reason for that is the weakness on B3
Robert I also want to point that one
very important moment when black played
C5 if we just back up a little bit
because I think that's so crucial to
understand that this move is perfectly
timed black can't waste another move
here give white one move white goes Rook
from F1 to C1 and you'll never get this
break you're stuck with a weak backwards
C6 Pawn Knight jumps to E5 and it would
be strategically lost already with the
control on the C5 Square so in fact
doing understanding that he plays the
move C5 it had to be played and
voluntarily went into this position that
gives up the C file but in return what
you get is a weakness on B3 and I'm
going to add one more thing to your
excellent point there that if black had
taken on D4 when white captures back on
D4 maybe with the queen we get a two on
one outside Advantage for white now that
the position is advantageous but in the
long term it's like in the grunfels
oftentimes black wants to get to the end
game because you create an outside pass
Pawn that's why ding chose to play C4
here that now you have two against two
on the queen side and if the Rook wants
an open line you have to play B3 so we
did see this trade on B3 after black in
the tempo with Bishop to D7 uh one thing
I'll note is that when this Knight goes
to D2 it protects the pawn on B3 and
it's hard for black to pile up pressure
on that pawn so the position is equal we
acknowledge that I'm sure ding knows
that but I just feel like it's slightly
more comfortable because one mistake you
could make is black is let's say we get
this position with Knight to D2 where
the pawn is very well defended and
you're saying I really want to get to
that pawn how am I going to do it your
Bishop can't that's the big problem is
the bishop is kind of a bystander in
this position it's not effective in the
slightest it's behind its own Pawn it's
staring into empty space this Rook would
like to slam on C7 or on C5 this Knight
comes in E5 black is doing okay and ding
will know that but he might also feel a
little bit uncomfortable because this is
the most Magnus type of position ever
with the white pieces no risk whatsoever
and a weakness that you can go after and
a weakness on your end that's quite easy
to defend
very nicely said actually that after
Knight D2 yes B3 is a glaring weakness
in White's cam but it's super hard for
black to get to Meanwhile white already
has control of the two open files even
though even and black should be fine
here it's definitely more pleasant to
play as white and I'm just wondering
with all these points can black can ding
in this position try and take advantage
of well White's slightly weakening with
all the pieces on the queen side and
let's say I offer a trade here I start
with a rook to see eight Robert because
I'm super happy if you go Rook see it
Rook see it and I'm super duper happy if
after that you take on A7
nicely point out the white king is in a
bit of danger so if you take on A7 you
fall victim to back rank Checkmate you
don't want to see any part of that and
if you play Rook C8 uh to start with I
don't think white really wants to give
up the C file Knight B2 is an option and
also Knight C3 isn't entirely out of the
question there's a second Knight that
can come back to D2 if that pawn needs
defending and if you ever move your Rook
to B8 the a rook A7 is loose and if you
move this Rook to be able you just
stopped on C8 and move it over which
sometimes you actually want to do
because now this Knight can't get back
to where we were just talking about so
there are pros and cons to this wasting
a Tempo methodology but regardless I do
believe that it's easier position for
magnets to play I'm not saying he's
winning nothing of that sort I just feel
like the a pawn is stuck in its tracks
the beat Pawn maybe at some point could
even start pushing up the board if we
look at the current position White's
next move might be B4 some point play
Rook C5 and just take over all the
squares in the queen side it's not out
of the question if this Knight is on D2
especially so I prefer white it's not
winning nobody's claiming that but in
order to beat players like dingly Ren
you don't just get winning positions out
of thin air you need to maximize the
potential of your position you to create
the most amount of challenges possible
and I think the real challenge for ding
is he has the worst piece on the board
this light Square bishop and it doesn't
have activity and there's nowhere really
to go to where would you put this bishop
on e4 why because you might want to take
a knight your inner Bishop can't get
there it's blocked in by its own Pawn
whereas this Knight has a dark Square
this Knight has a dark Square that's a
light Square Bishop being dominated by
the knights
you know I get it you're being super uh
you you're being slightly not super but
slightly pessimistic about ding's
position and rightfully so but I still
think Robert that it's he's gonna find a
way this is world number one versus
World number two ding is not gonna make
this very easy and I see that in chat it
says welcome to the London system very
well said because very often you think
the London that that can't be too too
difficult that can't be too dangerous
for you and then suddenly uh things can
become a little iffy and before you know
it you can be completely strategically
worse Robert I still feel that Ding has
his own uh his own ideas in this
position the more I look at it the more
I like the concept of offering a trade
forcing your knight to C3 and just
compare the lines that we've been
looking at Rook to see it Knight C3 you
get the other Rook to be it because I
really don't want to allow you to play
B4 you can't take on A7 because I can
take on B3 so I'm kind of a happy camper
your idea of getting the other night to
defend Knight D2 now you're trying to
pick up the A7 Pawn I put my Rook to B7
I prefer that than putting my Rook to C7
let's say I put my Rook to B7 and if you
just compare this position from the
other lines that we're seeing I think
black has made progress I attack your
beep on I'm challenging you on the C
file your Knights are not jumping and
that bad Bishop on D7 a bad piece is
often a good Defender you were saying
where do you put it nowhere right now
but the good news is it stops Knight B5
it's doing it's doing something in the
position yes and something is more than
nothing I admit that but another thing
you've done is you've dragged my good
night back to D2 I would want my name E5
that's an advanced Square it's also
clogging black uh pieces and where they
can look to so you're absolutely right
they're dragging the knight from B1 to
C3 and the F3 Knight to D2 that does
seem like a better uh set of
circumstances for black and I wonder
after Rook C8 if then Knight D2 is still
the move uh that way if you take on C1 I
have the open file and my queen is
better placed in the queen on D6 Queen
96 is defensive the queen on A5 is
active this doesn't mean that white is
better we are not saying that I just
don't want to reiterate that that
neither of us are saying that white is
winning nothing of the sword but if you
had to choose which side you'd rather
play with I think that every player in
this tournament would say yeah give me
the white pieces here just because black
is a little bit more passive with this
light Square Bishop but I'm totally With
You dingley Ren he is more than capable
of holding this I just have seen Magnus
win positions like this so many times
and he did go Rook F to B8 and so I
believe Knight B1 to D2 is automatic
couldn't agree more with you on that
Rook B8 is the decision taken definitely
more pleasant with white Camden find his
own activity he'll have to really put up
a big play to be able to do that against
somebody like Magnus with this A7
weakness Knight D2 is what we're
expecting should we just for a moment
zoom out while Magnus has a thing about
how he wants to defend B3 let's get the
bird's eye view on our ongoing games
once again I just cannot stop looking at
the bottom left second board here Fabi
taking on Jordan and what a crazy
opening this has been currently on the
board the Knight on e4 is attacked
refusing to move and that is an exciting
middle game right next to that we've got
Parham against the niche nothing's
happened since we left it Bishop on D7
so trade has happened black is probably
thinking do you want to have an
Intermezzo with Knight takes F3 and he
replies yes he does he picks up the
night trades of as many pieces as
possible makes a lot of sense yeah and
he keeps the Queens on the board did any
scary so uh he probably is trying to win
this game with the black pieces and I
think he has a good opportunity not this
position is better but at least it's
double edge and that gives him his
chances but I think we have to go to the
game between five and a carwana and
Jordan run for us because what looked
like a pretty tame position the Knight
on e4 the latest move that Jordan played
G5 he is showing absolutely no fear
whatsoever throwing his pawns forward
first the F Pawn now the g-pawn he's
clearly attacking this bishop 104 and
Fabiano by the way was not fooled after
Castle's King side he didn't take this
Knight he understood that the sequence
we were looking at is just going to be
good for black because of the activity
and the open f file and the second Rook
replacing the first so instead he went
Bishop F4 developing and Jordan said
okay take my knight now the D4 Pawn is
loose with check B2 would fall next
Bobby plays the com C3 and this move is
anything but come G5 slammed on the
board and he is going full steam ahead
Tanya he wants all of the activity in
the position
this is absolutely insane I mean it's a
clear example of offense is the best
defense and neither of the players want
to back down with their pieces they
don't want to retreat that someone has
got to give at some point and we see the
last move G5 hitting that Bishop on F4
and the ball is in fabi's court do you
go Bishop E5 do you try to trade off the
dark Squad Bishop because I still don't
believe that you can take the Knight on
e4 after F takes E4 black can think
about not capturing on F4 but in fact
first perhaps picking up the E4 Pawn F
takes E4 feels uh really attractive here
because after Bishop B5 you hit my queen
but the idea that we've been looking at
C6 attacking that Bishop attacking that
Bishop on F4 and you will end up winning
the piece back I like this position for
black
it looks really good when G5 is the move
you can successfully play and White's
best is to move this bishop probably to
E5 but if this bishop goes to E5 now
you're not so concerned about your G5
pawn and the E file might just close
down this queen on E2 was really nice if
the file would open now it's closed and
we have an asymmetrical Pawn structure
this Knight doesn't have F6 or D6 to go
to with that pawn on D4 was taking away
the C5 Square I'll go back to C5 put
pressure on your Bishop my pawns on the
king side are safe and this bishop is
blockading the Pawn on E6 so it can't
push that pass Pawn I actually really
like the look of Black's position you're
very active over here and not that white
is in trouble and I think we're gonna
say this time and time again as we look
from position to position the eval bar
states that it's about level that it's
you know everything is okay but these
top players they don't win just because
um their opponent blunder is a queen
they win because they put pressure on
their opponent the the situations on
uncomfortable and they're able to deal
with the complications better and I
think Bobby he doesn't mind a position
like this but Jordan clearly was aiming
for it from the start this was his
preparation and it's worked out well for
him this is definitely a more Jordan
kind of position than it is a Fabby
position especially after G5 you've
opened up the king's side you're asking
questions to write and uncomfortable
questions to answer really the bishop on
F4 hanging this line that you mentioned
after Bishop E5 I think Bishop E5 is the
most natural response you want to try to
trade off the dark Squad Bishop so that
somewhere in the future you can hope and
dream to take advantage of this over
ambitious G5 Push by weakening the king
side further but then after that you do
allow black to jump in with Knight C5
not just that if you just go to that
position Bishop E5 you trade on E5
Knight comes to C5 why white has to save
the bishop and black also has another
devious idea yes you want to put your
Rook from A8 to E8 Target the E5 Pawn
but Robert there's a D4 in the air as
well really opening up the position and
causing big questions big trouble for
white hair maybe in this particular
position I see our eval bar state that
D4 maybe not now but this is something
white always has to watch out for and I
agree with you that Jordan's Dynamic
play and these practical decisions uh
seem like they're paying off right now
certainly and fabi's never been able to
get settled into the position he hasn't
found that comfort zone like Magnus has
where you can safely play for an
advantage without any risk this position
does have inherent risk for both sides
black may be in danger of overextending
the king could become unsafe later this
Pawn on G5 could be a Target but for now
controls many of the important Central
squares and we talked about when their
pawns two squares apart it's the square
in between that your opponent can
usually take advantage of here if we
take in a Pawns in E5 no piece is taking
advantage of that square there's a pawn
that's going to sit there and May in
fact become a Target later as it is
overextended itself so I think we can
safely zoom out as Fabi is figure out
where to put his Bishop uh why don't we
at long last you know tune in to the
game between cash and Abdus Atara
because those two players uh they have
uh exited the opening and the latest
decisions that have been played with a
finally upon capture on D5 I think it's
worth checking out the current state of
affairs there because I believe
abdusitarov with the black pieces he
doesn't just want a balanced position he
decide after his move cd5 to take with
the Knight he just took the Knight on D5
hitting the queen and the queen A3
player so Tanya what do you make of this
potential Queen trade here
for me what's also really interesting is
that the move Queen A3 actually allows
black to double a white spawns after you
take on E5 so black does have the option
to actually First Trade on E5 say that
you go you can even start with Queen A3
let's say you take Knight E5 D takes E5
and now white Forever has got the spawn
structure where essentially you're
playing an end game a pawn down you got
three versus two on the queen side black
has a clear Pawn on the queen side a
meanwhile decide where white should be
having a majority you've got a double
Pawn taking care so four pawns are
actually handling Five Pawns beautifully
and for me that just feels as if black
is should at least be fine in this
position what does white have in return
is that the bishop on G2 is better than
the bishop and B7 and this glaring
weakness on D6 imagine a scenario a
White's Knight lands up from C4 to D6
that would be a very difficult situation
for black and if you have to make make a
move like B5 to stop Knight C4 you're
creating massive weaknesses that C6 Pawn
is hideous The Rook from C1 can jump to
C5 the Knight can go Knight C2 Knight D4
double up on the C line and uh I think
the more I look into the position the
more I understand why white is willing
to take these double Pawns
for sure and B5 would just be a head
scratcher removed the bishop on B7 is
relegated it's looking like a pawn we
did just see the move Knight takes E5
happen and queen takes E7 there is a
knight on D5 that can take back and what
black is aiming for in that situation is
that he's first to the open file and a
rook on d8 whether it's the F or the a
rook I'm moving the F Rook just so I can
bring the a rook to C C8 if needed but
if this Knight moves now there could be
a rook D2 slammed on the board hitting
the E2 pawn and the B2 Pawn so black
gets the activity first because white
lacks in development so after Knight
takes E5 which has just happened I think
that you can just take back with the
pawn potentially certain end games you
um oh he takes an E7 as soon as I said
that but he's taken here I just feel
like certain end games you're right
Tanya that the E5 Pawn can become a bit
of a problem for white you have to play
F4 but that's time consuming and black
is essentially up a pawn in the position
on the queen side whereas White's extra
Pawn isn't really extra because it's
double it's hard to create past pawns
when your pawns are doubled
exactly and I like the way that black
has chosen the precise move order
because Robert let's just show the
difference between uh the natural
looking Queen A3 the line that we were
looking at you might think that your
knight is on D5 instead of capturing on
E5 if black would go Queen A3 but in
fact you're helping white to develop his
own Knight and allow it to come to C4
just in time the line that we looked at
but the move order chosen by not a bag
just shows how focused he is and how
precise he's being he says I'm okay with
retreating my knight to E7 but more
importantly you're still not developed
I'm the first to the D file and at some
point black can a dream of putting
pressure on E5 the double Pawn with
Knight G6 if required the knight from E7
can even jump to F5 go to D4 defend D6
so it's actually a better place Knight
on E7 and white just doesn't seem like
he's got enough time to put that Knight
to D6
and one more thing I'll add to that
great explanation is that in some
positions white would actually think
about taking this Knight on D5 so if we
go to uh the position where you take on
A3 first Knight takes back Knight E5
Pawn takes there's a universe where you
take on D5 because the dark squares are
Black's problems that's a light Square
Bishop it won't be able to protect the
squares like that Knight on E7 as you
were just highlighting you can go to F5
to cover weak dark squares so that's
just something to keep in mind that
there are some positions where you do
give up the bishop for the Knight and
it's going to be interesting to see how
no dear Beck handles this he is down on
the clock you spend a bit more time than
Gucci has good cash with this thorn of a
pawn that's gonna bother black for a
while and you see him he's settled into
this game he feels he looks more
confident than somebody with zero out of
two but I think he understands his
position has promised if he could
reroute his Knight to that D6 Square
it's not an easy way to get there
especially with the way black has
handled the position the past few moves
we can see quite a few Spectators that
looking at the masters section also the
challenges being played right there the
same stage a Robert which is always
really nice to see there are so many
stories out of this playing Arena this
playing Hall players who are currently
right now playing in the Masters started
with uh their chess journey in the
amateur section Jordan van first we've
been talking about him his attacking
style his game currently against uh
against Fabiano caruana he started when
he was a kid playing the amateur section
dreaming one day of getting through the
Masters and not only did he get there he
actually went on to win it what makes
this event so exciting and so different
so unique is the mix of players that
we've got here you know you've got all
your a-listers you got the established
Elite but very often for a long time in
the Chess World we saw the big events
only ever invite the established players
but now that phenomena has changed now
we've got the rising stars the big
talents the big prodigies of the world
fighting alongside trying to prove they
belong there and we've got five
participants in the Tata steel Masters
who are under 20 years of age we've got
gokish Arjun not a back Vincent kaimer
pragnananda they're all between 16 and
19 and of course Jordan van forest and
Parham as well Parham is all of 22.
Jordan I think is 23 years old and these
are the players who are the future
Champions the future world champions
they've been they've really been shaking
up the Chess World over the last year
they certainly haven't there's also the
older guard the established players that
you're talking about who are in this
tournament they don't want to be
forgotten about so they are the former
champions of this event or in the case
of Magnus Carlson the reigning Champion
he won in 2022 he just won the World
Championship in all formats and besides
him there are all these great players
levana rowing has won the set four times
don't be misled by his 27-35 rating at
the moment he had a tough 2022 over the
board he lost so many rating points
including at the Olympiad in Chennai
where he was unwell for quite a stretch
of it so you'll see there you have four
champions in Viking Zay Carlson carwana
so and aronian and then Richard report
and East Geary ding Lorenz like don't
forget about us things like I'm the
number two player in the world and
anisha's saying I've been the runner-up
five different times I know that's not
first place but getting second place
here is very difficult we can't forget
that in the year that Fabiano I want to
played for the world championship 2018 I
think he had a big minus score in
Vikings they hit a terrible performance
and then he uh struck gold you know
throughout the year and was winning kind
of every single event so uh there have
been ups and downs but for Anish it
seems like all UPS in Viking Zay and we
were looking at his game earlier he
plays that energetic style I really
think something about this turn brings
the best out of certain players and
definitely that is true for Anish giri
100 and it's also the atmosphere Anish
is also the ambassador of the Tata steel
Masters he loves playing there he's
played there I I think he's played there
19 times already and Anish is 29 years
old uh correct me Robert if I've got
that stat wrong but yes he's played that
several times it's a bit heartbreaking
for him that he's come so close but yet
not had that championship and he's
played two playoffs for that first place
where he lost to Fabiano caruana he lost
uh to Jordan van forest in those
playoffs so it's been a bit of a
heartbreak as well but he's had solid
performances the way he started this
event showing that he's ready for the
fight he's ready for combative play he's
definitely looking for that uh
Championship that's been eluding him
through his journey in tata Steel
you know you said to correct you if
you're wrong the only thing I was going
to say is don't age the guy you said he
was 29 he's 28. come on let him be young
for a day here but that smile on his
face is one that we see very often in
Vikings a the five-time runner-up he has
suffered a heartbreak when he lost the
playoff to Jordan Von Forest the Dutch
faithful was guaranteed a champion it
was going to be Jordan or a niche it was
going to be the established Superstar or
the rising talent and at that point in
time in that Armageddon scramble it was
up in the air and Jordan was able to was
able to come away with it and for Anish
you know that's going to be
disappointing but he also has a lot to
look back on fondly he has performed
very well and I brought his game up here
because I think he's playing an inspired
tournament his Pawn is up on G5 his
Bishop's over here on A7 just lurking
waiting for its chance to attack at the
moment he can play this move Queen F6
offering a queen trade I do think the
Queens could come off and black will not
be worse in that end ending but I'm also
wondering if he can try to figure out a
way to get even more aggressive with the
Queens on the board I don't quite think
so and at the end of the day at the end
of the round a draw with the black
pieces a solid draw if he's able to
accomplish that he's not going to be
upset that's a good result against
paramaksudu
I agree with you especially the kind of
farm that Parham has been showing in the
events so far some great resistance
there by Parham in round one against
Winston in a difficult position and then
going on to save another difficult game
a marathon one against a dingler in
yesterday so farham is definitely ready
for a long long fight also just
objectively looking at the position
inspired played by Anish and beautiful
storyline there with Anish and Jordan
both starting their wike Journey you
know with different tournaments starting
to play as kids in the amateurs and
moving on to the challenges the C group
and then finally Landing up and playing
several times in the Masters it's truly
a growth in their chess career that this
platform has shown coming to the
position Robert if you look at it from
an objective point of view as well Anish
has done all that he could and gotten a
dream position out of the Italian yeah
Bishop on A7 is Super Active you've
gotten rid of White's uh strong minor
pieces but you still have to watch out
give white a little time and if white
can do can make it imagine if White's
Knight lands on F5 that would be a
disaster for a niche you know Knight C4
Knight E3 Knight F5 uh it is on root so
black needs to be a little careful black
can't get super ambitious I think there
are no troubles for black hair for sure
but it's time to now just make sure that
this over ambitious play with 86 G5
doesn't get punished because you have
created some weaknesses I like your idea
of Queen F6 the other move that comes to
my mind is that black can think about
getting his own Knight to E6 Knight F6
or Knight C5 trying to get it to E6 but
then you have to really calculate moves
like E5 imagine if the bishop on G3
comes into play let's just make it on
the board let's play Knight C5 here
and then suddenly white could go E5 hit
that pawn on B7 so you can't move the
Knight anywhere but most importantly if
you take on E5 the bishop coming to E5
this would be bad news Rook coming to D1
as well oh this is a blunder because of
Knight D3 I see now
uh Rook D1 first is first this is the
problem with the engine eval bars I'm
just trying to show your point and then
it turns into the blunder so we have to
say throw in Rook D1 first with Tempo
and then Tanya's Bishop takes E5 this
king is doing terribly
so you might just have to bail out with
the queen trade I like it but Anish he's
trying to think if he can complicate the
situation further but I think it's time
to just admit that you've done the most
you could out of the opening and offer
trades go into an equal end game
I agree so we'll see what Niche Geary
will do here he's spending his time he's
done that very well throughout the event
and we still have all seven games in
progress uh somehow in the second from
the left down below 500 carwana has
established that Bishop on E5 Jordan did
not take it so that remains a
fascinating struggle between those two
uh Magnus Carlsen top left against
England the Queens are off and so it
might just be an end game where there
isn't much left to grind and they might
split the point uh in the top right and
the bottom right we see the youngsters
really going giving it their all the top
rights and end game the bottom right is
a king on F2 so when we get back from
our break we'll dive into prognanda
versus kymer but before we head to break
I want to announce that the pro chess
league is back after a two-year Hiatus
the protest league is coming back at the
2023 season begins with a qualifier week
starting February 1st with 16 teams
advancing into the main season pass PCL
participants include Magnus ding nepo
Fabi Hikaru and VL and Anish so we could
not be more excited for the League's
return and with over 100 000 on the line
it's looking like a 2023 season the one
for the history books use the command PC
on chat to learn all about it for now we
head to a break and win return it's more
from Tata steel chess 2023
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kit
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
fifty thousand chest puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Hall in Vikings day we see Wesley so
calculating at the board here and Tanya
it was an interesting opening in this
one against Richard report because he
played the caracon he doesn't play the
carocon and yet he was forced into it
via transposition so in the current
state he is on the move he is trying to
work it out and we can pull up a board
to show you what is happening there
because it looks very awkward we have
two sets of double isolated pawns but if
we do a quick count Tanya white still is
upon ahead
you were mentioning the karakan Robert
something that Wesley was not expecting
but he has handled it pretty well and
we've got this position I mean he's a
world-class player give him any position
and he'll handle it well uh you're
absolutely right it's not the kind of
structures that you get to see every day
white has an extra Pawn but a set of two
double pawns but meanwhile hasn't
castled and I see that he just made the
move finishing the development going
short Castle you know these two double
pawns they are not really a big weakness
on the other hand because they control
so many squares as well Robert making it
difficult for blacks pieces to get
active that knight from A6 it's not
really going anywhere you've got to go
Knight C7 and hope to get B6 one day and
pick up the D5 Pawn but white will
meanwhile have time to push out that
knight from G4 as well this is a very
double edged middle I'm calling it
middle game because yes Queens are
traded but that's pretty much it pawns
are on the board a lot of pieces on the
boat both sets of Rooks on the board
this is everything to play for I see our
eval bar despite the horrible Pawn
structure I like white hair
it's an extra Pawn so you know yasu
sarawan where he's watching this game
he'll be very happy with the extra Pawn
but he loves the karakan so his
loyalties will be split but white
remains a pawn ahead for the time being
the pawn on D5 now is under attack
because the Knight and F6 came back but
you have two Defenders knight on C3 and
The Rook on A5 they're doing the task of
protecting this Pawn on D5 so what's
next Knight C7 is likely Black's next
move so white needs to keep that in mind
and you can play Bishop F4 but then you
need to remember there's also Knight B4
the Knight what's A6 it can also hop
forward so Tanya the big question is
will black be able to win this Pawn back
and if you're going to get that pawn no
matter what should white jettison in a
way for example Bishop F4 Knight B4
there's the opportunity to play the move
D6 that way lacks Pawn structure also
gets a bit compromised
I like what you're saying you know you
have to give up the pawn you give it up
in the best case scenario by creating a
weakness for your opponent also in the
process blocking the D file so that the
default Pawn isn't a weakness anymore
and now ideas like Rook B5 come to mind
hitting that Knight on V4 hitting that
pawn on B7 so definitely white has got
stuff to play for with this move D6
that's a nice spot Robert and I think
that is what Richard is going to go for
because look at the alternative let's
say you give up the pawn on D5 and this
is how you can come to this conclusion
via elimination if black snide lands up
on D5 and picks the pawn black pretty
much controls the game it's a beautiful
spot on D5 you still have the double
pawns on the B file D4 is a weakness a
real weakness now because the D file is
open your Bishop on F4 hangs problems
everywhere I like to move D6 and I think
that's what we're gonna see on the board
yeah D6 is played in earlier lines uh
with Queens on the board so it's a known
idea and I think Richard he is likely
going to try to do something like that
but it's important what you pointed out
the night before can always be met by
Rook to B5 so perhaps that's not a
threat at the moment but after Bishop
Ford Knight before as you also
highlighted once the Knight takes on D5
the Fisher on F4 is loose so all these
points are important uh Richard's
position according to the Evo are
slightly better for him he is upon the
head but he needs to figure out a way
that continues to challenge Wesley you
know if he's going to get the material
back it'll come at a cost uh if he
remains a pawn down West he's going to
struggle because he doesn't have the
activity he would like the pawn on D5 is
in the Rooks way both pawns are
healthfully defended for the time being
even though they're doubled and I said I
love The Rook on A5 that was a really
good moment that was played here by
Richard he brought that Rook up to the
defense and then Wesley said I need to
get rid of this bishop F3 it's too
strong and the bishop won't say it
didn't have good Avenues to work with B6
looks very tempting attacking The Rook I
just want to show that once The Rook
moves back anywhere let's say A4 if you
think you're playing Bishop B7 well D6
often happens here your Rook 996 is
loose the bishop trade is offered the
attack on E7 so Black's pieces are kind
of overloaded in this type of position
and Wesley is definitely thinking about
all these subtleties he did navigate
correctly I think both players have
played Super accurately so far uh you
know Wesley sacrificing that pawn early
on he gave it up now he's trying to
regain it but in that momentum gets a
little bit of development gets these
ideas of jumping with that Knight to B4
C7 nicely handled by black white still
has that pull till the extra Pawn is
alive and Richard needs to find the best
way to give it back that gives him
maximum benefits in return you can see
Wesley on our screen he looks cool he
looks calm composed and not much to
worry about so I think he is feeling
like he's got things under control while
uh Richard just there coming back to the
board with a drink in his hand and we
see that Wesley in fact has made a move
and it's richer to play Robert what did
Wesley go for
oh he brought the Knight back to F6 and
then we uh Richard just was away from
the board so we were talking about it
for a while you know forget uh who moves
when but Richard you know he's going to
be back at it so let's uh go to our you
know seven board view we can look at all
games at once while Richard figures it
out I I think we have to go to the game
on the bottom right the game uh between
pragnananda and Vincent kymer because
there's a king on F2 while black king is
safely tucked away and castled and yet
the eval bar is crept up in White's
favor that may be shocking to many
people so we're gonna Dive Right In Here
as the king that is uncastled is
actually quite safe for the time being
now the first thing I wanted to point
out is that it's easy to blunder when
your king is out in the open it's
defended for now by this one little Pawn
covering all sorts of night jumps but if
you made like Bishop E3 you'll already
see the eval plummet because Knight G4
is check and it opens up in attack on
the bishop so just watch out even the
one little Pond covers important squares
and limits the movement of the knights
that there could be a sacrifice just to
open up this King and go for an attack
in this case winning material
white definitely has to be careful about
these tricks with Knight G4 and it needs
to finish development what surprises me
at first is that despite the King on F2
and white having this slow development
blacks finished everything you know
taken out the night night is nicely
placed on E5 it is still giving a big
advantage to White well a big Advantage
at least a sizable advantage and I think
the reason for that is that white
strategically is stronger here you've
got more space the bishop on B7 is a
dead Bishop so far as long as the pawn
is on D5 even if the bishop came back to
see it one it comes in the way of your
own pieces second what's the future it's
not getting to F5 it's not getting to G4
so really it's not going anywhere the
King on F2 you nicely pointed out that
it is in the center but it hasn't
castled but it's completely safe and the
reason for that is that there are no
dark squared Bishop there isn't a dark
squared Bishop that black has currently
the position would be totally different
imagine a fiance Channel Bishop on G7
that would change everything for black
but it's not the case and I like this
move by Prague he continues to develop
and he also takes control of the G4
square that was so vulnerable that he
were pointing out with that tactical
line next he wants to bring the Rook
into the game he will slowly bring out
the light Squad Bishop meanwhile black
just doesn't have enough space to move
around with the pieces to create a
counter attack the only open file is the
e-file and very very often in such
positions we'll see white simply go
rookie one take out the dark Squad
Bishop maybe sometimes even do
artificial castling the king from F2 can
always come back to G1 you have all the
time in the world black has no breaks
meanwhile white with the space Advantage
double Bishop just has a long term Edge
which is why it's so important for black
to try and do something immediately and
Vincent doesn't shy away from that no he
does not he plays B5 and now it's
something important to note is what
Tanya was highlighting the bishop mb7 is
a bad piece so long as this opponent is
on D5 if you decide to take on B5 with
either Pawn that will be a mistake a
takes B5 a takes B5 you're opening up
some lines for black The Rook can either
trade or be defended but once this queen
gets to eight we see that it can Venture
even down to A2 and while the evaluation
is still in White's favor Black gets the
play that he needs so what I prefer in
this position is to keep as many lines
as possible closed with a move of Pawn
to B3 if Pawn takes C4 you take back
with the pawn you make sure your Pawn D5
is defended by another pawn and if black
ever made the mistake upon them before
you see the evaluation going really high
up for white this is a losing strategic
decision because white simply moves the
queen away back to anywhere I don't
think it matters so much and then you
bring your Bishop out to B2 and do
exactly what Tanya was saying bring a
rook to E1 and strategically white is
dominating because black can't open up
lines for his pieces in fact Irwin me
made a mistake like this yesterday
against Elaine robbers in the Challenger
section where he closed the queen side
and then she had a free hand on the king
side and she played an excellent
attacking game and won that one so this
would be a strategically horrible
decision from black Vince is not playing
Beast five to play B4 he doesn't have a
pass Pawn he's not getting a new Queen
he wants at some point to open up some
lines on the queen side for counter play
that was indeed a brilliantly played
game by Alina and definitely if you guys
haven't checked it out go look at it it
is a master class on how to conduct an
attack when your opponent closes the
game on the side in which they have play
and I think that is a key point in this
one as you're pointing out B3 makes so
much sense Robert and I think it's
better to play it now than after picking
up the B5 Pawn with the a pawn not even
allowing activity on the a file with
Once B3 is played what Vincent wants to
do is open up the B file so perhaps take
on C4 because if you take B takes A4 it
gives white the additional option to
take with the Rook open the a file
challenge the A6 Pawn you don't want to
allow this additional stuff when you got
the option to take on C4 with the pawn
and I think we've got a decision here
we've got to move by Winston he
definitely hasn't gone for
he's duck on for B4 has he made a move
yet no it was uh probably who uh we
after B5 played the move B3
um sorry we've got B3 already and
Vincent has to take a decision and I was
just gonna say he's going to pick up the
C4 Pawn eventually fall back with the
bishop to see it put your Rook on be it
put your queen on B6 and the B file is
where you find your counter play because
again he can't just give white a free
hand
no it cannot in fact you can start with
Rook B8 just to be a little cheeky here
because white can't capture twice on B5
normally you say well I can just take a
bunch of times but we keep talking about
this D5 Pawn I'm just gonna make the
move just so you see what happens to
evaluation it's immediately much better
for black you take this Pawn on D5 it
opens up the entire board for your piece
the bishop is better because it's not
staring into a pawn the Knight is good
it's attacking the Queen the queen is
better you can go to H4 so taking on B5
with a C4 Pawn is out of the question
and so Rook B8 it kind of keeps the
tension for a moment longer I don't
think black is worried about this trade
although having a newly controlled a
file could be to White's benefit in some
positions but the more that side of the
board opens up the happier black is so
Vincent he is probably going to take on
C4 at some point you can do it
immediately but I think keeping the
tension for a moment longer might also
make sense that way white doesn't have
this Rook B1 move because you're staring
into your own Pawn that might actually
just be a little bit dubious
nicely pointed out that's quite an
important idea that white will not be
able to challenge the B file if Winston
decides to keep the tension on we'll
come back and take a look about how
Vincent ends up handling this tension on
the queen side let's take an overview of
our games as the action continues all
around in the third round of the Tata
steel Masters and of course on our
bottom left we've got Parham against
Anish and as you were discussing Anish
did decide to trade off Queens so that
was a very pragmatic decision by Anish
and I think the right one we also see
just next to that are eval bar loving
fabi's position which Robert to me is a
big surprise because we were all praised
for the way Jordan had handled the
opening and we thought Fabi is the one
who's got to be careful what happened
there well that one is getting out of
control and what you might just want to
point out quickly because it might be
the last time we talked about it is the
game between Magnus and dingley ren it's
an end game it's completely even
material it's two knights and four pawns
against night bishop and four pawns it's
heading to a draw so dingley Ren said
Robert you don't know what you're
talking about I have no issues
whatsoever and we may actually see a
handshake any moment now because pawns
are all on the same side of the board no
pass pawns a symmetrical Pawn structure
on the same lines as one another and you
look on magnus's face kind of says it
all like okay ding there's nothing
happening we'll probably just make a
draw but Magnus he's not really one to
offer that draw he kind of you know lets
the game continue as long as possible
but even the move G6 there's no past
Pawn to create for White and the Knight
can get the F6 Square just doesn't
actually threaten anything
very interesting actually this whole
middle game that we had we felt that
Magnus had his chances but again this is
the El Clasico match of Chess so of
course the world number two is up to put
up the fight that we expect from the two
players and we see that this end game
has been reached I don't think either of
the players are going to be too
disappointed with the draw Magnus also
knows he's playing against someone he
has so much respect for and I see that
they might even just repeat the position
right now Robert as we speak so a nice
call out by you to go to this action
Knight H5 hitting that G7 pawn and uh
Magnus not shying away or trying
anything excessive with pawns on the
same side ding will now come back with
the King again to f8 defend that pawn
not give that F6 Square not give any
unnecessary play and this is going to be
handshakes
I think
I think ding is just looking making sure
that Magnus isn't going to change
anything but the look on magnus's face
says it all he's like all right make
your move we could shake the hands sign
the score sheets this game is a draw but
you know you don't trust your opponent
you have to trust your own calculation
and this position is particularly easy
they're not too many pieces remaining
and there it goes dang back to f8 so I
believe after the next move Knight back
to F4 uh the players will have reached
the position uh
for a third time so you know they don't
even need to call the Arbiter I know it
when you're growing as a chess player
and you're young they say pause the
clock go the Arbiter they'll just say
yeah you want to draw let's do it
they've reached past move 30 no draws
are allowed before move 30 and in
general the organizers appreciate the
fighting Spirit we talked about this
yesterday how the uh prizes are really
appearance fee so for winning third
place you're not there's not a prize
attached to it they're paid in advance
and the organizer always pick players
who are trying to fight for their wins
and this game just happens to have been
level throughout I see Mustafa yamaz in
the background there walking and the
draw is agreed Magnus Smiles England
puts up great defense and the point is
split
Magnus made that move and didn't even
bother writing he just looked up at Ding
and said you know this is a joy and then
ding just uh agreed handshakes there uh
and there they analyzed a little bit
Magnus probably feels that he had a
little bit of a pull in this game but
wasn't really able to break through
things defenses
a pretty even game from start to finish
no big fireworks in this one I did have
a go through with it and maybe Robert I
was thinking we can just uh quickly just
do a play-by-play of it because it was
nice to see how ding managed that little
pull that little pressure that Magnus
had out of the opening yeah we left off
here we said Knight D2 and the Eva bar
does say white is slightly better ever
so slightly better but look at this Rook
B5 hitting the queen and Max brings the
queen to C7 and this was the Excellent
Choice by ding Queen 67 would be an
inaccuracy you see the eval bar creeping
up because the Rook takes on C7 this
Pawn on A7 is threatened this Knight's
hopping into E5 hitting the bishop and
the pawn here white is very active so
instead I think this is a beautiful move
by ding Loren night Retreats are often
the hardest to find in chess dig the red
founded Tanya and I don't think he had
difficulty after it
and the best part about this night on
here is that once the queen Queens get
traded which is what happens the Knight
is on B6 which is a much nicer spot than
it was on F6 white jumps in with a Nike
E5 the bishop retreated and just the
next couple of moves being liquefied the
queen side with A5 and A4 once the pawns
were gone from there there was no
pressure at all and just a nicely played
End Game nice technique thereby ding to
just make sure that he's not in trouble
at any point uh the pawns got traded the
Rooks got traded and we saw the end of
the game handshakes there world number
one against world number two uh the Epic
matchup The Clash of the Titans ends in
a draw the first result of the day
yes a draw was agreed by repetition and
this one moment again Knight to eh is a
really good awareness from dink he
doesn't want to allow The Rook into C7
so easily and The Rook still could have
plopped down on C7 but the difference is
with the Knight on D6 it defends this B7
square that seems completely irrelevant
Until you realize the Rook can just
slide back to B7 and that way the A7
Pawn is protected if we see a rook trade
we still have equality A5 A4 to trade
off that weak Queen Side Pawn is all it
takes to ensure you will make a draw so
I I think that dingley Ren you know you
should be proud of the way he played
this game it was if you just look at
this game very quickly just press the
next key you might think nothing much
happened but there were a few moments he
had to be accurate he was he makes the
draw and I think from now we can put
this game in the past and move on to our
other games we still have six left in
session
absolutely Robert let's take a look at
these six games and you were mentioning
ding was accurate as were you with your
analysis because take a look at the
bottom right the second board and we've
got Richard rapper versus Wesley Richard
decides to go for the idea that you were
pointing out the best way to give up
that pawn with D6 the action played out
just like we were calling it and it
looks like a Westie Still Remains uh on
down in that one meanwhile the board
next to that uh The Clash of the
teenagers The Clash of these two big
prodigies Prague against Winston Winston
decided to trade off on C4 immediately
open up that B file so very similar
ideas to what we were looking at the
tension in Fabi and Jordan continues at
the bottom left there's a lot going on
where do you want to jump to
wow uh so many good options I like that
Wesley didn't take on D6 by the way
keeping his Pawn structure intact and
probably and it's a second from the
right on the bottom row trying to get
that pawn later uh but the game between
Jordan and Fabia you were saying how uh
things seem to have gotten a bit out of
control and it's looking much better for
Fabi all of a sudden uh the evaluation
bar is up to one a full Pawn essentially
in White's favor and I think the reason
why is if you look at this bishop on E5
it's actually causing an attack against
the black king so what would be needed
to deliver a Checkmate an open file so
if I play this move H3 right now and you
take and white takes back the king
safely can go to H2 and a rook to G1 for
example and maybe there are threats
against this King not to mention this
bishop on E6 is worse than the bishop on
D3 that Bishop defends pawns this bishop
puts a little bit of pressure on the
pawns and if a knight ever hops for word
the bishop can take it and then you can
play Knight against Bishop in some
position so I just think that with the
queen coming to H5 King H2 Rook G1 white
has an easier set of moves to play and
for black it's like well where did I go
wrong I thought I should be doing pretty
well why did I start moving backwards
the tides have really turned in this one
I loved Jordan's play in the opening and
it looked like he had uh you know Fabi
by the race Fabi had to be so precise
but then suddenly something went wrong
and I think it was that critical moment
uh Robert where we actually left the
game last and let's just quickly back up
to that the bishop was on E5 because I
think this is where Fabi got his big
advantage and Jordan missed his big
chance we were looking at lines of
actually trading this bishop on E5 so
that white is forced to take with the D4
pawn and black gets this hold on the C5
square with ideas of rookie 8 coming in
upon coming to D4 so much activity and
things look great for black but Jordan
missed this chance and Fabi pounced on
this missed opportunity the very next
move he played the brilliant F4 making
sure that now if you take on E5 in fact
the F Pawn is the one that can recapture
and that's what he wanted and after F4
everything is under control in the
center Fabi has full control of the
center black had to go on to fix the
king side with G4 and this is what leads
us to all the ideas that you were
mentioning that even the blacks the one
that has advanced the pawns on the king
side and looks like the one who's on the
attack but actually he's weakened
himself once H3 comes in the G file will
open up and I like how Fabi is taking it
slow he says I'm not gonna Rush with H3
I'm going to finish my development first
goes Knight A3 brings The Rook to the
center of the game reroutes the Knight
all the way to E3 to attack that F5
weakness that you were pointing out and
at an opportune moment when the time is
right Fabi will strike with H3
and what just happened was Knight E3 and
Jordan makes me B5 and look at the
evaluation bar go up and up and up so
white is Chloe better here in the live
position and the move B5 it was played
pretty quickly the Knight on E3 it
reinforces control of the C4 Square so I
maybe Jordan was afraid of this move C4
so he quickly plays at B5 but now H3
comes with even more Force White's
pieces are staring at this King side if
you take on H3 I think I can just take
back move my king out same idea King H2
Rook G1 and so on uh you also don't need
to take back you can play the move Queen
F3 because if you take on G2 you're
getting checkmated your king doesn't
have squares to run to the bishop on E5
is too strong so actually move like Rook
F3 Queen F3 something like that bring a
piece of the G file and threatening to
take on H3 with a rook it leaves black
with a shattered Pawn structure and then
white with a healthier punch right here
so this position is getting really
really difficult if white plays H3 and I
think Tanya that Jordan's idea is
bringing this Knight to C4 reinforce
that square and start offering some
trades
we were talking about a Fabi finding an
opportune moment to play H3 but I think
you're absolutely right that it has
arrived now with so much activity on the
king side it is time that you bought all
your pieces in the game everything plays
you've got all the toys to the nursery
it's time to break open the position H3
you can't afford to take it and open the
G file Robert
but was A4 played A4 was played he
decided on the queen side on the other
side and maybe this is just a move to
provoke A6 and he can always play H3
after that if you take B takes A4 that's
not a move you want to make because
white can also then switch over to the
queen side you've created an A7 weakness
and that will also be very difficult to
handle and this is often the case when
your pieces are passive you can't shift
quickly from one side to the other while
the attacking side can so you don't want
to take on A4 if you don't have to take
on A4 the only way to keep it alive is
to make a move like A6 because there is
pressure on the B5 pawn bishop takes D6
is a threat and now Fabi can do what
we've been talking about go for the move
H3
and also can go Rook A1 he could just
swing all those pieces to the king side
and I'm wondering just generally
speaking if after H3 black has its move
H5 uh if we go back a second if H5 was
available and maybe this is what Fabi
was looking at as like well what did I
really accomplish here if I take and now
black takes maybe I'll be in trouble
down the H file someday the king can you
do the Petrosian King march and go to
the other side and bring a rook to H1
but the black king will also try to do
the same thing once this bishop moves
out the way the king can run so I feel
like Fabi he's playing on both sides of
the board not just one weakness this
Pawn F5 but now trying to create another
on the queen side so that flank could be
a vulnerability for Jordan His pieces
are centralized that sounds really good
but it's a problem when the action takes
place all the way on the queen side
flank so it's really interesting moment
here by Fabi the strike with A4
yeah I think it's all about the approach
here and Robert you know Fabi really
well you've been calling out his moves
from the start of the tournament and I
want to ask you do you think he is going
to try to create an attack on the king's
side with H3 and go for this complicated
line where black also gets H5 in
although I have to say I do like white
there I think white is faster on the H
file simply because of that Bishop on E5
uh it feels like there are going to be a
lot of sacrifices possible on G4 Rook H1
Rook h8 if the H file opens up I I
really like it for white or do you think
he's decided and it perhaps suits his
style more to Simply say I'm better here
strategically this position is great for
white I'm not going to take any chances
on the king side and now just focus on
the queen side focus on creating a
second weakness there do you think
that's going to be fabi's approach and
he's actually going to go back like back
with the Rook but before Fabi has a
chance to tell us Jordan takes a
controversial decision something that at
first sight it just felt is not a good
idea because it creates this A7 weakness
he actually picks up the pawn on A4 and
now this gives white the opportunity to
slide with the Rook back to A1 and make
the most of it yeah and I think that
Jordan might be relying on some kind of
Knight F7 but I don't really think he
could take this bishop on E5 because
let's play Knight F7 if you take only
five white wants to take back with the F
Pawn but if I take on A4 first and you
take on E5 and white takes fe5 there's
this move F4 and that's really bad news
for white the queen of Bishop protect
the G4 Pawn this Pawn may even come to
F3 at some point the bishop gets to
escape so then black has the upper hand
as we see so what white needs to do
first because the pawn A4 is not going
anywhere play the move G3 that way if
Knight E5 F takes E5 this Pawn F5 is a
target it doesn't get to F4 if you play
Bishop G5 to play F4 the Knight slides
back to G2 and covers F4 so at some
point after you take care of the queen
side you can play Rook F2 Rook F1 and
use all of your weapons against this
Pawn on F5 you can bring your queen over
to C2 and I feel like black is on the
defensive maybe not losing exactly but
there's a healthy ponchin from B2 to E5
you win the game of Connect Four I know
we're playing chess here but a Connect
Four looks pretty nice so I feel like
Fabi is playing on both sides and Jordan
is realizing that he can't sit and do
nothing he's at least trying to make the
position a little bit less clear for
Fabi
we're okay one Knight F7 is a nice
resource and finding G3 in that position
to take it slow before you recapture
just a prophylactic move stopping Black
from activity is
it's not easy for Fabi to spot that from
this position and he's taking his time
to really think because B takes A4 was
sort of was a bit counter intuitive by
Jordan and maybe not expected by Fabi
do we see any alternative because the
other move that comes to my mind to put
pressure on the A4 Pawn which I actually
really like is the move Queen C2 after
you pointed out Knight F7 Knight F7 now
Robert besides the fact that it loses
control on F5 look at this line and I I
don't know if it works but I think it
might you don't have to take on F5 you
know where I'm headed Robert you know
what I want to take
Knight takes G4 is a huge possibility
here and this is a stunning move because
if you capture the knight at first it
feels like it's on free but there's
actually a Checkmate we see the bar
shoot right up because Bishop 87 and
that Bishop on E5 is a monster and
because this trick was so attractive I
had to draw your attention to Queen C2
oh that means queasy 2 might be a very
good move because Knight F7 is annoying
for whites have to stop and play G3 for
uh the one maybe downside if you think
about it this way is that black could
throw an A3 not that it's necessarily
the problem but if you take back with
the pawn you're not going to be able to
exploit that weakness the isolated Pawn
on A7 but after A3 just because a pawn
can be captured doesn't mean it has to
be captured you could even play the move
B3 and then go after the pawn A3 with
your Rook later so it's an interesting
Dynamic where both sides have to figure
out when do I capture what do I capture
with and I feel like Fabi he played A4
and after B takes A4 now he's thinking
he wasn't really expecting Jordan to
take that pawn and he can in fact bring
the Rook here he can play Tanya's Quincy
too which now I'm liking more and more
just because it stops Knight F7
um and he also gets thrown H3 if he
wants to continue playing on both sides
but H3 I don't think that's clear like
it makes sense if black takes that it's
good for white because I bring in p to
the G file or I take back on H3 with a
piece rather than with the pawn but I
feel like even the event of H5 it's not
that easy to evaluate or if it takes
Rook F3 or queen F3 then the bishop
comes to F6 and now there's no more
Checkmate because the king can escape
and we're trading off a lot of pieces
and maybe we're opening files for our
opponents so it's give and take right
Tanya we have some good options but
maybe it gives our opponents some more
good options as well
I like to move H3 and I do see our eval
Bar says that even after Jordan's B
takes A4 it's a very viable option still
white keeps Advantage after that but
psychologically speaking Robert in chess
and I think we've all been there if Fabi
didn't play H3 in the last move it's
very unlikely that he'll play now after
B takes A4 it almost feels like he's got
a different plan a different idea in his
head so I'm either expecting Rook A1 or
the move Queen C2 uh but again Queen C2
allows this idea of A3 and Fabi needs to
be sure that he's fine with that Rook A1
then you need to find G3 but I think in
fabi's head if you try to get into that
his mind has shifted a little bit
towards the queen side and now making
the most of that A7 weakness so H3 a
great option but it will surprise me if
Fabi decides to go to go H3 when he
didn't in the previous move
I'm with you I'm totally with you there
and he can't safely just go to the queen
side now he will be better and if he
wants an advantage without risk that he
should play a move like Rook A1 or queen
to C2 because that way he doesn't give
black chances to go after the white king
and just one thing in addition that
we've been talking about like H3 if you
make a move like that you might also
find yourself in trouble in the dark
scores this bishop at some moment could
slide into a square like G3 so let's say
we get a position here and white isn't
careful and plays like Rook A1 you see
the evaluation already creeping in
Black's favor because there are issues
on the dark squares and I feel like with
a queen sliding out this way and a
bishop coming here you could even see a
Checkmate if you're not careful so just
wanted to point all that out and the
move was played Queen C2 your move Tanya
great call
I'm happy to see that on the board Queen
City when Fabi was reaching out I was
like please reach out for the queen not
The Rook not the rook and then Queen C2
on the board and what a nice trick that
is that Knight F7 now runs into Knight
G4 and of course Jordan will not fall
for that and it's almost as if he was
ready for Queen C2 because Robert he
barely took a minute he barely took a
minute to respond he goes with H5
reinforcing defenses on that G4 weakness
so that Knight G4 is never a threat that
you have to think about Jordan plays it
gets up gives the signal that I'm not so
worried about my position uh and I am
confident of defending this it makes me
think of all
what has happened in the tournament so
far with Jordan the first two games he
has gotten into trouble out of the
opening and this one as well he's on the
defense but Jordan's managed to survive
those two games but very often they have
been end games this one might be more
tricky to save because your king is weak
everything is on the board barely
anything's been traded off and queen C2
I like that idea H5 now you can just
think about attacking the A7 pawn and
Fabi is just such a beast in these kind
of positions he really is and H5 it
allows for some options with Knight F7
with the queen on C2 but if the queen
goes to A4 that has distracted the queen
away from this Pawn on F5 which means
Knight F7 Knight takes E5 is available
to Black so I like Queen Z2 as step one
I actually think Rook A1 makes more
sense the pawn on A4 isn't going
anywhere and if it can be captured on
the next turn maybe you capture with
full force going after the A7 Pawn or
you capture with the Rook on A4 for your
next over to A1 because black cannot
easily open up the king side you'll
bring your Pieces away from your king
but white is the one with all of the
Firepower over here a bishop that is
entrenched on the E5 Square creating
problems for the black king the F5 pawn
cements it in place is a long-term
Target thanks to this bishop Queen and
Knight configuration so I'm liking the
look of this for Fabi but Jordan I mean
I think he sees something for himself he
doesn't believe the position is that bad
for him but it does look very appealing
for white
Robert you point out Drew K1 and I love
it I think there is no need to rush as
you're saying to pick up the A4 Pawn
also after Rook A1 Knight F7 the other
advantage of Queen C2 is that Knight F7
is impossible because F5 is hanging you
can you after 907 you can simply go on
to take with the Knight Knight into F5
and after Knight E5 you can recapture
with the F Pawn opening up The Rook on
F1 to defend the Knight on F5 and this
would be a complete collapse for black
so a really nice spot there not to rush
with Queen A4 but actually to set it up
in a way that when you recapture the A4
Pawn it's the best possible version you
can get keeping all of your options open
that is what Rook A1 does and Fabi he's
thinking he's trying to be precise you
know he's had two somewhat shaky games
white in round one against a niche uh
and each sacrifice at night and the Fabi
had to make that draw then in game two
oh Fabi you know he made a draw but he
was black against abusotarev he was down
a pawn in the drawn Rook end game so
it's not like he played badly but he you
know was on the back foot a little bit
he was the one who had to prove the draw
so both these players have had a start
at least by the play on the board that
they probably don't love so they want to
get a win here in game three Bobby's
position is better he's thinking so
let's zoom out from here it will and
wait to see what move he makes but
six games in total five other games are
still going on as Fabi did in fact just
make a move and it was King H1 what wow
that is a surprise that's a shocker
Robert we were looking at all these
ideas about Fabby shifting play on The
Queen side and he makes this quiet
little move King to H1 it still doesn't
give a majority of his Advantage away
but that is super slow
does Fabi have all the time in the world
to make moves like this I guess he does
I I'm really trying to figure out why
that move is necessary why he didn't put
his Rook on A1 but maybe he's just
passing the Turn Back to Black
foreign
I'm honestly a little confused
um I don't think it's a bad move right
it doesn't change anything but it also
doesn't put more pressure on this Pawn
um really interesting I feel like these
top players often make moves that I am
mystified by but mysterious chess is
still good chess if you're carwana and
now it's Jordan's turn so we are
surprised but we will venture to another
game for now as we look across the games
that we have left Anish Geary in an end
game against Parham maksudlu even
material but not the same Pawn structure
for both sides that's on the bottom left
in the top right by the way Abdus Atara
with the black pieces has fully taken
control over the D file and yet White's
King has walked into the center I think
we should go to that game uh just
because I'm I'm eyeing a tactic at the
moment that I feel like black has to be
very careful about uh so we we'll pull
up the the game between gookesh and
abusot lost the first two but if White
had a move so let's make move H6 his
plan is likely Bishop D3 where it shuts
the Rooks off from each other and it
turns out that it's actually not the
best move because the exchange sacrifice
May in fact be pretty decent for black
but actually we see the eval bar once it
is getting more depth saying no it's
actually an equal position but this
Knight comes to G6 this pawn and this
Pawn are both weak and maybe that's why
black has enough play for the sacrifice
material but that Rook on D2 you know
don't be careless you could find it in
trouble
you've got to watch out for this
sucks and taking away any squares from
it it's not like it's safe on B2 because
the Knight will jump to A4 and attack it
as well so in this position you can't
really make the move Rook B2 trying to
get your other rook in all the Rook B2
Knight A4 E2 is hanging so I'm just
wondering after Rook P2 does he want to
go Bishop C2 and really boxing up that
Rook on that square and then there's no
saving uh from Knight A4 or Knight D1
winning this rook and potentially the
game it's a rook that's gone too far so
that's one of the things that gurukash
is eyeing is can I get this rook and
Bishop D3 did not work out well for
white in that position where the
exchange sacrifice happens and Knight to
G6 and that's good news for no deerback
is that means he doesn't have to freak
out and bring his Rook back to D7 in
which case uh then maybe white can move
the bishop bring a knight to E4
especially because of Pawn on G5 look at
these squares if a knight gets to E4
black is going to be in some trouble
with the Knight hopping in but if you
play King G7 oh no my Rook on D2 I
blundered and then we go for this
variation we were talking about with
Knight G6 and D3 and E5 are both going
to fall while black is better according
to the evaluation bar so Bishop E4
doesn't have the threat that you would
hope for
that's definitely a lot of compensation
I mean why it's going to be the one
who's going to be on the defense in this
one once the E5 Pawn Falls and very
important to play Knight G6 there's no
F4 to control that pawn anymore you will
lose the F4 pawn and this bishop on A6
will be a complete monster and 100 sure
gukesh realizes that he can't afford to
win this win this exchange he wins The
Exchange but probably ends up losing the
game in that case because of blacks
pieces jumping around with all the
activity now if Bishop D3 is not an
option then after King G7 how is white
planning to play on your knight on C3
has to stay there stopping any ideas on
E2
is it time to think about trading Rooks
is Rook D1 an option here it certainly
is because if you take on D1 and we
could swap all the Rooks but I just
wanted to put a specific position on the
board the Knight on E7 doesn't really
have anywhere to go at least not a place
that's super appealing if you go to G6
going for this pawn bishop takes G6 King
takes G6 and G4 an important move so the
king doesn't get in this is not what
black wants a knight that can venture to
dark squares whereas a bishop that
doesn't have anything it can attack this
would be a better end game for white not
a winning end game but one that's
clearly white is a side for choice so it
with the bishop on e4 you're restricting
this Knight after all the lasting play
was G5 so then I could go to G6 a move
ago Knight G6 is met by F4 and your
knight looks a bit silly now because
you're not capturing this is a healthy
Pawn structure so Bishop E4 is a
preventative move it stops that knife
from getting the G6 and Rick 51 may be
necessary Tonya I I think that is what a
gupesh will settle on and I don't really
think Hill he's better in the end game
but he won't be worse
but all these subtleties that you're
pointing out especially that move G4 I
think once the Rooks are off the board
white can try and create something
because notice that pawn on E5 which we
keep calling out a weakness it is one
but as long as it can't be attacked it's
actually a strong hold for white taking
away a lot of keys Quest from black once
the Rooks are traded off white can
slowly try to get his own Knight to put
pressure on black spawns I like to move
G4 and most importantly Robert this Rook
on D2 is making life so difficult for
white you're not able to move your
pieces around there's no activity so I
really think that Rook D1 has got to be
the right direction here simply trading
off Black's most active pieces and in
that end game despite having double
pawns white space activity and this
Knight potentially jumping to E4 at a
good moment if anyone's going to try
that end game without the Rooks I think
it's going to be white and a big
question is what about keeping one Rook
on the board can you play Knight takes
D1 and it says it's still a level
position uh the reason I don't like that
is The Rook on D has been The Rook on A1
but these are the questions the players
have to ask themselves how many Rooks
would you like to have on the board do
you want to trade them all off what
minor piece trades do you want you can
you can't win Knight G6 here so easily
with C6 hanging but also Bishop G6 King
G6 same as before if this King can't get
after this Pawn on E5 is this what black
wants to my eyes it's not you can't
attack this Pawn on E5 and the Knight
will be better than the bishop in many
positions so you just are looking at
possible exchanges Rook D1 may see all
the Rooks come off and then we may see
the point being split but hey it's still
a game both players are fighting and so
uh with six games remaining in the round
we do have a lot of exciting chess left
in store including in a potential end
game in this one
I mean we've seen a gokish and nordeback
fight it down to blood in their previous
battles so regardless of what our eval
Bar says what the objective evaluation
is till the board is vacuumed out the
two are going to play on so we'll wait
and see how the action progresses on
that one let's take a look on the other
boards and the the Anish farha match
still on and we see a lot of the ideas
that we were discussing have actually
happened the Queens have been traded why
did get E5 in Black decided not to trade
on E5 so the bishop on H2 still looks
like it is blocked and is not finding
its activity meanwhile Fabi with that
mysterious move King to H1 uh the left
or the second left board and Jordan is
still having a think he still doesn't
know how to respond to that
yeah it's a tough position for you're in
King H1 one of those little devious
waiting moves your turn I'm gonna pass
it on over to you and it's not that it's
a zuk Swang but black needs to find some
ideas so very interesting play from the
both of them I'm looking at the bottom
right the king is still in F2 for
prognananda uh it could be an electric
position in the near future especially
because black seems to have improved his
pieces I think Vincent has done a great
job maneuvering around there and also
one other position that still catches my
is the one between Richard report and
Wesley so because the pawn still
survived on D6 when he went D6 and once
he pushed the pawn to E6
he left that pawn on the board and I'm
not sure he's going to be able to win it
so easily so I think we can
um you know get to those games uh the
one between Wesley and Richard that
that's catching my eye so if we can uh
go there it would be excellent because
this part on D6 Tanya you may think oh
Bishop f8 let's get it but right now
there's already tension and this Knight
on D5 is under attack twice and there's
just this end game potential where if
Knight C3 Pawn takes C3 we've fixed our
structure and if you play Bishop f8 to
go after this Pawn the reason why white
is better is not because of material
anymore I just slide my Rook over you
take on D6 and I plant my Bishop on F6 I
have a better Bishop than you do my Rook
is active attacking a pawn if you bring
your Rook off the last rank you may lose
upon on B6 with your Rook hanging on
eight and if you make a move like Rook
to C8 over here it's a calm move white
just simply expands and can keep
expanding on both sides of the board
Tanya this looks really unpleasant with
the superior Place pieces for all of of
the pieces are in White's favor
not Bishop on F6 if it lands like that
it will dominate the position and the
game I don't think this is what Wesley
wants at all he will not want to go into
such a passive position where white is
playing all over the board but the
problem is that if you don't take on C3
well he's made a decision he's decided
to fall back with the Knight white also
has the potential option to get rid of
the Double D pawns here uh Robert you
can consider the move D5 I want to get
rid of the weakness I'm still up a pawn
and if I can solve the problem of my
Pawn structure I've got everything to
play for and the more I look at D5 the
more I like it unless you refute it
tactically
no it's not refuted tactically but I
think Wesley's planned the whole way
through with Knight to F6 is that he
wants Knight E8 and D5 won't stop him
from doing that you take on E6 the pawn
takes back you take on G7 the king takes
and you are losing the opponent D6 by
force which means we have will have an
even material end game as we can see off
the side it is level it is not just
level by material but by the evaluation
so very good choice I mean a brilliant
Choice by Wesley to retreat the Knight
to F6 here he could never take on E5
with the bishop because then you give
white a protected pass Pawn so he goes
Knight F6 I love that move by him and
his next move is Knight E8 to get the D6
Pawn
yeah and that just uh plays the spoil
spoiler to D5 let's just point out that
after D5 it's very important to be
precise with 98 because if you take
Knight takes D5 instead Robert which is
what I was hoping for to solve all
structured problems the issue here is
that white actually captures the bishop
on G7 you don't have time to take on C3
because the bishop returns and picks up
the Knight and exactly and if you take
with the King on G7 now white will
eternally be your extra Pawn up takes on
D5 takes everything the D6 Pawn is alive
it's not going anywhere I don't know if
this is enough for a win or not but this
is long-term pressure and a nightmare to
defend oh nobody would want this and the
king is very close so there could be an
opportunity to double up Rooks and get
the pawn but at best you're going to be
a pawn down and hoping to make that draw
so for Wesley I think he is choosing a
more precise route with Knight F6 The
Rook came to A1 and he can't play Knight
E8 but I actually think that Richard is
setting up a little bit of a trap as
well so if Knight E8 and he plays D7 and
you go Rook takes D7 there's Rook takes
B6 so Richard he's clinging on to that
extra pawn and the most clever of ways
Tanya I think he's showcasing his
creativity I know wait it's an end game
it looks like it's going to be strategic
or technical but he's finding tactics
left and right and if Knight E8 D7 is
available for white that's not so easy
for black to meet because if you move
your knight back to F6 then you can
consider Bishop C7 and after Rook takes
D7 this bishop takes B6 and there's a
pin down the a file so clever play here
by the new Romanian uh the born
Hungarian player
that's actually super interesting just
the way he's really Clinging On to this
pawn and not letting go of it very
instructive stuff Rook A1 idea has to go
D7 and not easy for black to recapture
it and as long as Richard's Pawn is
alive
he's the one with all the chances
Wesley's still trying everything that he
can to regain it and we see that he has
in fact played really accurately we see
the eval bar say that everything is
under control but practically when the
players are on the board and they have
no idea of what is the objective
evaluation of the position until you win
that pawn you don't feel safe at all
for sure that is a pawn that is in enemy
territory it's gonna be a thorn in
Wesley's side and now he is seeing
Knight E8 there is D7 a nice tactical
shot from Richard report now uh Wesley
he really is holding on well here I
think that he's fully capable he is such
a good end game player and I don't think
he's in too much trouble but it's just
credit to Richard report for kind of
keeping that pressure up he's not taking
a single move off he is working to his
maximum capabilities and making Wesley
prove it but we will let Wesley do just
that we're gonna zoom out really quickly
and see all six games that remain Magnus
Carlson and dingler and Drew other games
are still underway here so we're gonna
take a quick break and win return it's
more from the third round of the Tata
steel chess tournament 2023.
oh
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock up right here almost
there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time Lots yeah okay you bring a clock oh
I left my clock at home dude you idiot I
told you to bring it let's just go get
somebody okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
on screen playing his game against Arjun
aragaisi right now and well this year he
would hope to add a fifth title to his
previous four he has been a Mainstay in
Viking Zay this is the 85th Edition wow
and I see his Queen jump up the board
there but this is the 85th Anniversary
of the tournament it started in 1938.
it's been in Vikings a since 1968 it was
in bever vike which is very nearby
before that as a sponsored by Tata steel
since 2011 some of the notable Champions
include Magnus Kasparov vishyanins
Anatoly karpov icard Nakamura and the
man you see on screen there Lavon
aronian so Tanya Lavon he's been a great
treasure in the Chess World and he's
been a menace for opponents in vikon Zay
he just played this move Queen C2
against your compatriot the teenager our
generic I see who we've been praising
for his preparation and performance with
the black pieces in the first two games
now with white it seems like he's just
worse because Levant is more active with
his heavy pieces
Robert you know Gary kaspro once said
about Levon that the Chess World is a
better place when LeBron is playing well
and I think that just sums up everything
that Lev has added to the world of Chess
he is one of the most creative player
one most resourceful players he has a
sense of beauty a sense of Aesthetics
for him chess is truly art and that's
what his games go on to show you're
absolutely right that apart from Magnus
who's won the event eight times Levon
aronian in this field has won this
Championship the maximum number of times
now he returns to why can't they the
Tata steel Masters as the oldest player
in the field he's 40 years old he is a
new dad as well so Renewed Energy
renewed feelings about how he approaches
this tournament but one thing's for sure
that love hasn't been having the kind of
results that we expect out of him and
what we've seen from him over the last
couple of years and I think this start
of the year is super important for him
he is motivated to perform at his best
and this game shows that he's ready to
take on one of the players who's given
him a hard time in 2021 and in 2022
Arjun aragassi who's had a very good
score against him in faster time
controls with the black pieces in this
game levons had no problem at all and
continues to play this position which is
slightly better for black and the reason
for that is that one piece activity just
simply compare Lev's Queen and Rook to
arjun's Queen and Rook not just that in
general terms when there are pawns on
both sides of the board the position is
open the bishop is stronger than the
Knight you've got more targets it's a
long range piece the bishop can come to
F6 attack the B2 pawn and all these uh
all these things and these subtleties in
the position give Levon something to
play for in a position that at first
might not look like much
that's right and there is going to be a
rook slamming down on C2 in the future
if you trade The Rook gets there
immediately but if you don't trade black
can take on B1 and The Rook can come to
C2 that's gonna be an active Rook
compared to White's passive Rook sitting
on B1 and you pointed out there's a
bishop a long range piece these pawns
are on dark squares it means the bishop
can attack them try to pick them off so
the Knight on D3 is perfectly situated
for the moment but let's say we do get a
queensry just to make a couple moves and
just exhibit some of these ideas what is
White's plan what moves does white have
you can't move the Knight you lose the
pawn on B2 if you move the Rook
somewhere let's see one trying to get an
open file The Rook slides the D2 putting
pressure on this Knight you don't want
to move the Knight because down goes B2
and if you move the Rook to defend and
your Rook has to go to B3 look at this
position your Rook is sitting on B3 and
it's defending this Knight I want to
kick your Rook away I see the eval bar
is tanking which means A5 is good my
next move is A4 to win your knight on D3
if you move your knight on D3 then I
take on B2 and I win the ensuing and
game up a pawn so I think that Arjun has
these problems to figure out if the
Queens gets rid here he doesn't really
have a plan and what Lavon can do is
start pushing his King forward pushing
his pawns forward decide where his
pieces go he kind of has a free hand
this position is a nightmare to play
with the white pieces because you know
you're on the defense you know you've
got no trumps in it you're going to play
an end game where Black's gonna pretty
much daughter you until eternity and
lab's going to enjoy doing that here
Queen C2 a nice offer of trade and with
this it looks like arjun's facing an
uphill task to save this game a nicely
played positional battle here by Lev
keeping his Advantage with the peace
activity and as we know we're we've
actually finished two games already in
this round with Magnus ending finishing
in a draw the first one to finish in a
draw between the world number one and
the world number two where Magnus had a
slight pull out of the opening but ding
kept his defenses up and he made it look
almost easy against the world champion
and this is why yes currently the second
best player in the world apart from that
the crazy opening that we saw in the
Parham Anish game also fizzled out into
a draw Robert and I think both players
can be pleased with that outcome for
sure because Parham he had a long day
too now here in the third round he draws
with the white pieces you might want to
get a little bit more be a bit more
ambitious with white but it was a solid
draw there was just two Rooks per side
along with a knight and six pawns uh
each side has some weak pawns and some
strengths but the game was agreed on the
draw now they drew based on a draw offer
I have pretty big feelings about this I
do not like the draw offer I think that
people should play it out I think it's
better for spectators I'm not blaming
either of the players I think that as a
rule it's always best if people play it
out now this tournament has a lot of
Fighting Chess and there's a rule you
can't make a draw before move 30 out of
respect for the organizers and the
sponsors and Anish gear is an ambassador
for the tournament and a great one at
that and he had the black pieces so
making a draw is good for him but I just
feel like the fans the public are
deprived if we bring this position up
just for a second here
why is this game a draw like that would
be the big question so as we just show
you the finale of the game if I showed
you this position or you showed me this
position Tanya I would be like wait a
second this actually looks like there's
some life here this Pawn on E5 is a
potential Target yes the Knight can go
back on F3 to defend but then we look
and black has four pawns against three
on this side of the board maybe there's
a B5 push at some moment I'm just
pointing out that even though it's
completely even I think that draw offers
often are bad for chess because you know
the games can Peter out in other ways
that just are completely obviously drawn
where this doesn't feel that just yet
as a spectator you would love to see
this end game being played out for the
battle to go down to the wire and see
the very end of it and the players
really proved that their endgame
technique is equal to each other and to
split the point that way but here in
this case after Knight E4 it does appear
that Anish offered a draw Parham
understandably took it because if anyone
can try this position at least to my
eyes Robert it looks like with that E5
weakness and the queen side majority
it's perhaps black who has a slight
nagging pull in this so understandably
Parham agreed to the draw but on the
other hand F7 is perhaps a weakness and
Anish just felt that he did not have
enough in this position
it would be nice to see this play on but
the two players have decided to end the
day because it is a long tournament as
well they've had long Fighting Chess
speaking of you not enjoying Jaws if we
just pull out the one game I know that
you're going to be enjoying Robert is
the second board from the left Fabi
against Jordan van Forest crazy things
are happening in that one last we left
Fabi had made a mysterious move King to
H1 now we see the king is back on G1
Jordan is going ahead with the pawns H4
G4 has played over ambitiously on the
king side but it looks like it might pay
off because I see our eval bar seems to
say that Jordan has covered ground
well yeah after we left A3 was played
Fabi took it and Jordan took the
opportunity to play Knight C4 he didn't
want to hang about all day and just let
fobby do what he wanted so it goes
Knight C4 offering a trade Bobby takes
the bishop the pawn takes back and King
to G1 look at this by Fabiano he just
moves his King shuffles back and forth
not really clear what he's doing maybe
he's saying to Jordan you don't really
have any improving moves but Jordan
plays H4 and look at the eval bar I'm
gonna show that again it was slightly
better for white now H4 is played and
it's significantly better for white
because Knight takes G4 Tanya and it was
a one move blunder if you take on G4 in
comes the queen to G6 check you've been
just a champion of this bishop on E5 and
it's leading to Victory the king can't
move the only legal choice is Queen G7
Queen takes G7 is made so I think that
was a one move blunder under because
Jordan played Bishop D5 the Knight goes
back and yes Jordan's Bishop is on e4
but C4 is weak uh you're down to pawn
that was a big big blunder by Jordan
that's a huge blunder after H4 and
suddenly the moves King H1 King G1
seemed to make a lot of sense if your
opponent just walks into this Robert
that means that Jordan has actually
blundered a pawn in his first three
games of the Tata steel Masters and he's
constantly on the defense being upon
down in these games you remember him
missing Knight to F4 in his game against
Wesley giving up that E2 pawn and it was
the same narrative with him being a pawn
down in round two as well I think it was
and now H4 a one move Miss Knight takes
G4 let's just show that on our analysis
board again and of course Fabi doesn't
miss that kind of stuff after he had to
keep the pawn on H5 you played that move
to keep the G4 Pawn defended not to
create attacking chances on the king
side because it's your king that's weak
with the bishop on E5 H4 walking into
this huge trick with Knight G4 a trick
that we've been talking about in a
different position and as you said FG 4
is met by Checkmate in one the queen
jumps in and it's all over of course
this Jordan relies after he played H4
it's too late Bishop to D5 happened
Knight E3 and now we've got a same
position but white just has an extra
pawn and suddenly these mysterious ideas
by Fabi are shuffling the King around
its work to Perfection and you can see
by body language as well that Jordan we
could see at least that he has his hand
on his head I mean he's distraught at
the moment he simply blundered upon and
a Pawn on C4 is also going to be
vulnerable so a really bad Miss for such
a great player a champion in tata Steel
in 2021 and I think we just have to show
it one last time because oh you're right
that Fabi was doing something very
clever he had his King on the corner but
he brings his King back to G1 because in
the event of Bishop D5 he doesn't want
his King to be in that Bishop's sight
and other moves like Bishop D5 were just
better for your not that he had the
advantage you could see that white is
still better and maybe moves like Queen
A4 attacking this Pawn of Rook coming to
B1 I think it's quite natural that white
has the advantage here with great
control over the position and it's very
difficult for black to keep everything
defended like it's upon on C4 is
defendant for now but at some point you
could even consider taking on D5 and
going for the open files the bishop on
E5 is still the best piece the position
remains relatively close which is good
for the white king and well H4 was just
a tragedy it blunders upon and now the
problem still exists but White's also
upon ahead
this is absolutely horrific and you're
you're completely right that you look at
Jordan a couple of moves ago he was
walking around getting a drink looked
completely chill and now you can see the
shift at this stage at this platform
being at the Tata steel Masters you
can't make these kind of Errors Robert
not against the world-class players that
you're facing against Fabiano caruana
you don't make a one move blunder and
hope to survive it this is shocking but
it's great for Fabiano right one
person's pain is another person's uh
pleasure in this case and for Fabiano
he's going to be thrilled to get a
victory in this game if he can work this
out and win because he had two kind of
shaky draws himself not his best stuff
and a win in game three will catapult
him to two out of three uh likely in the
lead because co-leaders Carlson and
dingley rent they drew Anish Curie who
was in the lead also Drew and unless
wins that means five Banner will enter
the fourth round of action in a tie for
first if he can win this game and well I
think Queen A4 looks pretty
straightforward Tonya going right after
the C4 Pawn because Bishop D3 is the
point defending and attacking The Rook
but white can just like swing his pieces
around you play Queen F7 you defend this
Pawn uh enough times but then C6 is
hanging oops sorry that's C6 over here
and if you play Queen E6 to defend C6 A7
is hanging and queen G7 Checkmate is
threatened so I feel like white is about
to win a second pawn and so for Jordan
his body language looks to me like he
kind of wants to resign maybe he has
some chances here he needs to give it
his all because the game isn't over just
yet
you're not only upon down as black
you've also got the ugliest Pawn
structure in the world look at Jordan
spawns a7c60 for f5h4 all of them
disconnected all of them weak so him
ending up losing another Pawn I will not
be surprised at all Fabi chooses another
path a really nice one as well I like it
Queen to E2 you're threatening the same
Pawn C4 and you're pretending like
you're walking into a move like Bishop
D3 which would be a skewer but the queen
actually jumps over Robert all the way
to H5 threatening a devastating check on
h8 and you don't care about the Rook on
F1 so I like the move Queen E2 it not
only threatens another Pawn but also
threatens to attack Black's King right
so the best move would probably be Queen
H7 and you could trade Queens if you
want uh but I think that even if we I
was just wondering if we give up the
exchange here you have two pawns and a
knight for a rook this king is weak this
Pawn is weak all the other pawns as you
mentioned are isolated so even if you
give up that Rook for the bishop it's
still going to be good for Fabi that's
just how big of a blunder it was from
your the G4 Pawn was too important
holding his position together and now he
um will need to find some kind of
resource I I don't know where it will
exist but it looks like he is going to
suffer
and this would be a win for Fabi who's
currently on a one point and winning
that will LeapFrog him further into the
standings this is where we stand with
the game still in progress Magnus has
already finished his round which ended
in a draw so he along with a niche thing
and yeah three of them lead the
leaderboard with two points currently
but of course the games are still
ongoing so in fact Fabi if he wins this
can join the leaders at the end of the
day and it's nice to get off to a good
start a running start so for Fabi he
really wants us one so Jordan he has his
work cut out for him it's not going to
be an enjoyable task but maybe he can
fight back here in this game because the
knockout punch isn't that obvious let's
zoom out again look at our remaining
games that are still going in addition
to this one because we have fights
across the board we saw in the middle on
the bottom Lavon Ronin remains better in
the end game he didn't bring his Rook
down to C2 but said put his Rook on d8
uh the bishop will outclass the night it
looks like Wesley so did not get that
pawn on D6 instead bringing his Knight
back to seventh second from the right on
the bottom but my eyes are still on the
bottom right game there's a king on F2
uh there are many pieces on the board a
black queen has ventured out to H4 so
Tanya I feel like we should go on over
to that game between prognanda and
Vincent kymer sounds like a plan but I
just want to finish the whole uh Fabi
Jordan debate you were mentioning that
Jordan might still have chances in that
I have to say Robert it looks like that
game is going to end I think Fabiano's
got that point after winning that G4
Pawn I'm still in shock about Jordan
making that one move blunder and it's
again not just the pawn is not your only
problem your king is weak and the pawn
structure and I think that's going to be
a Fabby game but coming back to this one
where we have no idea who is better but
what still has the feeling that with the
two Bishops white should be an icr eval
bar seems to be saying that Prague has
the upper hand and the reason for that
is also that the A5 Pawn here is so weak
in fact it can be picked up the only
thing going in Black's favor currently
is that the C4 Pawn is under Fire as
well so in fact the move the last move
played was Rook from E8 to B8 putting
the Rook on the open file hoping that
one day it was a trade actually after
rookie Rook be it and you're hoping and
dreaming that you can get that Rook to
B4 to defend that A5 Pawn I think it's
impossible for white to currently pick
up the pawn on A5 if you play Queen
takes A5 perhaps black can just play
Bishop C4
yes the queen is needed in the defense
Bishop C4 just grabs that pawn and
that's very bad news for white
and if you don't have time to pick up
the A5 Pawn that gives black the
opportunity to place the Rook on B4 that
and Robert that gets me to the point
that I want to make here that maybe it's
important for white to play
energetically in this position you've
got this if albar telling us that
White's better but if Black's Rook comes
on B4 whose pawns are weak A4 is
attacked C4 is attacked so how are you
going in with this position and what is
it that our evaluation likes so much
about prague's gameplay yeah the pawn H2
is also loose so many white pawns are
also under attack and I was thinking if
I could play Queen takes G7 and Knight
F5 check would be a fork to follow but I
can't do that because you're a knight in
the way and playing F4 runs into Knight
G4 check which I don't want so King G1
Sliding Away from the pin protecting the
pawn on H2 looks very good to my eyes
because if black plays Rook to D4 I now
have F4 cutting you off from this Pawn
on C4 which is what you're attacking and
if you try to take on C4 here I have
Knight F5 so now I don't even need to
take right away on G7 with the fork I
played Knight F5 threatening Checkmate
in one and your queen the only way to
stop that is Queen F6 but that Rook on
B4 that's a problem because once the
queen moves out the way I get your Rook
first and then I get your knight second
and white will end up an entire Rook
ahead so King G1 actually is a tactical
move not just a defensive move it slides
out of the pin it allows for the move F4
followed by Knight F5 and I do believe
that Vincent needs to be careful and the
big question is can you players with
Queen D4 check opening up the C5 Square
for your second night these are really
big difficult questions to answer
and you were mentioning the H2 Pawn
which made me wonder why it was not
picked up and I want to show the reason
for that when black made the move Rook
B8 let's just back up a couple of moves
here Vincent was to play with the black
pieces and the H2 Pawn looks like it's
hanging but that's a devious trap you
pick it up and then suddenly you realize
your Queen's got nowhere to run nowhere
to hide and it would be trapped on H2 so
in fact the pawn is not on free and King
G1 as you're mentioning let's go back to
our current position of course Winston
did not fall for this he trades up one
pair of Rooks wants to activate it with
this small move King G1 channeling Fabi
Spirit uh will Prague find it if he goes
King G1 that's super impressive you and
he's very he said it he makes it just as
I was saying Robert
you were saying you were saying it would
be impressive he wanted to be impressive
and now you are looking at this position
with F4 available so Vincent has this
big choice voice of Queen d project I
think if he doesn't play Queen D4 he's
much worse because F4 is about to happen
at the very least kicking this Knight
back A5 is a Target so I think that
Queen D4 check it's a big chance for
Vincent because after it takes Pawn
takes you're threatening D3 you're
trying to bring the Knight to C5 go
after this Pawn C4 is still a bit weak
the B file is available for this black
rook and yet the eval bar still says
that white is better what does somebody
have to do to eliminate that Advantage I
don't know
yeah I'm really surprised with this
evaluation bar in this position you
point out Queen D4 I love it it's
blackstroke that's on the open file you
can't even make a move like Knight F5
looks really attractive but that just
invites Rook B2 and suddenly our Bishops
are not happy at all and this would be
big trouble so if it's not Knight F5 the
C4 Pawn is under Fire uh there are
threats of Rook C8 Knight B6 is coming
in Robert eyeing that A4 Pawn eyeing
that C4 Pawn how is white even handling
this and why again again the question is
it's so hard to understand engine
evaluation and you're pointing out this
energetic move with F4 kicking that
Knight out taking advantage of the fact
that right now c4 cannot be picked up
and if the Knight has to go to G6 that's
definitely progress for white
yeah it is and Rook B2 still available
in Knight C5 but the A5 pawn and it's
not just A5 it's also the pawn on D6 and
I think that at some moment white can go
after these pawns with your knight F5
move as well so Bishop F1 or something
like that avoiding this Rook B2 okay the
evaluation went down when I made that
move so my bad but I was just trying to
find a move that avoided this Rook B2 uh
tactic uh but D4 D6 A5 all weaknesses
even though they're squares and weak
Pawns in White's Camp it seems that
white should have the better position uh
at this moment
and Winston playing it just like you
said he should he's gone for the move
Queen D4 this was his moment to offer a
queen trade before White had the
opportunity to make the move F4 and
block that Queen out on H4 with the
queen on C3 being super strong so nicely
timed by Winston and looking at all
these uh factors in the position
I don't care what the eval Bar says
anymore Robert I think it's a it's an
end game where anything can happen black
also has his own trumps with the C4 A4
weakness The Rook jumping to B2 it's
hard to justify the evaluation and
imagine the players on the board who
have no idea about what the engine is
saying they can definitely feel that
this is a messy end game
it will be a messy end game and I think
that white doesn't have too much of a
choice because if you move your king
somewhere let's say King F1 that Rook is
still landing on B2 with pretty
devastating effect so prague's hand is
forced he has taken on D4 the pawn
captures back just now and with the C5
Square available it's the Knight Knight
B6 as you mentioned Rook B2 Rook C8 it
feels like black has an initiative some
counter play and that's all you could
ask for when you have an opponent who
has two Bishops who has the opportunity
to attack your weak pawns so I do
believe that you know the activity
should be sufficient to give Vincent
good drawing chances but it is apparent
that he is worse after the move F4
very important for Prague to find F4 as
well and take a look at the clock
situation Prague is down to 20 minutes
Vincent has got about 20 minutes they
are currently on move 24 so they still
have 16 moves to make to meet time
control and uh let's just remind
everyone of the format of the tournament
with the time control the players have
got a hundred minutes for the first
control to make 40 moves after which
they get an additional 50 minutes and
once they make move 60 then they get the
to the final time control with an
additional 15 minutes and all through
the game from move one they get an
increment of 30 seconds every time they
press the clock
that's right and so they are trying to
reach move 40 this game is only a move
24 and other games also have yet to
reach that 40th move so I think we
should zoom out for the moment as now
Prague has some important decisions to
make we'll let him figure it out uh
because I'm looking from game to game
and uh Fabiano caruana and the bottom
left he has a huge Advantage he did
sacrifice The Exchange he's taken over
the B file the F5 Pawn is weak as well
the game next to it Lavon ruins still
with an advantage with the black pieces
but not too many pieces remain in the
top right we see a relatively level
position between gookash and abusotarev
it's a night vs Bishop ending but my
eyes still and by the way Prague did
just play F4 but my eyes really are on
that game between Richard LaPorte and
Wesley so because somehow the Rooks have
landed in the light squares in the queen
side and black remains a pawn down and
it's a pass Pawn at that
let's deep dive into that one it is a
very fascinating end game just look at
the bind that white has created and you
were mentioning this Rook on Asics was
annoying you so much Wesley heard you
out Robert he says I don't want it there
anymore immediately goes back with the
Knight to be it a retreating move uh but
an important one to make sure that white
stroke doesn't stay there and Rook falls
back to A4 now Wesley can think again
does he want to go back and are they
repeat it I think they are repeating yes
because Knight went to F6 Knight D7 was
played and we saw Rook A6 Knight B8 and
The Rook went to A4 though instead of
being on A1 what's A4 the Knight to D7
Rook A6 Knight B8 Rook A4 Knight D7
could be a draw here handshakes
and Wesley plays Knight D7
now Richard slows down so it's not yet
Robert it's not a draw yet if he goes
Rook A6 that would be a threefold
repetition but Richard very well could
have just been gaining time on the clock
we see there are still 15 moves to be
made to reach time control he's down to
13 minutes so every second counts he has
gained that extra minute with this
repetition I'm sure Richard realizes
that if anyone's better here it's got to
be him and knowing Richard knowing his
fighting spirit
I'm gonna be shocked if he bails out
with Rook A6 here there's no risk for
him right now he's up a pawn it's his
Pawn on D6 what black is threatening is
the move A6 to kick the Rook out of B5
why do you want to kick the Rook Out The
Rook needs to help defend this bishop on
E5 otherwise if you move this Rook away
Knight takes and you lose a pawn and
will lose D6 next so that means that
Richard either has to take this bishop
on G7 he can Retreat his Bishop to G3
The Rook on A4 is doing an important
defensive task but things to get a bit
awkward so Bishop takes G7 feels like
the big question and look at the eval
bar it's saying well black is actually
evening this thing up over here uh in
this position because the pawn D6 is
going to be a Target the Rooks are kind
of awkwardly placed if you get A6 in so
I think that Richard might make that
draw with Rook A6 if he thinks that if I
don't make the draw now maybe I
jeopardize being worse
and let's point out that A6 is just the
beginning of problems for the Rook let's
say after if you decide to take on G7
King G7 and just to make a point after
A6 whitestruck falls back on B4 and
imagine black gets B5 in Robert
B5 in you're hitting that Rook on A4 and
this Rook on B4 is trapped for the rest
of the game you gotta give up you can go
Knight B6 or Knight F6 after that no
matter where you move the Rook D5 would
mean giving up a pawn D6 is under attack
The Rook on B4 is struggling for breath
here and this is a problem which makes
me think that perhaps whether Richard
likes it or not Rook A6 might be
objectively the best move for him now
yes and it would just be that repetition
so he started with the Rook on A1 he
brought his Rook up to A6 and I guess he
just hasn't found anything because the
Knight going back and forth it's looking
like now that the continuation it's
settled in on the analysis this whole
position is just equal and Wesley so
bringing the Knight back to F6 back to
D7 back to d8 and then returning to D7
after that he's shown great technique in
this end game he has equalized and if
the move works is played that means it's
the third and final time it's a
repetition and it would be a draw
very impressive play by Wesley he's been
down the pawn for the majority of the
game and yet he's managed to keep the
balance with these retreating moves
which are Super imaginative by him
they're not easy moves to make he had
the option to try and go directly take
the pawn with the move 98 at some point
but he didn't do that he went Knight D7
instead finding the most accurate
defense and Richard
is still thinking he hasn't yet made a
move I thought he was going to reach out
for for The Rook but it looks like with
this precise defense in a difficult
opening and very impressive I mean at
first it might look like you know there
wasn't much in this game there wasn't
that many sacrifices or anything but
finding this kind of defense this is a
pure class by Wesley
it isn't it is a great defender he
always remains objective and he is going
to complete his objective and make a
draw in this game it looks very likely
so while Richard decides whether or not
to play Rook A6 and make a draw
immediately or somehow play on we can go
to our other games just to see what's
happening uh because they're you know
some of completely full of life and well
your invent for us is completely falling
apart so the eval bar is just it's like
on a rocket ship it's going up up and
away here and his position looks
miserable Tanya he is has an extra Rook
for a knight in two pawns but the white
king is way safer let's just bring that
board up so we can show what's Happening
Here the last bunch of moves were
if we go back in time
H4 was the big blunder giving away the
G4 Pawn just to show it one last time
here Queen G6 is check and mate so it's
just a one move blunder of a pawn in a
difficult position and now after this it
was an exchange sack for a bishop in
another pawn and Rook B1 Rook B8 and we
I see the move C4 played by Fabiano D5
at some point uh can be the choice you
can also play C5 and Knight C4 bring a
knight in
in such a miserable position
that Bishop on E5 it all goes back to a
long long time ago when Jordan had the
option to actually just swap off and
trade these Bishops and none of these
problems would have happened but instead
he decided to keep the Bishops on the
board and it's now this bishop that
dominates Black's position white also
has the Tactical trick always to pick up
another Pawn in this uh current board
that we've got on by going Knight F5 or
queen F5 the bishop on d8 hangs and with
these extra pawns and the killer Bishop
on E5 white will be the one dominating
that end game as well Robert the this is
just massive problems for Jordan he has
survived two difficult games in round
one and two I don't think that would be
the case this time
and he's going to be pretty upset
because he's played badly in the first
three games and I only state that
because he is capable of so much more
and we've seen that here in Viking Zay
he won the event in 2021 he's over
performed his rating every single time
he's playing the master section he's
being the likes of janapamnashi and
other top players and Tata Steel's past
so for Jordan he's just 23 uh you know
his best isn't behind him nothing like
that but the highlight of his career to
this point was winning the 2021 event
and now he's off to the worst start
imaginable he had the white pieces in
two consecutive games he drew both those
from positions of you know inferior
positions and then now with the his
first black pieces he's in big trouble
he had an opening prep that looked good
but since then it's been all downhill
for him
absolutely this has been a tough
tournament so far and this one move
blunder by him going for H4 and it's
something that he's done in round one as
well it just goes on to show that he had
he isn't in his A-game he isn't in his
best shape right now going into this uh
event and he just hasn't had his kind of
positions very tough events so far for
Jordan and it looks like a Fabby will
not let Jordan's luck continue if he
does win if Fabi takes this point home
that would mean that he would join
Magnus Carlsen Anish giri and dingler
and on the leaderboard Fabi would jump
over to two points and meanwhile of
course the rest of the games are in
progress and if we just bring them up
let's take a quick look at what is
happening all around we will keep an eye
out on the Jordan board but the one big
board that catches my attention where so
much has happened has been the game and
the narrative that we've been discussing
between the two prodigies the two
talents the two teenagers of the
tournament and we have a result
yeah I believe that Richard report and
Wesley so Drew their game they split the
point uh we were expecting that to
happen with the Rook going up and down
the night going back and forth so we
have now three games finished at the
moment and that means we have four games
remaining
and there we have our tournament Hall
and our remaining games here we've got
if we take a look at the bottom right
frog against Winston so much has
happened a black pawn has reached E2
we've got to back up to that moment when
proctic the decision to go F4 we were
talking about energetic play here after
the queen trades and that's exactly what
happened after F4 uh black responded
with D3 so counter-attacking the bishop
on E2 while giving up the Knight on E5
Prague decided to take it
black recaptures the piece on E2 white
picks up the pawn on D6 and this is
where we are Rook C8 putting pressure on
the C4 Pawn I see our eval Bar says that
after all these trades and all these
exchanges White's the one who lands up
with the upper hand is that because you
can simply go 92 Knight D4
uh that you can just grab that you grab
the pawn on A5 as well
um I'm wondering though with the
presence of opposite colored Bishops
there are long-term chances for black to
hold the draw even down two pawns
sometimes with opposite closed Bishops
you can be down three pawns and still
make a draw so Knight takes E2 there
could be Rook takes C4 and well if you
take the bishop gets active and goes
after the D5 Pawn if you take on A5
there is not Rook takes A4 I don't think
because while the Bishop is under attack
I think the Rook slides up to C7 and
this Knight is in some trouble here and
you do not want to lose the Knight
because then the d-pawn becomes very
strong there are back rank problems it
says it's actually still uh staying at
the same eval like the same assessment
but it looks very dangerous for black I
know White's pieces are also hanging but
the king is unsafe this is the past Pawn
this is a crazy position everything
hacks there's a background problem then
I don't need to hang the bishop on A5
hangs the Knight on D7 Hank Hank's
White's got this passer on D6
but it still looks like White's the one
who has the advantage here 92 is what I
am expecting and after Rook C4 you were
pointing out that white could take on A5
and we could potentially have an
opposite color Bishop ending with the
Rooks traded off and that might be
Black's best bet but Robert as long as
the knights are alive it's going to be a
hard and a tough road to defend that
position with the black pieces it
certainly will E2 is hanging C4 is
hanging A5 is under attack as well uh if
it's not it's ever free to move A4 will
be a Target so there's just so many
pawns that are weak in this position but
that's what Vincent wants is the trade
off most these pieces to liquidate
because his King can be useful in a pure
end game the kid can run over to the
center of the board it can't do that if
the Rooks remain so I do believe that
Vincent's doing everything necessary to
try and hold this game Rook takes C4 has
just been played
Bishop A5 if you trade the Rooks then
this bishop can go to C4 and you win
this Pawn White's only going to be one
Pawn ahead and with the presence of
opposite colored Bishops Tanya I feel
pretty strongly that black is going to
be able to hold this
oh that would be amazing if Winston
actually survives this very difficult
game and shows amazing defensive
resources he had a tough task ahead of
him on day two against Magnus uh with a
difficult Rook ending which he went on
to lose but today with this opposite
color bishop and we might very well be
seeing it as you're pointing out it
looks like Vincent might survive this
one but he still has work to do speaking
about pure end games we have a pure ping
Pawn ending in the uh in the case versus
not a backboard let's just zoom out and
get our overview our bird's eye view of
the positions that are going on we've
got end games all around except of
course Fabi still playing against Jordan
as we can see in the bottom left here
with that exchange sacrifice the bishop
on E5 Still Remains C4 was the move
played Jordan still thinking in a very
difficult position meanwhile Arjun
versus Levon and this is a minor piece
endgame a pure minor piece end game with
a good Bishop versus a bad Knight these
let me tell you are so difficult to
defend and notice White's weaknesses the
pawn on E3 the pawn on G3 they're all on
dark squares easy targets for black so I
think levon's going to be grinding this
down and then we've got the Prague
versus Vincent which we just just
discussed I want to take your attention
to gkesh and not it back all the pieces
are traded off we've got a porking Pawn
ending and let's Deep dive into that one
and see if either of the players have
any chances because Robert usually in a
King Pawn ending the side with a double
Pawn is under a massive disadvantage
when I see a reval bar and it says that
yes despite black practically being upon
up on the queen side it's still equal
yeah the reason why is because white can
spring free a past Pawn if black tries
to win let's just make a bunch of moves
where the King goes this way
whoa what
what oh I guess the eval bar just
freaked out for a second I was like did
I make a mistake no uh King just King C3
King E7 King back King back so the point
is if the King goes all the way this way
at some point white is going to play for
F4 and
it looks really promising for white
right because you are threatening this
Pawn if black takes now white will be
able to get a pass Pawn on the king side
but wait a second let's say I go A6 and
you take here
what past Pawn is white ever going to
get why it's up a pawn in this position
but practically speaking you're down
upon because G6 is covered this one Pawn
covers two of White's pawns so it is
essentially white being down upon over
here on the queen side even though white
is up a pawn with the pawn on G5 it's a
very weird dynamic Tanya but that's what
happens when you have double Pawns in
the end game they don't actually help
each other whereas if you had an F Pawn
it would help spring free a passer with
double e pawns with double G pawns you
can't do that
that's such a unique kingpong end game
and this idea makes me feel that why
can't why why can't guesh just
immediately go for E3 F4 trying to free
up his double pawns trying to create a
parcel before that black activity that
you were pointing out on the queen side
happen don't waste time with King moves
go E3 go F4 and make sure that Black's
King is just stuck on the king side
right because you want to get this very
quickly and something else we should
note is that two white pawns can take
care of three black pawns if I put A4 at
some moment and you put A6 you're not
getting your past pawn and in fact
you're gonna lose the game because I
could play A5 and if you play B5 now I
can successfully take in one two three
thank you very much that's a queen and
if you take this Pawn on A5 then the
white king is too fast it's gonna go up
this way I guess somehow it's saying the
king C3 that's gone up and down but it's
winning for sure I don't use this evil
bar to tell me that the white king just
runs and wins the pawns and wins the
game and you still will have E3 F4 and
the least those are you know Tempo moves
to toss to move back to the opponent but
the black king is way way way too far
away to deal with all of this stuff and
this is what I meant once we get here I
just go King A5 and if I need to lose a
Tempo I could push my E Pawn but I don't
need to do that because the King goes to
B5 wins the upon and we have an extra
Pawn that's a passer so my long story
short is that the two White ponds will
take care of this B5 square and so black
cannot actually create a passport over
here and after King G7 one of my other
questions if one Pawn take excuse me two
pawns take care of three can white even
think about bringing the king over here
because if I play this with F4 and you
take and I get here I'm just wondering
if in some universes you can go after
the pawn on H4 I'm not sure
it's very possible I think black has to
keep the King close to the Jeep on you
want the option to play King G6 when
required when white does make the move
F4 so some really interesting Dynamics
in this King Pawn ending at first it
feels that if anyone should be able to
try It's gotta be black with those two
double pawns but in fact with these
ideas of a for blocking those three
pawns on the queen side and E3 F4
targeting the king side it's actually
black that needs to be careful here with
the King moves deciding where you want
to place the king this could be Gucci's
chance and it's not a back who has to
play a very precise King Pawn end game
it's a role reversal of the Olympiad
where uh gukesh was better and
overpressed if no deerback overpresses
he could lose this game but it does look
like it still remains in the balance it
should be a split point with proper play
so
oh we're gonna take a moment here
because the players are nearing the tide
Patrol we're gonna take a quick break
before we hit that moment uh but before
we do
uh you know we're just going to reset
relax and ask you are you trying to get
your friends into chess because now you
can challenge any iOS user with the
chess.com iMessage app your friend
doesn't need an account just tap and
play text an old friend a family member
or your crush but you have no idea how
to talk to head over to go.chess.com
iMessage or use the command message in
chat to learn how we'll be right back
for more from round three of the 2023
Tata seal Chess Masters
foreign
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
who is next that's the question that
everyone wants answered will it be one
of these two players we see on screen
pragnanda or Vincent kymer they're not
really next they're the current
generation of talent they may be young
in age but their chest strength speaks
for itself they are above 2700 I guess
they're not technically above 2700 but
everybody considers them that and we see
the rising stars of this year's Edition
Tanya we're very familiar with them at
this point
this is the youngest ever Tata steel
Masters and that is saying something
when you've got the youngest ever
daughter steel Masters also being the
strongest avatar steel Masters just goes
on to show the strength of this young
wave of talent and that's what we've
been seeing Robert for the last year
over the pandemic just what a mark
they've made in the established Elite
world of Chess from pragna nanda's
phenomenal performance at the Champions
Chester nehal Serene going into the
finals of the global championship and of
course the Olympian which was the
breakout moment really for this new wave
this new generation that is marking
their claim at the top spot in the Chess
World with the very youngest baking team
taking the gold medal and also the
youngsters from India it was the India B
team comprising of many players who are
currently playing in the Tata steel a
group who took the bronze medal and
right now the two players that we've got
in front of us are the two Front Runners
Vincent Kamer with his win at the
grandkid Masters a meteoric rise for our
generic SC this is the chess we love
where you've got these hungry hungry for
Success hungry for opportunity talents
of the world fighting against what is
the best that the Chess World has to
offer yes and sometimes you get punished
when you play the best players in the
world we saw that happen with gukesh in
rounds one and two he lost a dingley
wren with the white pieces then hit
black against nishikiri and that was
great prep and great ideas and execution
by Anish so the youngsters they can
punch above their age range but
sometimes they face that experience that
strong preparation that's been years in
the making and it can cause them
problems but in this matchup between two
teenagers it looks like now that the
dust has settled a bit uh White is
currently up a couple pawns the D5 Pawn
is loose these are double isolated but
also past pawns and you have it outside
pass Pawn as well so black does need to
be careful here this is not just some
kind of easy draw nothing of the sort a
move that comes to mind is Knight to B5
over here trying to protect the D5 Pawn
by giving a check a fork on C7 but then
I think the Black Knight jumps out to C5
the king does the knights task of
blockading the pawns and putting
pressure on these pawns and the A4 Pawn
so Tanya I just feel like the white
pawns are going to fall at least one of
them and if that's the case then Vincent
is getting closer and closer to holding
this half point
he's such a fighter Robert Winston has
shown in difficult positions uh the kind
of resistance he can put up in round two
against Magnus he got into trouble early
on but really made a life difficult for
the world champion and this one as well
after coming into a lot of pressure out
of the opening uh he is fighting back in
an opposite color bishop and gay which
gives him hope he's getting closer but
still there's a lot of work to be done
and as you were mentioning of course
what the youngsters have in ambition and
hunger often lack in experience and
that's why these elite players of the
world like Anish when they're playing
against they want to make the most of
these opportunity as they say Pita
Wonder young
that is certainly necessary for some of
these players because all there is a
farooia you need to beat him when he was
like 10 years old because now he's
nearly 2 800. but let's actually zoom
out from this game because we do have
many interesting end games that are
ongoing and as we look at them things
have changed in the game between Levon
aronian and Arjun aragaisi it's bishop
and three pawns against Knight and three
pawns that's the center game on the
bottom row it says better for black
because you have an outside pass pawn
and knights are short range pieces
Bishops are long range and we maybe
we'll dive into that in a second but I
first want to go to the pawn end game
the king and pawn and game between
gookesh and Abdul sitarov because they
have been trying to make progress in
this position and I want to put this on
the board because I think there are some
nuances here that are really important
for people who are learning the end game
the move just played with King to C7 it
was Black's turn you can't move any of
your pawns you couldn't do that if
Kingdom B5 is played King B7 and the
King just goes back now the black king
goes to C6 and if you bring your king
back here you see the evaluation drop
because black is going to get a pass
Pawn now just because you get a pass
point doesn't mean the game is over and
the reason why is if you go B4 check and
I just wait for your king to approach A5
and I go King A2 and you go King A5 then
I go King B3 and your king can't get in
and if your king can't get in your Pawn
can't go forward so I'm just trying to
show different situations where even
though there's a clean past Pawn you
might not actually be able to use it to
your advantage because of a blockade so
we are seeing King B5 King B7
and if F4 is played Black I do not think
is going to be taking this Pawn because
if you take the pawn you see Sky High
evaluation you have given white some
opportunity to create a password if King
C7 F5 you just want to sit and wait good
for you I take and then my g-pawn is
running and you can't stop it so this is
really important you give up your Pawn
on G5 you just move your king away after
politics you move your king back because
this Pawn cannot go anywhere this Pawn
cannot go anywhere black has everything
under control despite being a pawn down
sorry Tonya I just really wanted to
emphasize that point
this was a master class that you just
gave and of such importance because
really King Pawn endings are super
instructive and you pointed out and
highlighted all the important factors in
this one how black keeps it under
control on the queen side making sure
that white skin cannot Advance any
further from B5 after you go King B7 it
doesn't even matter if you take your
king to A6 black will have the the move
King to C6 and you've got everything
sorted there but the more important
point is how do you handle the king side
and super super critical to make sure
that you understand the idea that the G5
Pawn can simply be given up why it can
be a pawn up but cannot go on to make
any more progress even if this position
was to come black falls back with the
King to C7 and after King B5 will not be
able to repeat
to repeat anymore not to repeat but not
to be able to take on G5 and make any
more progress and uh Robert I think this
one will end in a draw uh in a King Pawn
ending that required Precision but both
players have shown that they're up for
it and their end game knowledge is on
point and yeah there's one last point I
want to make is if you play F5 you see
again the evaluation change because Pawn
takes Pawn takes white maybe thinking
about getting a queen but black actually
sacrifices a pawn it's not about Pawn
quantity in many end games it's about
the quality H6 G4 H3 the black pawn gets
the other side whereas white doesn't get
there because if you take the king is
already in the Square so you're not
going to make a queen if you play F6 the
King goes back and now the king is in
the other Square your G Pawn is too slow
because H2 H1 is a queen in just a
couple turrets so I just wanted to point
all these little things out they're very
important and we are going to see a draw
very shortly I think we might see this
draw after the king C6 Pawn G5 King C7
Wilson with King A7 and these moves are
going to be forced back and forth King
C6 to C7 King A6 to A7 because if the
white king decided to go back to B5 King
B7 and you bring your king back and we
get this situation where the king drops
back you see black is now suddenly
winning because you have a past Pawn so
even though white is a pawn a head black
is not playing B4 I showed why that
doesn't work you take on C4 and then put
King B6 the king will have to move at
some point soon the King goes up I push
my opponent to keep doing that use the
pawn as a decoy and this king is going
to full Pac-Man and take all of these
pawns on the king side
Robert you're you've just called out the
whole game because as you were pointing
out the players realized these lines and
we're seeing the current position with
King C7 and very important that after
King A7 King C6 white also doesn't have
the option to go King B8 trying to come
from the other side he's too slow
getting over to the king side because
black just goes on to Queen the sea pawn
and it's going to be a lot faster and
there we see King A7 has been played on
the board King C6 King A6 it's the only
way it's almost like a mutual song with
only one good move for both players and
this will end in handshakes but a nice
technique there by gokish and by Noddy
back with this draw gokish finally
starts on the leaderboard and there it
is the draw is agreed no progress could
be made these two youngsters they're
talking about the game they will see so
much more of each other I hope that
they're friends because they're gonna go
face to face for decades to come but in
this particular game progress was
stalled no side couldn't inch into the
other person's position any more than we
saw a draw was the correct result Tanya
I think it was a well played game and
for good cash you know he could take a
bit of a breath he has made a draw he's
done the scoreboard and now 10 Rounds
remain take it game by game
these two players have such a bright
future ahead of them and Robert you're
absolutely right along that path they
will face each other time and time again
and every time that they've played so
far it's been fighting chess and this
game also coming down to a King Pawn end
game where it was forced into a
repetition just goes on to show that
neither of them are willing to back down
and they stay on the board to analyze
the subtleties of the position this goes
on to show how chess always wins and
their priority is to get stronger and
regardless of how competitive they are
on the board once it's over the main
motive is to get stronger and to get
better
absolutely so these two uh they shake
hands and they're going to talk about it
for a while I mean it was an interesting
game lots of subtleties that when you
just quickly press the next button and
you're you know just clicking next move
next move next one you don't analyze as
much and so for these but they want to
talk about see what their thoughts were
see what the other player was thinking
and it's just such a good sight to see
honestly because these two players are
the future of Chess they're the
president of Chess no dear Beck is an
Olympiad gold medalist with his team uh
gookest won the Olympiad gold medal for
board one ahead of all of the best
players on the planet so these two are
just magnificent chess players great
human beings and they are going to be
role models for the next generation of
Chess Superstars but with that game in
the books we still have three games
remaining the other two teenagers are
facing off in prognanda and bitsychimer
our generic icy he's trying to survive
against Lavon aronia in in that game so
Tanya I feel like with Jordan van four
struggling you know it looks like he's
going to go down
um in that one against Fabiano maybe we
should tune into the end game between
Arjun and Lavon
absolutely and we see the two youngsters
still continue to discuss their games
out I wouldn't be surprised if you again
see the Arbiters intervene and say it's
time to go back the other games are on
uh but right now they're just involved
in their discussion what also is amazing
about nordeback and gkesh is just how
modest and kind they are off the boards
they are extremely soft spoken and
whenever you talk to them it's always a
pleasant feeling you tend to forget just
how strong they are over the board and
their Killer Instinct that they have to
win every single game but for now that
one ended in a draw and this one is
going to be a tough one for Arjun he is
trying to save half a point we've been
talking about the importance of a good
Bishop against a knight in an end game
where you've got bonds alive on both
sides but as there are few and few pawns
left an important point to note Robert
is that Black's H Pawn is of the wrong
color and what do I mean by that what I
mean is that black has got a dark
squared Bishop but take notice of that
H1 square that is a light color Square
which means that if every Pawn got
traded if white was let's say to
sacrifice his Knight for the a pawn and
somehow managed to pick up the g-pawn
even if black was ahead by a piece this
end game would end in a draw so this is
a motive that white definitely has in
mind as a defensive resource I'm glad
you brought that up because I think
people are tired of when I say that
that's my favorite thing to mention on
broadcast is Bishop and Rook ponds the
good news for Lavon though is the a pawn
is actually the correct color with this
bishop so if the a pawn is left then you
can win if the H Pawn is left as Tony
was just saying you're not going to be
winning the game even if you're a full
bishop and pawn ahead just chess that's
a theoretical draw so how does Arjun
approach this I would think about
bringing my king in opposition With the
Enemy King because what does Lavon want
to do move his King out the way and push
that pawn up the board Knights are
notoriously bad at dealing with the side
of the board they're slow moving pieces
and they can't lose a tempo as a bishop
can so if there's a position where it's
best to pass the turn a knight can't do
that while a bishop can so uh King C4
comes to mind Tanya just to keep the
king boxed in but maybe this King can
also start running towards the enemy
pawns on the king side if the white king
goes after the A6 Pawn the black king
May Venture on over to the king side
one thing white has to really try and do
in this position is create his own town
to play with the E Pawn you need to try
to March it down the board as quickly as
you can to put pressure like you
mentioned Robert the Knight is a bad
piece to defend an outside passer not
just that the defensive resource of
sacrificing your peace to play for that
wrong colored Rook Pawn Square in this
position gets trickier and that's
because of the double bonds that white
has on G2 G3 just imagine how do you
ever trade off Black's G7 Pawn it's next
to impossible for white spawn to trade
off that G7 Pawn so the defensive
resource is super hard to achieve so
what white has to focus on is to create
counter play with the e-pawn as well as
delay blacks Advance as much as possible
I like your idea of King C4 and if black
continues with King A3 white should
already think about pushing his own Pawn
pawns go E4 go E5 and at some opportune
moment and sacrifice your night for the
Apon go in with your king all the way to
F7 and that's how you can try and hold
this game yeah that King can go all the
way to F7 that you are definitely going
to get this G pawn and the Knight will
have to take care of the a pawn but
that's notoriously difficult so we see
the eval bar saying 0.7 it's not that
straightforward for white in many of
these positions because let's just go
forward with uh King to C4 and I'm just
gonna make a move like Bishop f8 uh
turns out was a terrible move so let's
take it back uh Bishop G5 let's attack a
pawn okay sure the Knight has to go back
to F1 I play A5 E4 so we're getting sort
of what we're talking about E5 King to
B2 if this King goes to B5 and takes
this Pawn
I'm wondering now if the white king is
too far away and the black king can even
actually
almost trapped this Knight and go after
these pawns over here that's what I was
aiming for when I was describing it
earlier is you know you have fun with
this Pawn over here and maybe I just win
the pawn and then go this way but the
point is that white king is very far
away from the remaining action
this is why it's best hope and this will
be the plan that I think we will see
Arjun go in with will it be good enough
to hold or not uh time will tell Levon
will of course push this to the end it's
a game that he's playing for two results
Arjun is the one who needs to be precise
this is a big game
it certainly is and they've already
reached move 40 which means that they
have received that extra time and
there's plenty of time on their clocks
for now so let's zoom out once again I
know there are going to be intricacies
in every single end game I love end
games personally I find them so much fun
to look at and to dissect uh and we'll
see how Arjun how much fun he has in
trying to make this draw but for now
Lavon is in the driver's seat but I was
noticing Tanya look at the game between
Fabiano and Jordan it's gone from bad to
worst to probably just completely lost
at this point
Fabi is the only one who's having fun in
that and deservingly so you just cannot
make a one move blunder against one of
the best players in the world I still
cannot believe Jordan missed that trick
after H4 that was truly the turning
point in the game and after that it's
just been all suffering for him the
current position Bishop D6 I really like
this move by Fabi getting rid of Black's
biggest Defender look at that King on f8
it is absolutely naked there with the F5
Pawn hanging if you were to trade on D6
white gets a super power on D6 not just
that Knight F5 in the air your king is
weak White's gotta got got a huge Pawn
on D6 C5 coming in for support this is
game over you haven't succeeded in
creating a single threat not just that
the queen on D5 the Knight on E3 control
the only soft spot in White's position
that is the Pawn on G2 and you just
cannot make anything out of the Queen
Under book no this is completely lost F5
is falling right now by the way white
has three pawns and this Knight for this
Rook over here that is a material
advantage a fourth Pawn is falling the
King on f8 is looking like him like a
checkman at any moment and if you take
on D6 and give me a pass Pawn you're
gonna be stuck block hating it and you
probably will successfully do that so
Fabiano caruana is completely winning
thanks to a massive blunder from Jordan
Von Forest the position was unclear they
were struggling but then the struggle
was no more once he blundered his Pawn
on G4 and I'm just gonna quickly show
that moment once more if you're tuning
in this move H4 hanging the pawn on G4
because Queen G6 would be Checkmate the
pawn on H5 was defending this Pawn on G4
a really tragic blunder for Jordan and a
great win for Fabiano he doesn't care
how it happens the fact that he's
winning is the most important thing so
just to show that checkmate
for everybody to see the bishop was
doing the heroes work the queen swoops
in and that would be made so Tanya
really unfortunate for Jordan I think he
is going to be very hard on himself
after the first three games of this
tournament
hopeless position that he has right now
and I am certain that thoughts of
resignation are already in his head how
do you control everything it's
impossible you can think about a move
like Rook F6 trying to defend the F5
Pawn but then white jumps in with the
queen to the Central Square of E5 and
again your position completely falls
apart if you can just have that on the
board Robert just to show how big a mess
this really is for the black pieces Rook
F6 trying to say that I'm not going to
give you a pass Pawn I will defend my F5
Pawn but after Queen E5 everything falls
apart your Rook on F6 hangs the bishop
on E7 hangs and Jordan finally decides
to make the move Queen E6 offering a
queen trade why just needs to be
slightly careful and don't get greedy by
picking up that F5 Pawn with the Knight
because Knight F5 would be absolute
disaster Queen E1 would be checkmate
that would be the worst one boot blunder
we might have ever seen But Fabiano
caruana and he's nearing the time
control it's moved 40 he takes on E6 and
this should be very simple from here
because once The Rook takes back on E6
Knight takes an F5 getting a fourth
extra Pawn hitting this bishop so you
have to take on D6 otherwise white goes
into a winning King and pawn end game
and after Bishop takes Pawn takes you
have a password that's game over Fabiano
caruana you know is just going to move
these pawns up the board and win the
game is so many extra pawns the Knight
Against The Rook is just too much so
unfortunate for Jordan but C takes D6 is
very simple right now
and you don't even have an option to
stop the pawns from rolling down the
board if we just play on a couple of
moves after Bishop D6 C takes D6 you
can't go King j8 King E8 because there's
a fork on G7 Knight G7 wins The Rook
wins the answering King Pawn end game so
you have to actually give a check on E1
before you move the king and then King
comes to F2 now if you go Rook C1 D7
probably wait with D7 because Rook to D1
might be a little tricky after that I
was very excited about D7 here I was
just showing your point that the king
can't get to uh the E7 Square because
the Knight covers it and also the Knight
covers D4 so your point still certainly
holds uh as long as you don't rush with
D7 because then The Rook comes back to
D1 to grab the pawn and still white
should be winning because you could take
this Pawn H4 and you have three passers
with that Knight so you can blunder your
most advanced pass pawn and still be
winning but Fabiano he doesn't want to
make any mistakes at this point I wonder
what exactly he's thinking about would
he really take on D6 with the Knight
that just looks wrong so C takes D6 is
automatic but he hasn't played it yet C
takes D6 I'm just to finish what I was
saying raw but after C takes D6 rookie
one king F2 we were pointing out that
Rook C1 doesn't have a threat because
once you take on C4 there's D7 but even
if you go Rook D1 the C Pawn just
advances down the board let's say Rook
D1 C5 and King E8 is not in time because
white gets in C6 and it just looks like
white is rolling down the boy God and I
am equally surprised that Fabi hasn't
just blitzed out C takes D6
why is he thinking in this position
maybe he's just composing himself he
reached move 40 he doesn't need to rush
um he's enjoying it it's the first time
all tournament where he's had an
advantage and now he has a huge
Advantage so he's just taking stock of
the position completely winning for him
he's going to take c66 I I just can't
imagine a world where you don't take
with this Pawn advancing towards the
other side and creating two past pawns
with one move
I don't know maybe
um is he really thinking about Knight
takes D6 I have a hard time believing
that
I don't think so I think it's just a
professional approach they've just made
time control it is the 41st move yes he
knows he's completely winning but these
guys are pros and they just want to calm
down compose after making that time
control he did have enough time on the
clock anyway but I I like it that
regardless of how winning he is he
continues the correct way to play right
after you've made time control you
always take it easy you always just calm
yourself down and then make the next
move eventually he does go on to pick up
the bishop with the C5 Pawn of course
that's what he decided in the first 10
seconds but he just first takes a deep
breath and Jordan I mean he makes this
move Rook E1 check King comes to F2 and
it's clear the look on his face says it
all but also the position does the
talking because King to E3 we keep
talking about if you take this Pawn on
C4 D7 happens the Knight takes away the
king's square and that means the king
can't stop the pawn so if the king just
joins the party with King E3 to D4 your
pawns are going to be pushing along with
the king's help it seems like there's
nothing that black can do once this King
reaches D5 it's completely over
and we see Jordan get up and leave the
board Fabi having a thing of course I
did blunder into D7 Fabi must not do
that even if it's winning after that you
just have to win the position all over
again don't do that I like your idea of
getting the king into the battle King E3
and once King goes to E8 your king comes
in to defend the C4 pawn and will also
support its March down the board this
looks like it's going to be a Fabby
point which means that he will move on
to two points and join a Magnus Carlson
thingler in uh there we see Jordan
return to the board return to the misery
that's been his game uh thus far
plundering that pawn on G4 and a nice
conversion but for me what really stands
out about this match has been fabi's
King H1 King G1 in a position where it
felt that he had everything he makes
these small moves and immediately we see
his opponent collapsing and that was a
very interesting moment uh King E3
played Jordan there shaking his head but
I get the feeling that he is going to
resign soon he makes the move King he
ate and expecting Fabi to continue with
the King march
King D4 is obvious now and I think
Jordan's gonna play a few quick moves
and then just resign uh but uh for
Fabiano this is a really important
victory for him because he did not have
a good 2022 In classical chess his Blitz
rating went through the roof right over
2800 uh I think it was number two in the
world in Blitz and during some of the
rating lists then at the world's rapid
Championship he ended up with a bronze
medal third place so he performed really
well in the quicker time controls he
also won some events he won the American
Cup which was a knockout event that was
classical chess he won the U.S
Championship which was also classical
but in the events that mattered right he
had played the candidates tournament
after the first half he was five out of
seven he did not know that Magnus
Carlsen was going to step down he
thought that Magnus for sure was going
to play because if he knew that Magnus
would not have been playing the World
Championship he would have sailed
through the second half and end up in
second place but he thought with yeah
100 certainty that magnets would play so
he needed to go all out and win it
completely backfired he stumbled down
the stretch losing many games uh in that
second half and then he had to pick up
the pieces from there his rating was
gone his chance of the world
championship title was gone he played in
the Olympiad performed very poorly there
uh hard to find motivation but then he
was able to write the ship later on so
uh for Fabiano I think gaining this
confidence uh trying to win this
tournament he needs this game right here
he's getting it and it's just step one
of a very long event
the candidates were so unique in that
aspect with magnus's decision and you
know one understands where that decision
came from it was a personal choice so
with what Magnus wanted to do uh with
regard to the world championship match
but Robert I always had the feeling that
that decision on him had to come before
the candidates and of course he did
nothing wrong because there was a
certain timeline by which he had to give
the answer whether he was going to play
the match or not and he respected that
and acted upon it but I just feel had
the timeline been different the
candidates would have been very
different as well because the players
would know what they were fighting for
was it a tournament where only the first
place mattered or was it a tournament
where you could come second and still
try for the world championship match uh
and these were of course questions from
the past and it's a lot of what-ifs but
the one thing that really stood out to
me was that uh
magnus's decision and fide's question
about Magnus whether Magnus wanted to
play the world championship or not this
was a call that had to be taken decided
upon and uh mentioned out before the
candidate started and maybe the deeper
and bigger question the overarching one
is is there really a world championship
without Magnus Carlson right I think
that has to play in people's minds Jana
palmchi and ding Loren will have an
opportunity to be crowned world champion
well we think we have no information
about it fide hasn't released anything
but even if there's a winner there it's
kind of unfortunate that most the public
is just gonna be like okay well you want
to match it was just a match against a
strong player not against Magnus Carlson
and Magnus is the best player and he
will remain the best player until
someone proves otherwise you know it
doesn't matter that he's not playing the
World Championship so uh this game here
is not for the world championship it's
just for the Tata steel chess tournament
I think we can zoom out from here
because Fabiano carawanna for sure will
win this game as he marches his pawns up
the board and
I thought there was going to be a
handshake but not yet but we do have the
two other games we're in the end game
Tanya looks like on the bottom right
it's no longer an extra Pawn for
prognanda
and it looks like it's all fizzling up
they're on D6 as we can see and it's
still very much alive but Knight jumping
onto C4 there are attacks there it
definitely looks like everything's fine
for Winston a meanwhile arjun's bought
the center board against Levon let's
take a look at that you've got the
double Pawn still on the G file white
did goking C4 this was the line that we
were calling out Robert it has happened
it will be all about white creating
Chances with the e-pawn and Black's King
coming over to the other side with the
March that you were talking about with
King A3 King B2 meanwhile white has to
create his own chances pushing that E
Pawn down the board it's going to be all
about timing and Precision in this one
levon's still pushing but I think
arjun's close enough to make a draw yeah
it seems that way and the King for white
is going to have to deal with the a pawn
because the Knight is far away it takes
a lot of time so I I just want to look
at that again King A3 E4 let's say we go
A5 and don't actually give you the pawn
because earlier I was saying the king
would win this and the black king would
do all that stuff so let's say after E5
y plus A4 the problem appears is King C3
and
somehow white is better now because the
bishop is tied to this pawn and the king
is going to be stuck here so she's E6
Knight E3 and the tides turn in White's
favor that's amazing I was just kind of
making moves mindlessly but you can't do
that in a position like this and look at
Lavon he goes King to a five Tanya he
says I'm gonna go King B6 and I'm gonna
make your task more difficult if you
want this Pawn you're gonna really have
to come and get it and then the black
king will Sprint on over towards the
center and the pawn is still not
Advanced very far
that's a really cool idea what love has
done and it actually makes a lot of
sense let's just try and play a couple
of moves and see what Lavon has in mind
let's try and get into his brain right
now Robert let's say you go E4 King B6
E5 you go King C6
and what you really want to do is go
King the seven King E6 next now white
skin cannot go all the way to the king
side because the a pawn will be
unstoppable then so let's say you play
Knight to H2 trying to activate the
Knight the only Square available King to
D7
I still don't care about King D5 because
my a pawn will be strong enough Knight
F3 or Knight G4
and now you get your king to E6
you can't ever take on G5 a King Pawn
ending will be dead lost this will be
game over because White's King is way
too far and distracted with the a pawn
but let's back up let's say white skin
starts the March along to pick up the A6
Pawn King C5 or King B4 come to mind uh
you say your knight is defending the E5
Pawn but now what black wants to do is
get the bishop into the game you can go
Bishop to C1 Bishop to B2 pick up that
E5 Pawn meanwhile white will win the A6
Pawn but the king will be super far away
black will simply come up with the King
to G4 also win the G3 pawn and this is
what love has in mind King A5 a
retreating move with the King
counter-intuitive play in the end game
when you retreat with your king but what
a try
yes and what white needs to do is get
this Pawn with the Knight you mentioned
this earlier so in this position if the
white king is in fact able to and I
don't even know if we let the king
approach the B6 Square uh I think
actually you can keep it out directly
and just win the pawn on E5 your
variations are just so strong right now
and if the king went to B4 first I think
we can keep the king out this way with
Bishop d8 Bishop C7 take E5 uh by the
way Fabiano caruana has officially won
that game against Jordan fund Force no
surprises there but a win in the books
for Fabi
that's a huge win he LeapFrogs standing
with two points now on the leaderboard
and uh felt like a gift really by Jordan
this one playing that move H4 and giving
up the pawn and with that essentially
Landing up in a lost position uh we also
have
we have five games that have ended so
far with four draws and one win for Fabi
Richard rapper Wesley so ends in a draw
good case not a back what a fight came
down to a King Pawn ending both players
holding their own that ended in a draw
the first game was between the world
number one and world number two which
finished and Anish and Parham was also
even Steven
it was and the two games remaining there
could be two more draws and that means
Fabiano's the happiest player of today's
action to be the only winner but we
still have two games left to look at and
we'll have some great matchups for
tomorrow as well I mean that's the cool
thing about this event 14 players 13
Rounds and every round promises fun
Fighting Chess but
at the moment we see the standings as
they currently exist round three still
in progress some of the players like
levona Ronin here trying to jump to that
first place tie will he be able to take
down Arjun aragaisi with whom he shares
one out of two on the leaderboard that's
the big question and Tanya I'd really
like his position I'm just not convinced
there's enough material remaining based
on what we've been talking about based
on how using the night Wellness
sacrifice itself for the g-pawn but I
also trust Lavon I feel like he is so
much experience and his technique
usually is superb that in an end game
like this if there's a tricky path to go
down I feel like it's going to be
difficult for Arjun
but we've also seen Origins
resourcefulness right he always goes for
the dynamic way to defend so I think
he's definitely thinking about this idea
of eventually when the e-pawn gets
traded off for the a pawn if that is a
lot the night sacrifice will come Arjun
will try to make it we see our eval bar
so he's still pretty much in the
perimeter of a draw the it's not a lost
position yet Knight to H2 was his last
move he wants to get the Knight into the
game expecting black to play out the
line that we were talking about here but
Lavon slows down and I'm just wondering
if he's thinking about advancing his
spawn is he thinking about the move A5
does that change the Dynamics in the
position
that's I think if I want A5 I need my
Bishop on E7 so I can put it all the way
down on A3 if you get your Pawn to A3 I
think you're just winning so I want to
show that let's say A5 Knight F3 Bishop
to E7 I make some kind of random move A4
and I make another move like Knight C2
A3 and the King comes back the reason
why I think this is winning is because
if you take here the black king will end
up winning this Pawn so King and pawn
and games are often just winning for
black as the white pieces are distracted
to the flank while the enemy pieces the
black pieces here go towards the center
um so you you this position also is kind
of a standstill you can't make progress
the king can't go to these squares so
you could probably even throw in a king
C6 first but this is what Lavon
undoubtedly wants he desires a way to
get his Bishop to E7 and pawn up the
board so 91 was a silly move but let's
say go Knight D4 after A4 now Knight F5
happens and we get get what we're
looking for the Knight attacking the
g-pod and the King going after this Pawn
on A4 but yeah it's not the end of the
story exactly especially if the black
king could Sprint on over to the F2
Square to make this draw that we keep
talking about I'm just gonna show it
because I think it's much easier if we
do it this is losing but I'm gonna make
it a draw so everyone let this happen
for a second
all right here you see it
it happened whatever some random move
this position here the bishop has can go
to C5 so you don't make it but this is
what we need is I'm not going to do it
I'm just making the draw that we keep
talking about and the King just sits in
the corner no matter what the king is
going to stay in these squares so you
can go ahead and pick off these Pawns
over here but the white king is going to
keep going back and forth if you go King
F2 it's stalemate immediately how else
do you make progress in fact you can't
move your Bishop somewhere King back
King here King here you bring your king
in you give this check the King goes to
the corner it's stalemate apparently
this is what oh my gosh is this some
kind of crazy win
I think the point is that at some point
you'll be forced to push your pawn and
get my Pawn onto the G file there'll be
some G4 G5 but these are super
complicated end games Robert the most
important point is that white has to get
the king to H1 at the right time and as
we can see it's still not over
yeah I'm gonna just put the position
that uh we've been talking about
essentially if you get this position it
is a draw theoretical draw I'm sorry it
took us through Whirlwind to get here
this position with Bishop Pawn wrong
color Corner Square this is a
theoretical draw where the white king
just stays in the corner and there's
nothing black can do about it you can
look it up uh Bishop in Rook Pond versus
King this is a draw and it just goes to
show that there are tricky ways and we
saw the eval bar going uh you know back
and forth up and down that there might
be some ways where black still wins and
they often revolve around forcing this
Pawn to go up to G5 and then being able
to take that pawn in that manner I think
this still is a draw here but it just is
uh important to note what the long-term
vision is and this is what Arjun wants I
know we've gotten away from the game it
would seem but that's what Arjun is
really thinking can I get this Pawn give
up my knight for this pawn and then
bring my king to the corner that's what
he's thinking give out we promise you
that's definitely a peak into arjun's
brain right now and as we can see the
two players it is still an end game
that's full of life as is the other one
and Robert while the players have a
think on how they're going to save this
difficult position which has which is so
rich with all these complexities we're
going to go into a shot break and be
right back
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on
come on chess.com is excited to announce
the community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream the and your stream will
be linked to your games on our play
server type command Community streamer
in chat and start growing your stream
today
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun and look at
the intense focus on magnus's face what
a performance it has been
once again Vicon say starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
the tournament and it is yours and fun
for race winning the dramatic Armageddon
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here as a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steep in Prestige and Legacy and does so
again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
[Music]
and return to the playing Hall in
Vikings a Vince camut making his move
his game against prognanda still in
session he has been fighting tooth and
nail to try to hold this half Point
Tanya he kind of looks like he's been
through it it feels like he's a player
who's been exhausted by playing first
Magnus Carlson yesterday now the black
side of this game against Prague none
today so I feel for Vincent
he's so close but he still has to make
sure that he plays precisely till the
very end in this one uh Robert you know
the worst is behind him in this event
with the kind of playing field every
half Point matters and he's going to go
all out he's going to give it his best
to save that uh save that half a point
he's been in trouble for the majority of
the game he's been playing down upon but
it looks now the situation has a
liquidated and let's take a look at our
leaderboard So currently Prague and
Vincent the game is still on but we've
got Magnus Fabi Anish Ding and not a
back at two points going into round four
meanwhile Wesley Parham Richard are at
Richard is at one point and Levon still
plays Levon still trying to win his game
against Arjun but it looks like that one
as well as inching towards a draw
we're sure and Vincent in his game he
would love to be able to get that half
point and get the white pieces once more
and as you're talking about Lavon and
Arjun Arjun he has shown great defensive
skills throughout the first two days now
in day three he needs to hold that to
the end but let's first dive in to the
game between Prague Nanda and Vincent
the last moves that were played we left
off a little while back but the black
king was running towards the center and
the bishop ran back to D2 and after
Knight C5 A5 now the D5 Pawn was taken
and Bishop B4 Knight A6 why did he give
up the pawn that's the big question
because after Knight B8 Knight C6 is
kind of a threat it sounds weird to
frame it like that Tanya but trading off
the knights should be an immediate draw
so because pragmundo wants to play on he
jumped with his Knight to F5 and then
into E7 attacking this bishop but the
bishop went to B7 and now Knight C6 is a
threat you put that in air quotes
because there's a wind material but it
will liquidate attacking the pawn A5 and
threatening the Knight on E7 so that's
why Prague G3 and after Knight C6 moved
his Knight back to D5 giving up the a
pawn
and then we had a check with the Knight
on F6 still trying to be a pawn up still
winning that pawn on 8-7 but the problem
with the piece placement is that after
Knight eight seven black has a nice
reply Robert now you can take advantage
of the disc coordination between White's
forces let's say proc picks up that pawn
on H7 black has the option Winston is
considering to go Knight C4 and that's
what I'm expecting and the problem is
that you don't have a good Square for
the bishop you can go to either B4 or C5
either way is the geometry of the
position is such that this gives black
the option to go Knight E5 threatening a
fork on D3 threatening a fork on G4
either winning the H2 Pawn or driving
the bishop away and in this way Vincent
can keep the material balanced which is
why he gave this position a long thought
before deciding to retreat with the King
to d8 it is the most accurate move in
the position getting away from all night
checks a retreating move by the king so
that the king is super safe on d8
because if the king went up to E6 to
your point there could be a knight G5
check with a fork of King and pawn so he
stayed out of Harm's Way by going back
to d8 and as you were indicating in this
line no matter which Square the bishop
goes to the Knight can always hop back
to E5 with this fork with this Fork of
King and pawn and if you run with your
king to jump out of the fork you could
even play Bishop A6 check this move
seems pretty straightforward if the King
goes here you check it when the pawn if
the King goes at f2 you lose a piece and
thus the game thank you very much so I
feel like with all these with the jumpy
Knight they can't keep trying to run
somewhere but eventually black will put
the King on D7 and go after this Pawn on
D6
it's really a great geometry here and
how Black's Knight is actually
dominating White's bishop and there are
no good squares poor white species which
is why Prague is taking his time before
he picks up the 87 Pawn he knows he gets
a pawn but loses complete coordination
between the pieces
right so the king is on d8 and the pawn
A7 has not been captured yet so Prague
is thinking well if I do that the Knight
will jump back into the game but he
can't stop Knight C4 as the next move
the good news though is if we just make
some kind of random a G4 Knight C4 and
the bishop comes to B4 now black is a
little bit Frozen your king can never go
up to D7 because of this Knight and F6
and so sometimes you just leave the
status quo with even material but you
just make your opponent's life as
difficult as possible he decides that
this still would remain even because the
Knight can come to E5 and maybe even
back to D7 so he takes on H7 at least
he's up a pawn but the Knight Will
quickly hop into C4
frog we saw him reach out for that Bond
on eight seven picks it up with the
Knight he is up upon but loses
coordination between his minor pieces
the black king on d8 I think that was
such a nice touch by Vincent finding
this move King to d8 and Robert this is
what separates these players because
their level of maturity is Way Beyond
their age it would be so easy to make a
move like King E6 and then you know your
margin of error keeps getting smaller
and smaller but here Vincent is getting
closer to the draw with his precise play
and I am expecting him to jump in with
the Knight to C4 I think that's the only
justification for his move King the
eighth yeah it looks the perfect defense
and one thing that Prague and being up
upon has going for him is if he he can
throw his pawns up very quickly maybe he
can get outside past Palm but that's why
the Knight comes to C4 and into E5
trying to Fork the bishop via the D3
square or fourth the pawn via the G4
Square so uh Vincent I know he was upset
after yesterday's loss to Magnus he is
really defended nicely in this game I
think many players would have already
lost to prognanda but he found all of
the resources he needed to
he's a fighter I've been saying it and
this I know uh from spending a lot of
time in commentary with Peter leco as
well who is Winston's trainer he has
been Winston's coach and Mentor for many
years and I think Winston's style of
play is greatly influenced by Peters as
well and we can see this in him the way
he fights his coordination between
pieces his positional strategic approach
to positions and in this one it looks
like Prague has tried everything that he
could but it's not been good enough
Winston's defenses withstand Frog's uh
offense here Knight C4 on the board and
now the Knight finds itself centralized
on the next move with Knight to E5 and
everything will be in control we've got
another game going on so let's see if we
can get a bird's eye view and get a
quick update on our two remaining games
let's pull that up here and we see that
levon's still trying to make his idea
work and as we've got only two games
remaining we also see the crowd
trickling out from the playing Arena
just a few Spectators left but there are
quite a few of them even though we're
well into the fourth hour of gameplay
and there we see Levon still fight it
out against uh Arjun who just like
Vincent is showing incredible resistance
really nicely done by Arjun his Knight
went back to then go forward and the
Knight is in the center here on D4 and
for Lavon playing A5 becomes difficult
now the king is pushed back and let's
think about a move here if you play E6
check and the King decides to step up to
D6 then Knight F5 and we take G7 and we
take H5 of course white is very happy to
win all those pawns and if you go to a
square like C7 I think the white king
can even come up the board here and
black needs to be a little bit careful
um if the Knight gets in here it's
attacking the bishop attacking the pawn
trying to promote you could find
yourself in a teeny little bit of danger
I don't think black has any actual
problems here but somehow white got
really active it feels like Arjun made
four free moves almost
I agree with you I mean the king marches
all the way to the center of the board
but arjun's having a think it's it's an
important moment for him E6 is a very
committed move when you've fought this
hard and you've come to this point where
you can feel that you're so close to
saving that half point you want to
really think through moves like E6
because they can prove to be a big
blunder in these positions of course
we've got the eval bar telling us once
you play E6 on the analysis board that
everything works out Robert but for
Arjun to make this move I think he's
going to still take some time uh and see
because if you move the king to D5 you
also need to keep in mind blacks Pawn
moving forward the a pawn let's say in
that line with E6 King C7 King D5 and
then suddenly you're looking at all A5
A4 A3 coming you really want your King
on C4 you want it to be in reaching
distance with that a pawn so it's going
to be interesting to see how Arjun
approaches it we look at him on the
screen his clock's running down he's
just leaned back on his chair he's not
even looking on the board he his his
attention looks like it's elsewhere but
one thing's clear and we've been saying
this again and again with our origin
regardless of where he's looking the
board is in his mind he is calculating
this position trying to get that defense
that we've been talking about about
giving up that night getting the king to
pick up the a pawn how does he make all
of that work
good question you know he he wants to
put every single detail in a perfect
little box nice and tidy and try to win
the game if you're thinking from
LeBron's perspective and From origin's
perspective you know you don't want to
just make a careless move that gives
Levon the upper hand so E6 is that big
decision that we keep talking about
because pawns do not move backwards and
bringing that King to D5 allowing A5 I
was wondering if Knight C6 with a fork
is good but suddenly I realized Bishop
B4 is available if you take on B4 the
pawn takes back you see the evaluation
drop we keep talking about this the
white king is getting distracted away to
the queen side whereas all the remaining
pawns are on the king side the black
king just walks right up and just to
show you How This Ends
the white king needs to be over on F2
even if it were on F2 the g-pawn could
push but it's too slow you just go and
win the pawn and you can protect your
second Pawn but that's not going to help
black can at some point I don't know if
G5 first was good or not you need to
count this one by one but if the King
goes here you can just push your Pawn
and I think we've reached a winning
position that no matter where the King
goes it's going to be losing because if
you go to the corner
and up you have to move H3 G3 check King
here H3 also works but that's the main
point is you're trying to Spring free
your passer and deliver a checkmate with
a new Queen
it's a really big moment for Arch in
this one and not easy I see our
evaluation it says that things are still
under control but all these lines that
you're pointing out Robert and all this
analysis that you're showing which
really brings out how difficult this end
game with such few pieces really is it's
not a clear path for Arjun we have all
these Concepts about how a draw can be
achieved but how to get there is
completely unclear when you're trying to
keep the king side under control as well
as the a pawn
if you don't play King D5 or you don't
play E6 how are you making Improvement
in this position as white or how are you
holding this position as why you've got
to make one of these two moves meanwhile
play for Levon is super easy he wants to
go A5 next
what is also a really standout Point has
been this super tricky plan of Life of
just walking back with the King and I
think that's really impressive it just
goes on to show what a classy player
Levon is there's a direct path which
would be soak which would be so obvious
for all of us you move forward with your
king try and get it closer to the king
Side Pawn but lemon actually changes
course and it is getting trickier and
trickier for Arjun to save this position
not easy at all regardless of what the
evaluation is
yeah it was just showing that he went
back with his King rather than up the
board and he brings his King back and I
think Arjun he has played very nicely to
this point you ask what other moves are
possible and we're like Knight F5 it
attacks the bishop and attacks the pawn
but G6 is good because if you take the
bishop you're in that lost King and pawn
ending and if you just have to move your
knight back then black pushes the pawn
to A5 King B5 looks good looks
sufficient but we just were talking
about this exact end game the bishop
supports the pawn the pawn supports the
bishop they're really good friends over
here and Knight C6 the king can always
go to E6 you're never going into this
end game with the king of the pawns
because black wins so this is just a
huge huge problem for origin as he
figures out can I afford to push my Pawn
forward can I bring my king away from
the enemy past Pawn but you can't do
nothing that's the critical point
and this is move number 45 he's got 15
more moves to make to meet time control
he's got 25 minutes remaining on the
clock and that can also be a fact there
because every move is super important
it's so important to be precise in this
situation as we can see that the players
are currently on the 45th move they have
completed the first time control 50
minutes was added to the clock they need
to make moves move 60 to get to the
final uh time edition of 15 minutes and
of course with every move with every
press of the clock they get a 30 second
increment but right now Arjun has burned
about 20 minutes on this move and that
just goes on to show how difficult this
moment is
because you can't take the move back
especially if it's a pawn push that pawn
is not moving back and it's not easy
here the eval bar it can mislead people
it can mislead me I'm speaking from
experience as well where I'm like okay
it's just a drone like hold up there may
be only one path to maintain that
material equality not Material quality
equality overall but in this case it is
all about the material and the ensuing
end game so E6 might be too committal
and it's process of elimination to some
extent King D5 Pawn E6 some kind of
knight move somewhere I don't think you
want to bring your king back to B3
because you're going in the wrong
direction uh maybe just Bishop C5 to
kick this Knight away and then bring the
king to E6 so you need to make a choice
and most moves you can just eliminate
off the bat they don't make so much
sense but I like lavon's strategy of
playing H5 he doesn't give white a
chance to push the pawn to G4 and then
he'll put his Pawn on G6 and that way
you have connected pawns you're also
taking away critical squares from the
White Knight
that we
that week six so all this while while he
was not looking at the board our generic
as he was calculating all the lines in
his head in his mind because otherwise
you never make such a move he's gone for
E6 it is the right approach we see our
eval Bar says everything is in Balance
after this and now King D6 bad idea as
we pointed out it runs into a fork
Knight F5 and the and white is doing
absolutely fine but the tricky question
is after King goes to C7 how will white
respond and will Arjun continue to play
out a precise resistance
foreign
has been played and you see Arjun once
again looking away from the board but we
know he's working hard and calculating
and it's all about this King going to D5
Knight to F5 is another option the
bishop slides up to F6 and then black
will play G6 next to boot the knight
from its Square that's why this Pawn
went to H5 if the pawn were on H6 you
couldn't push the pawn to G6 ever so
let's just go back to that moment I I
don't want to take it for granted it
seemed random at the time H5 but in
these positions where the Knight is
coming around to the F5 Square you can't
push the Jeep Pawn in the same exact
type of position because if you ever
push the G Pawn you'd lose H6 and if
white pushes the pawn to G4 here okay
the king is very fast so I'll bring the
king to D5 and threaten E5 but my main
point was that the pawn is not pushing
without the H Pawn going to H5 so I
think that Lavon had the foresight to
recognize that and push it immediately
that's an amazing point because that
just shows labs long Vision in this
position that he anticipated that white
will try to get the Knight on F5 and
when that happens he should be able to
make the move G6 without losing that
pawn on 86. so H5 was not a surface move
it wasn't a first thought of just
defending the Knight to G4 where it had
a much longer vision and that's what
we're seeing being played out now it's
not that easy for Arjun to make the move
a knight F5 it will always be pushed out
once the bishop moves Also let's point
out that after Knight F5 let's say the
bishop moves
to F6
and you can never make the move E7
because black then just simply a slides
with the King to D7 defends that pawn
from going to E8 from promoting and you
end up losing that pawn for free so it's
not something that you need to worry
about in the position
not in the slightest so Origins still on
the clock here
um but who's in front of the camera
there it's not Lavon so maybe it's an
arbor that's probably I don't know I was
probably I couldn't yeah I didn't see a
face I just saw a back essentially uh
but Prague he's playing down the hall
over there so just looking at his
friend's game and well speaking of
Prague in that game I wonder if any
progress has been made not really it's
just the position we were talking about
earlier so that's what happens at this
stage the players they received more
time 50 minutes were added to the clocks
at move 40. so until move 60 they have
to use that time that they gained then
when you reach move 60 you get an
additional 15 minutes the Tata steel
tournament uses the really traditional
classical time Patrol and I know some
people will say well that's so long why
do they they have so much time to play
it's because they play the best chess
that way when you you have one minute on
the clock to start your game bullet
chess well you're making sloppy moves
it's not really chess some people would
argue so they are just trying to allow
the game to be as beautifully played as
possible and somebody who has a
beautiful style who sees chess as an art
is Levon aronian he is trying to win
this game here and go to two out of
three tied for first in the standings
he's a four-time champion of this event
Tanya so he knows what it takes to win
games like this and to win tournaments
like this
he is playing somebody who is a front
runner of this new generation of chess
players while Lavon himself is the
oldest player in the field he's 40 years
old he has a rating of 2735 he's a
four-time champion of the tallest seal
Masters uh and of course this is a big
game for him he's trying to squeeze this
out but Arjun holding on to this one and
it's not going to be easy for Lev to get
a win out of this
not at all so the king is up on D5 we
keep talking about A5 and Bishop B4
these kind of ideas trying to help
protect the pawn but let's talk about it
A5 Knight C6 Bishop B4 you can't take
this bishop on B4 it's what we're
talking about so what can white do this
just to show you one more time is losing
because the black king grabs the e-pawn
and then quickly grabs the g-pawn we
just show that ending so if you can't
take on B4
you can't move the king you lose the
Knight you play E7 the king slides over
it says somehow it's still uh just about
level and maybe it's because the Knight
can't be captured kind of this might be
it wow I didn't see this in advance but
once we're here you can bring the king
back and the black king can't take
because then you promote
this is an amazing line and if you take
Bishop E7 you just go Knight A5 and hold
that without any problem because unlike
the other positions that we've been
seeing White's King is close enough to
the king side
right the king gets back over and with
the Knight on the board trying to
sacrifice for this G7 Pawn we've seen
how you can make a draw that you know as
long as these pawns come off the board
even if black is up a bishop that
position would be a draw you can't mate
with just King and Bishop versus King so
that's actually unbelievable that in
this position it is in fact E7 we were
saying earlier E7 is not a move you want
to play in so many different variations
but here you have King C4 and I would
play Bishop to E1 going after this Pawn
I don't think you want to lose the pawn
on the G3 square and black double Pawns
and you brought up this move and that's
the first one that came to my mind
because of a nice little Fork if you
take H takes G4 white has got the idea
to go Knight E5 and pick up the G4 Pawn
that's right you can just grab this Pawn
at any moment and I actually think this
might be just no progress because now
this is like
you can't take the Knight
I don't think I've ever seen this kind
of geometry or like not that I can
remember
but this is a beautiful spot Robert that
you just put your 9 on C6 you defend the
E Pawn which is an E7 Black's King is
stuck to it Black's Bishop is stuck to
defending the A5 pawn and Arjun once
again looking really relaxed it's almost
like he's seeing this line through
he doesn't seem stressed at all he
played the move E6 he's found to move
King D5 and now it's to be seen does
Levon go for A5 which almost seems like
it's Landing into this forced sequence
of moves that you've just pointed out if
not A5
do you see another alternative for left
to try to continue the pressure let's
say you make a move like G6 just
stopping Knight F5 in some situations
and keeping uh the position as is
I think still just Knight C6 and the
bishop moves somewhere let's say down to
A3 you can maybe even go after the
g-pawn but I was thinking you have to
have King D7 and I give you a check and
take the pawn
nice nice stuff
it looks like arjun's really inching
towards closing this one up
if he is able to get Knight C6 E7 then
yeah he found a very creative defense
here and A5 has been played so I wonder
how much time Arjun will take oh oh he
doesn't he doesn't take any time at all
and makes an inaccuracy
okay Knight B5 what is the idea here so
if the King goes to D to B6 there might
be Knight D6 because now you definitely
can't take uh the Knight as the e-pawn
will promote and you're threatening
Knight C8 coming in with the fork so
you've got no time to play A4
right A4 would walk right into this fork
and somehow it's still a draw because
black also gets a queen and and white
gets a queen as well wait that's white
get a queen
chess is the most ridiculous game
sometimes
after but we have to find the right
Square I think exactly we have to find
the right Square
nobody could see it but I just rolled my
eyes at the board just because this is
so absurd like
if you just look at this with the engine
on you're like okay it's just a draw the
whole way through and then you get here
which is somehow still a draw
but how was it
this is unreal
the reason why just to show that line
one more time is E7 is always met by
King D7 and you can't promote the pawn
for white but black is about to promote
so where in the world does this Knight
need to go
wow
um
can I call a friend can I yeah
do we have magnus's number anywhere can
we you know ask him for the solution to
this is this for real this is just
unbelievable
oh and the problem is that you need to
find a good Square so that black doesn't
have King to D7
I think I got it my process of
elimination oh this is Knight F5 82. if
we play E7 we lose because King comes to
D7 but if we start with Knight takes G7
you get a queen and then I go E7
I'm gonna promote if you take my knight
and if you check my king you might not
have enough checks and my king will kind
of stay in this area over here
okay if Arjun has seen this line and
calculated this through and realized it
I mean that is just impossible to
believe that is impossible to believe
because this whole sequence of moves
finding Knight F5 Knight G7 I mean I I'm
speechless and realizing that black has
got no good check to capture the Knight
or to defend upon and this ends in a
draw is unreal this is unbelievable
Robert all I can do is shake my head
because you know I was thinking oh now
it's just going to be a draw and I'm
just gonna go back to how we got here
Knight B5 check King B6 Knight D6
looking like this Fork is really good
but then after A4 you gotta say wait
that a pawn is faster and somehow
someway the only move is Knight to F5
because Knight G6 A2 E7 King D7 you
can't get your Pawn to promote your king
would have to jump into F7 so Levon
actually decided to bring his King back
to d8 maybe he saw that variation as
well they're thinking very deeply about
the position but Tanya this has been an
amazingly tactical end game when it
looked like it might just be peaceful
I think most players would just leave it
at seeing King B6 Knight D6 and there's
a folk threatened and you just don't
even want to look at anything beyond
that that's how practical chess works
and over the board I I would love to
hear their thoughts after the game if
they actually saw this line in its
entirety or was it just stopped seeing
that Knight D6 looks strong enough in
any case Levon decides to fall back with
the King and now Arjun taking no time at
all for his moves simply comes back with
the Knight to C3 stops the a pawn from
advancing any further Bishop B4 played
attacking that Knight you can't put your
knight on e4 anymore because then black
does roll down with the pawn A4 and
let's say you go King to C4 I think
black and play A3 then say that I can
sacrifice the bishop because my Pawn is
Unstoppable
and if King goes to B3 the King goes to
E7 we saw lines like this when the
Knight was on C6 and untouchable now the
bishop is Untouchable because the Pod
promotes in Black steals E6 brings the
king over steals the rest as well this
is a shaky position it looks like Knight
A4 King E7 so what is arjun's idea he
has a blockade that's the good news is
the bishop on B4 is on a dark square
that is the inherent limitation of the
bishop you need to now move the bishop
both to B5 and to B4 to keep kicking the
Knight out and help Pawn go up not
possible so what if white is just King
E5 the answer is it's bad because Bishop
D6 check wins this Pawn the bishop will
go back to protect A5 and now black will
have passed pawns on both sides of the
board and the E6 Pawn may not be able to
be defended so King E5 is actually not
available
so what is arjun's plan here Todd is he
going to move the Knight around a bunch
do you think that's it
so why can't you go Knight to B6 what is
it that you're worried about I want to
go Knight B6 and maybe give you a check
and see it
I think it's just a single check though
right the king can run backs
right
I don't feel confident but I'm gonna
make the move okay for some reason oh
okay good made a decent move but I'm
just attacking your knight and if you
push E7 the knights are such clumsy
pieces right you need to somehow get to
this Square to help you promote but as
soon as you move the Knight you lose the
pawn and your king needs to be on F7 but
you can't walk through the E6 square and
that means that white is completely
Frozen and black on the other hand will
either push the pawn or bring the bishop
back first and take on E7 winning for
black
you know I see our live board and I see
our eval bar and it feels like arjun's
still within the reach of a draw
according to our evaluation but the last
couple of moves that he's played so
quickly Robert from Knight B5 and sort
of getting the knight from the center of
the board to this query for I feel like
that margin of error has really reduced
he needs to play Super precisely right
now as you're mentioning the G3 Pawn is
under attack and I know that there are
some ideas where you mentioned earlier
which might be possible where you go G4
instead of giving up the G3 Pawn as is
you try to double up black spawns but
it's kind of hard to believe uh that
they would work one and two you have to
find the exact moment when to go for it
it just looks like Arjun now again might
be in a little bit of a trouble
practically speed
I agree with you I'm just trying to find
moves there are not many pieces
remaining so either you move your knight
we talked about King E5 being bad
because you simply pick up the G3 Pawn
the king can't go anywhere else because
he was the E6 Pawn so the king can't
move that's a limited we have two Night
Moves Knight B2 and Knight B6 no matter
which night move you make if we go
backwards for a second
um I think Bishop E1 to pick up this
Pawn is possible you can also bring your
king up the board because the bishop
protects E7 so I wasn't even thinking
about this initially but now I'm looking
at it can the king just March up and
start taking these pawns because the
bishop is such a good long range piece
it's not out of the question for you to
sit your Bishop on E7 and bring that
King up and try to promote your Pawn so
it's looking so dangerous for Arjun who
made a couple moves there very quickly
and now he's sitting and thinking so I'm
worried for his chances
still not looking at the board and he
decides to make the move Knight B6 makes
a lot of sense if you've got to move the
Knight the B6 Squad definitely is more
active gives white more chances and now
your move Bishop to E1 is the big
question and coming back to the idea
that we were talking about is it the
moment to sacrifice the cheap one let's
say you go G4 because if you allow black
to pick up the G3 Pawn with the bishop
then it just feels like Black's got
everything you wanted an extra pawn and
it'll just be game over there will be
another passer on the other end of the
board impossible to stop I want to
double your pawns and my aim is to try
to pick up that pawn with my king let's
say you go H takes G4 and now I come in
with the king so King to E5
okay so if I you know give you some kind
of check your king will maybe have five
king of
oh you know what the problem is
is so bad at dealing with outside with
Rook pawns you're notoriously bad so I
will give you one of my pawns pick your
poison let's say you take this one I
take on E6 you go King G5 you're trying
to hunt down my Pawn I attack your
knight and if the Knight goes to A4 this
is a known configuration Bishop on D4
takes away all four squares remember
knights in the center can go to eight
squares Knights of the rim can only go
to four so even if you win end up
winning this Pawn on G4 the black king
simply wins the Knight on A4 and to
finish the variation here you may think
ah I'm just in time to get your bishop
and if your Bishop moves anywhere then
the Knight goes this way if the bishop
goes this way the Knight goes back to B2
I take your knight I go King to B3 and I
go full Searching for Bobby Fischer on
you and get a queen here you should have
taken the draw there was none offered
this is that's rude this is just unreal
what is happening here I
it's just amazing
how quickly this has gotten so
complicated from a position that we
thought Arjun was doing everything right
and he still looks pretty relaxed like
he knows exactly what he's doing so
Knight B6 and Levon is still having a
thinker he has he moved King to F6
I think he just moved that King up to F6
uh yeah I see that King there on the
board and so he is trying to work his
way up and take the pawns with his King
and what is Arjun gonna do about it
oh my goodness this is such a rich end
game
and I I don't see another move except to
hop around with the Knight your king is
tied down to defend the E6 spawn G4
doesn't get you anything
you can just move your knight to A4
because you can't allow uh r2d7 with a
check but that just allows King B King
G5 and as we can see even Knight A4 runs
into King G5
maybe Knight C5 ah because if you take
now it's winning for white not because
of what we saw before going for the a
pawn because we keep talking about this
one king D6 A4 E7 I'm one square away
from promoting if you try to stop me now
the king reaches D7 the pawn will reach
the promised land and that will be a
queen this is such a complicated end
game so after Knight C5 we can't take we
have to bring our King back but we just
saw this position with the knight uh
potential coming to A4 or to D7 with
check but I think the reason why Knight
A4 is a little bit less precise is the
bishop can run away and now if you bring
your knight to C5 I can take it because
E6 is in contact and if you move your
knight somewhere else like Knight to B6
I think King F5 avoiding this the fork
and if your king moves you lose the pawn
if your knight moves back to A4 now it's
time for my king just go gobble gobble
win the G pawns and the H Pawn will
promote this is unbelievable
just amazing stuff and Levon really
focused there he has made the move King
F6 so he realizes that he needs to get
the king to pick up the pawns and Robert
let's just go back because King F6 made
me think about something that we perhaps
missed when we were looking at the
option of immediately picking up the G3
Pawn let's just go back one move because
you're very attracted to the possibility
of black playing Bishop E1 here why not
just pick up the pawn immediately and we
came up with the idea of G4 G4 H takes
G4 but let's take a deeper look at this
position actually if white just stays
here black doesn't have a way to improve
because yes you won a pawn but in a
sense these are double pawns what you
really need is to create a passer on the
king's side
yep just like in the end game we saw
between good catch and abysatarov we saw
a lot of Concepts revolving around
double pawns how they cannot help you
promote
and in this position after each takes G4
you can go in with the check because now
very importantly levon's move King F6 is
impossible I think you're
can you go King D6 or does that not okay
the bar still stays so that's a good
sign
yeah this is so wild king D7 and if you
go a oh my 96 96 is the move there's
Knight D6 and Knight B6 because you're
attacking the pawn and threatening the
fork at the same time oh my God
96 also looks really good and oh it was
just yeah it forces uh the draw here
queen queen and because we promote
at the same time
actually this almost loses for white
like you have to be very careful in this
position to not lose because the black
king is snaking away and you're up a
pawn and G2 oh my gosh it's still zeros
of course because
you are correct King H4 King if King F4
was the idea yeah King F4 here but then
there's Jesus oh my God
I wasted Tempo somehow this
oh my gosh you go King F5 and if G6 your
king G5 so when the king takes you take
them this pawn and go back and then take
that pawn oh and look at the
construction on the board just look at
this all the king the king and all the
pawns are on the G file G6 King G5 G4
King G3 G2 uh this is Aesthetics it's
like a kebab you know it's a skewer it's
like a skewer yeah
well now that we found this position
Arjun of course sees everything that we
just talked about as does Lavon I mean
this end game is so much more difficult
than meets the eye it's really tough to
figure out what move to make at any turn
because you have to see so deeply
this is just amazing stuff and Levon
realizing these points and understanding
that the aim for black is to create
another passer so he can't really allow
a doubling up of the pawn and that makes
me feel Robert that if we were to go G4
here I think Lev wants to go H4 he
doesn't even want to pick up the G4 Pawn
oh so you can it's play H4 King G5 king
take in general you're saying that that
you're gonna ignore the pawn pass it and
then bring your king up to take the rest
it very well could be the idea lavon's
played King F6 he wants to pick up the
Jeep on with his King Arjun continues to
look around not taking a look at the
board at all and when he does he tends
to just make his move really quickly I
think he can feel it now uh that it's
it's gotten a bit out of hand and you
know that moment when he had when he
played those couple of moves without a
thought I think that was when it all
turned around and that was the moment
that it slipped
because now he's really thinking you
could see it on his face
and well he needs to figure it out just
refresh the board sorry about that
everybody
um but after King 2 F6 he has his work
cut out for him and there's a ton of
work because we just showed you like
eight different variations which either
win for black or barely barely barely
hold for white because of one little
tactic so uh it's tough
it's super tough and if Arjun aragasi
manages to survive this he is about to
reach out for his move uh Robert he goes
for it and he's made the move G4 the one
that we were just talking about and the
eval bar I see does not approve of this
move and we were talking about black has
two approaches now do you pick up the
pawn with your Pawn but in that way give
up all rights to make a passer or do you
play the move H4 with levon's initial
idea of going King G5 and picking it up
with the King huge question
for love here I'm just gonna make the
move and see what happens H4
says Black's Advantage is slipping a bit
here uh maybe it's because of the night
coming to C5 so Knight D7 check if the
King goes to E7 the Knight it can go
back to B6 it also can go to E5 and
around to C6 those kind of positions as
well if you go back to B6 it still is
good enough it appears uh the white king
now can come to E5 successfully there's
no check picking up a pawn so maybe it's
just in time for white to play Knight D7
because if you go King G6 the Knight
comes to C5 and we've talked about how
you can't take it as you lose the game
with the King going back to D6 helping
usher the pawn to the other side
all right well if H4 gives away the
advantage of course it's still a very
difficult decision practically to be
made by love it might be something that
he's attracted to because that's what he
implied with his previous move of King
F6 that he really wants his King to
advance down the board let's take a look
at what happens if he does uh fight that
thought and go for the second approach
of winning the pawn but by doing that
giving up the right to create another
passer
he's gonna need his King still to run
quickly and go out for the pawn but we
keep talking about this kind of
variation we're at Knight D7 check if
your king goes up the board Knight C5
you can't take it so your King has to go
back but look at that Knight C5 in this
position
somehow there might be like a zoos along
eventually if I go king of six you go
Knight D7 check back what if I go King
G6 that way Knight D7 isn't check and
then I'll push my Pawn
so I think that black at some point just
needs to lose a Tempo and I'm only
finding this out because I see the eval
bars reaction but this is how amazing
this end game is and it shows how a
knight can be outclassed by a bishop a
bishop can lose a Tempo if you want to
pass the turn you can first go to D2
then go to E1 next a knight has to
change what color it's on it doesn't
have the opportunity to lose that kind
of tempo so that is unfortunate where
Knight D7 as we were talking about it
loses because you've allowed the pawn to
run forward
well a big moment here then for left to
take this call whether to take on G4 or
play the very attractive H4 which in
fact turns out to be the wrong way
forward and this is the beauty of
classical chess Robert we are only
treated to these intricate complex
situations because the players have time
to navigate through these complications
if it was Blitz or rapid by now we would
have had four Queens on the board there
would have been about 20 blunders made
already but as we can see the level of
accuracy Is So High by both players for
the most part and the fight still
continues
the fight will continue will allow Lavon
to ponder this decision it's a really
big one and he has plenty of time uh as
he works to figure out do I play H4 do I
take on G4 it's really not an easy
choice and you know you can see him on
screen there he is looking not at this
position honestly he is his vision is
taking him 10 15 moves down the line
both players are doing just that trying
to figure out in the event of a capture
on G4 can I win with those double pawns
will my king go into enemy territory to
win the G2 Pawn or can I never create a
past Pawn because my pawns are in each
other's way on the flip side if I play
H4 like we were talking about have I
allowed the Knight to come to D7 and
then why doesn't King G6 work like it
did in that other position or was it
King G5 first Knight C5 then Kingdom G6
what's different I'm not really sure
honestly I'm just reacting to the Evo
bar but maybe it's this move G5
because wow you can't move your king
back into the box over here and if you
take we've talked about this many times
at this point you try to go A4 the king
comes up A3 D6 excuse me E7 uh this is
going to be a check so you are not in
time to promote if you try to stop it
thank you very much I still promote
first so the G5 push actually takes away
the squares from the King and if you
can't now pass the turn very easily
um you have to watch out you have to be
very carefully or not to lose the game
as black the evaluation could change at
any moment Tanya I don't know about you
but I feel like I need a quick break and
Lavon he's gonna you know take a little
breather think deeply and in the
meantime
we do want to you know lets you know
that you can join chess.com on Discord
the official chess.com Discord server
has been revamped a fresh new look lots
of new features and more join us at
go.chess.com Discord and make sure to
connect your chess.com account to earn
unique Flair use the command Discord in
chat for more information but for now Ty
and I are gonna run to a quick break
when returned there's so much more to
look at in these beautiful end games
we'll be right back
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chest but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck you're gonna
score it to place the dog
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns came to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemates but still wait there is
still me but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the fast
ing duck Chuck
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
yeah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Levon aronians still on the clock after
Arjun pushed his Pawn to G4 it can be
captured on that square and maybe he'll
join another winner of today's action
that was Fabiano caruana Tanya we've had
Five results in the books only Fabiano
won his game but the rest of the games
were quite intense and fighting
Fabi won his game but that looked like a
gift from Jordan in a position where
there was everything to play for Jordan
walked into a one move blunder and it
was the kind of blunder where there's no
coming back from not only did he end up
down upon but a devastating position and
Fabi showed a Flawless Way Forward one
without any difficulty making him the
only winner of the round the other four
games did end in a draw were well played
out the balance was kept in each of them
Robert and despite the fact that we've
had one win I think the game of round
three is the one that's still on it is
this one against with Arjun aragassi
facing Levon aronian in what is a
mammoth battle between these two levons
had the edge for the majority of the
game he's been trying to squeeze out a
win meanwhile arjun's showing resistance
but he has lost the path somewhere and
it's still a super complicated position
and take a look at this we've been
talking about how the players need to be
precise on the other side of this break
we left the position with a big decision
for Lev Robert will he go H4 or will he
accept this Pawn sacrifice of G4 and
Levon has made the right decision he has
captured the pawn on G4
capture the pawn G4 the Knight came to
D7 with check and now the Knight would
like to land on C5 blocking this
Bishop's path back to stopping the past
Pawn but we've looked at this position
just before the break that this King
goes up to G5 and the Knight blocks The
Bishop's path the king can go back
safely to G6 and if white says all right
we've been here before I'll bring my
knight over to A4 to stop the past Pawn
the King goes to F6 so you kind of
you're looking a bit closer and the
Knight doesn't have to check on D7 right
here you have to play a move like Knight
B6 that gives black a turn to move the
bishop somewhere along diagonal and then
try to push this Pawn as it becomes
available or to bring your king up the
board and win the G2 Pawn I just think
that white can't handle everything in
all directions because the Knight is
such a slow moving piece
this is amazing stuff I mean a lab still
has to find all these precise King
Maneuvers Knight D7 check has been
played by Arjun he seems to be playing
confidently in this end game I think he
still believes that the draw is within
his reach he's playing fast we see the
players they're on move 56 so four more
moves to be made two time control
arjun's got about 13 minutes Lev has a
great clock Management in this event
he's got 30 minutes to navigate all
these possibilities and we see him with
uh his head and his hands right now
completely focused calculating the lines
to the end Robert let's take a look one
more time so King to G5 is the move that
you were suggesting and the key idea is
that after white blocks it out with
Knight C5
you have to retreat with the King to G6
you stay well this is so difficult to
find
yeah it's not easy but the good news for
Lavon he doesn't have the eval bar which
helps us as commentators but he has
plenty of time and he just made the move
it looks like King
back maybe to E7 yes he went King back
to E7 actually still keeping the winning
Advantage so it wasn't just King G5 to
G6 uh that happened to work or maybe he
needs to go back
but what other moves come to mind here
Tanya besides King F6 that's the big
question he can move his Bishop
somewhere they might have lost some
Knight checks what would what do you
think what are our move candidates
well he's come back with the Knight to
B6 Arjun played it immediately and it
was really the only way forward because
you can't allow white uh you can't allow
black spawns to just March forward and
now you're mentioning that of course
Lebon has the idea to just simply repeat
the position with the King to F6
it's hard to come up with an alternative
because you don't want to move your
Bishop from B4 it seems like it's
ideally placed on B4 the a pawn doesn't
go forward
G3 could that be an idea does he want to
place his Pawn on G3 and say that you
know what that's a better version what's
your move next but our eval Bar says no
the pawn does belong on G4
yes maybe it's because it takes the
king's path away that when you put your
Pawn on G3 if this King eventually comes
up the board oh it's can't get any more
forward because the pawn is in its path
so uh G3 maybe G6 is another option it's
saying nope not that one either uh
perhaps because where is the progress
going to be maybe the King goes over to
E5 trying to get after this pawn and if
you played Bishop D6 check trying to
keep the king away the King goes back
which has the threat of Knight C8 check
so
these uh moves are not easy to come by
and
if we repeat the position you know with
Bishop to B4 King E5 now we really don't
have other moves because the king is
stuck where it is if the bishop goes
down to E1 then we have Knight D5 check
from a more active square and the King
slides up to D6
I think he's got to come back with the
King to F6 and love will realize that
that the only path that he has is
forward but the tricky point is not to
go King F6 King G5 well but it is to
visualize and to be aware that after
that you will have to move King G6 well
love on it looks like he's failed to
find that and you can't blame him it is
so hard to find this idea of the king
Retreat from G5 to G6 instead he makes a
bishop move he makes the move Bishop all
the way down the board Bishop to E1
played
Bishop E1 was his choice just there he
is trying to uh figure out where the
bishop ultimately belongs but for now
it's very far away from the enemy pieces
no Forks nothing of the sort so let's
think about moves for White Knight A4 is
possible Knight C8 check just to go back
to B6 is another line uh the king can go
to E5 we've been talking about positions
like that I believe that's those are all
the moves that I see is those three
well King E5 looks pretty attractive
because you vacate the D5 Square for
your knight you are kind of uh always
eyeing the king marching towards the
king side to pick up the pawns but of
course you have to be super careful when
you do that because that gives black the
opportunity to improve his own King
position but how do you respond to King
E5 to start with
Maybe
you know black has to worry about Knight
D5 check so I've been throwing the check
on your king over here and just like
before if the King goes to F5 G6 check
will win is the exact position we saw
earlier I know it's a different move
order things have changed a little bit
but no matter which Pawn is captured the
black king captures on E6 Bishop D4 will
be played and the a pawn will not be
possible to uh contained especially with
the black king coming over to kick the
Knight when it gets to A4 just to show
that variation one more time we looked
at it earlier if the Knight tries to
blockade the pawn the King goes to D5
you take the pawn G4 King King
King comes before and I still take you
because after King takes you for King B3
the pawn finally gets to go forward and
promote with check to boot so tiny these
lines are crazy like every single
variation changes with the smallest
subtlety or nuance and that is perhaps
what Lavon is looking at if the King
goes to E5 he'll give a check the king
can't go to F5 but what happens if it
goes back to D5 exactly that's the whole
point that you don't have to walk into
with King F5 King D5 and the whole
problem is now this winning idea of King
F6 King G5 King G6 the bishop on C3 in
fact is worst place than the bishop on
B4 because white has got E7 so now I can
go Knight to D7
mm-hmm and you can't even go King to G5
because of E7 now right the pawn
promotes
so you don't have these ideas and you
have to fall back with your king to E7
so Bishop on C3 isn't accurately placed
and I see Arjun reaching out he's gone
for the move King E5 it is the most
natural move in the position the only
thing that I hope Argent has
has looked at is that after the check
he's found this nasty trick that you
were pointing out king F5 loses to G6
but I think these players are so
involved and invested in this position
Robert when we are playing a long game
we know all the ideas that exist in it
we've been calculating them for a long
time so I think Arjun does realize that
that he needs to keep the king closer to
the a pawn if left gives a check he will
make the move King D5
you know it's interesting the eval bar
is kind of swinging a bit and maybe it's
uh not sold increasing its depth trying
to figure out the position uh but Bishop
G3 check is available as well we know we
need to check the king but we have two
different diagonals to work with if we
go Bishop to G3 check
King F5 might attack this pawn and this
bishop but I think it's the same exact
uh situation G6 check I get your king
away because even if you take this Pawn
on uh G4 I simply attack your knight
take the pawn and we have talked about
this a number of times now the black
king will Rush on over to pester that
night and black will then be able to
promote that a pawn so after Bishop G3
you go King D5 back maybe I have a
better Square for my Bishop somehow like
away from the Knight attacking it and if
it goes to A4
oh I don't know I guess I can't really
go King F6 because King D6
ah
wait somehow it's still good for black
huh
is there's Bishop E1 to B4 this is just
an amazing amazing end game
there's so much geometry here and so
much back and forth with the pieces and
we can see Lavon having a big think
right now he's taken he's burnt about
almost 10 minutes on this move uh he's
still trying to figure out where to give
the check from from Bishop to G3 or
Bishop to C3 either ways white has to
make the move King D5
arjun's still looking so relaxed it's
just amazing the kind of nerves that
these players have
it's unbelievable and I wonder if Arjun
really believes or you know he's sure
that he's going to make a draw or if
he's just trying to you know convince
himself in a way because there's no way
either player sees the Finish Line just
yet but Lavon did bring his Bishop to G3
with check now Argent cannot play King
F5 we've been discussing this G6 it
distracts the king away from the
all-important E6 pawn and then black
will scoop it up so Arjun almost
certainly will be going back to D5 with
his King and then I like the look of
Bishop F2 kicking the Knight away from
B6
all right so you kick the Knight away
from B6 and what if the Knight just goes
back to A4 what's your idea let's say
King D5 Bishop F2 I come back with the
Knight to A4 how are you making progress
here
um so somehow King F6 was working even
though I thought King D6 would be the
problem and I'm wondering if it's
because Bishop E1 nope not Bishop B1 so
tricky this uh I don't know why
it looks like a pretty good move
King D7
maybe King D7 is a problem and after
Bishop B4 there might be Knight B6 ideas
and then I'm threatening Knight D5
uh super clever you're trying to remove
the bishop and get your E Pawn going so
amazing amazing you might be seeing this
by the way Robert because Arjun has made
the move King D5 and now levon's got to
show his cards what did he want with
this bishop transferring from one side
of the board to the other Bishop F2
is not played yet but this is the move
that we're expecting yeah Knight A4 and
somehow after King F6 which I thought I
was trying to show it's not good because
of King D6 but maybe it's this move and
it's just press of elimination Bishop H4
because if you play E7 the King goes
back to F7 stopping the pawn from
promoting and attacking the pawn on E7
with the bishop so Bishop H4 it
stops E7 and maybe black will give up
this bishop for the pawn if the king can
go really quickly I'm not sure it's in
time but I'm just trying to figure out
why in the world this position is you
know so promising uh for black it still
does not seem very clear to me
and let's just play out this line this
idea that you're talking about because I
want to see if this actually works it's
so tempting what you're saying let's say
after we and we've got to move already
so he has gone Bishop H4 without driving
the Knight away from B6
and our valbar approves
it does and if King E5 do you think he's
going Bishop F6 check so he's gonna
check the king away from a square that's
close by and try to force that King back
to D5 anyway at least the bishop on F6
covers the E7 Square
it covers the E7 square but the drawback
is it takes away the F6 Square from your
king and I don't know if that's progress
right because your king in many of these
positions needs to go up the board
rather than sitting in front of the pawn
so Bishop H4 played by Lavon that's move
59 so as soon as Arjun makes this next
move he gains an additional 15 minutes
on the clock it's not an easy move to
make because King E5 Bishop F6 check
came back to D5 maybe that's what Lavon
is looking for uh and Arjun has to be
extremely careful at this moment but I
still don't see another move besides
King E5 because if you move your knight
back then the black king does go to F6
and we were talking about how the bishop
is promising on the diagonal if you
bring your king up to D6 King F5 this is
what I was mentioning earlier that black
is going to win this position because of
the king F4 King F7 something like this
the black king Scoops up G2 and the g
Pawn will promote
what an amazing line I mean this whole
end game there's so much going on and it
is super rich and so instructive the
players completely focused on trying to
make this one work Lebon wants to he's
doing everything he can to take the full
point uh meanwhile big resistance here
by Arjun and we've been so involved in
this fascinating endgame robber that we
completely forgot about another game
that's been going on I did keep my eye
out on it pragnananda versus Vincent and
there have been a lot of developments in
it uh and I'm just wondering if we
should take a quick look at that and
then of course we will shift right back
to this end game because it is just one
of the most fascinating end games I've
seen in recent times
yes the other game is still a pawn ahead
for prognado not too many moves have
happened in that one and it's an extra
Pawn for white a past Pawn on D6 but now
Knight C4 check was just played by
Vincent he is going to take this pod
potentially but F7 is loose so if we go
through the variation Knight D6 Bishop
takes King takes Knight takes F7 check
apparently it's still a hold for black
because the King goes on over to F6 very
quickly and the bishop and the pawn
match which is very important because
you can protect that pawn so Tanya it
looks like it should keyword being
should not will be a draw it's still a
lot of life left in this end game
what stands out to me is just the kind
of chances that Prague and Levon are
creating in these positions it's
incredible to watch these two players
trying to convert this into a win and
Winston and Arjun on the other side of
the board just holding on uh we see
Knight C4 check that has been played and
this line that you've been pointing out
uh Robert trading the d-pawn with the
f-pawn as they get fewer and fewer pawns
on the board Winston gets closer to the
draw and even though he will be down
upon it looks like it should be fine
because black will sacrifice his Bishop
at the right time for the last remaining
Pawn on the board unless white along
with the King and Knight can go on to
win the G6 Pawn but that's where it
comes into play what you mentioned that
Black's king and the bishop on the b187
diagonal will keep the pawn defended
right the apollon G6 can be defended and
you have to kick this King out if this
King ever moved to a square like G7 I'm
trying to waste the move but like go
King G7 it could be dangerous but that's
where that Bishop comes into play where
it defends so you're not going to be
able to kick both of these pieces out
and they defend perfectly along the
diagonal for the bishop and the King
doesn't have to move just move your
Bishop back and forth how is the Knight
gonna check this King so if the Knight
can check the king that would be uh
promising where do you go like if I'll
let you
I'll let you check here and the King
goes to F7 because whenever a knight
checks a king it's very close by
and then you get attacked and you can
give it another check with Knight d8 but
the king Falls right back to G7 keeping
G6 defended and everything's under
control here the moment you'll go H5
black will be super happy to trade the
last pair of Pawns and the bishop on
this diagonal will eventually give
itself up for the final remaining Pawn
there's just no way that you can improve
this position because if you imagine
white even gets a knight on G6 to block
this diagonal
okay let's try it let's just get that
position
make some moves
and black can even go into a King Pawn
end game here with Bishop G6 8g6 and you
just need to make the final accurate
move with King to G8 so that you're the
one who can take an opposition and
wherever white goes you take the
opposition white gives a check come back
and this would be a stalemate
that's a sale made indeed no moves for
that black king and so that is showing
that even though it's going to be a pawn
ahead for white that black is in time
just bring the King on over eventually
get the bishop to B1 and protect this G6
Pawn so I feel quite confident in this
one I think Vincent should be feel quite
good about how this game has gone on
because he's likely to secure the half
point but Arjun Eric Garcia he his task
is much more difficult and we actually
have seen some moves in that game it's
not that we don't want to give prognan
to end timer our undivided attention we
would love to but with the other game
just being so spicy such a rich end game
I feel like I've already learned a lot
and I feel like I'm still learning
because when I just pulled up the game
here Tanya it looks like LaVon has
misstepped
and it's so easy to do that you know
again let's just understand that we
always have the eval bar and the ability
to take back our moves when we go wrong
we say this doesn't work out we can try
something else out but the players one
they have no idea what is the actually
objective evaluation of the position and
second no take backs they've got only
one path with their knowledge and with
their understanding they just make that
move that they feel gives them the best
chances and lavon's still trying to be
tricky with his King Retreats let's just
back up to that moment of Bishop H4
where we left it last just a couple of
moves have happened since then after
Bishop H4
Arjuna I'm sorry keep going sorry about
that Tanya
no worries we see our board we see our
players and there we have our analysis
board so when Bishop H4 was played if we
just back up a move uh Robert
Levon decided to just simply fall back
with the King today think to d8 not a
move that we were expecting we were
thinking there would be some checks on
the board either from G3 or from F6 but
this is a new king Retreat Levon made it
last time with King A5 now with King d8
but one gets the feeling that again
arjun's in control one big question move
the Knight the Knight comes to A4 I
really don't even if another move is
better I don't want to allow your Pawn
to push for forward and as I was saying
that Arjun says I don't care about the
pawn moving forward he believes in the
activity of his pieces he makes the move
Knight D5 the eval bar approves and what
is his idea A4 does he just want to go
in with the King to D6 that doesn't make
any sense what does he want after A4
yeah because uh A4 King D6 can you just
kick the king away with a check and then
push your Pawn that seems uh way way way
too slow maybe what's King
D4 exactly and also I want to point out
uh Robert King D4 as you're making this
square right now this is a great
technique to understand whether you're
in time or not the king D4 is within the
square which means it catches the a pawn
just in time to stop it from promoting
one concept I want to show is that after
King D6 Lakin of course give a check but
the other idea that black has is
actually to just continue I think
promoting the pawn because after A3
let's say you go E7 which is so
attractive yes you win the piece but you
lose the game because Bishop E7 97 and
nothing is stopping the A2 Pawn you have
one check on C6 but the Knight is too
far away
wow yeah this Knight is such a slow
moving piece it the bishop on the other
hand can leap across the board and help
out on both sides so the Knight did come
over to D5 if A4 he must be thinking
King D4 he is in the square and that
means the king can hunt down the pawn
but this position we've talked about
before you can't take the bishop you
lose the king and pawn ending and if
your king goes over to B3 is there a way
for this King to attack this Pawn I know
the king doesn't move like a knight but
that I think is origin's defensive setup
he's gonna leave his Knight and pawn
here which means C7 D7 and E7 are off
limits from the black king so how would
you go to that pawn you need to go
something King C8 King B7 King C6 King
D6 that takes too much time and you know
we'll move our Bishop back first the
king will come to A2 how do we get to
this Pawn King here allows E7 and you
win a piece and you make a draw so Tanya
I feel like Arjun did everything he
could he keeps the king stuck at home
from all of these squares and that means
that perhaps Levant can't really make
progress
an arching after a long time gets up and
leaves the board he realizes he's
achieved the defensive setup Now by
switching the Knight and the King it
will be the king now that's going to go
on to stop the A5 Pawn while the Knight
as you're pointing out will take away
all activity squares from levon's King
and Levon there shaking his head I think
he realizes that his best chance is past
him now and playing the move King d8
he's just given an easy defensive setup
to Arjun and kudos to Arjun to find this
so quickly with Knight D5 you want to
kind of stay with the defensive setup
that you've had all this while I was
mentioning come back with the Knight to
A4 don't allow the a pawn to March
forward but this just shows how focused
he is he gets one opportunity and he
centralizes the Knight on D5 and
realizes that his King is just in time
to save the pawn now one more thing that
I'm wondering here does black have the
option to go Bishop to F6
aha because if you take Pawn takes King
takes A4 would be a huge blunder because
the white king goes up to F7 helps the
pawn promote but instead you block with
the king the white king is in time to
chase down the a pawn but as has been
the case in many previous positions you
can go ahead and eat that a pawn because
the pawn on G2 will quickly be captured
and then the remaining Pawn will promote
exactly which is why I was wondering
what what does art have after Bishop F6
check but I think the problem is that
you don't get tempted with the King Pawn
ending you simply March forward with
your king you go King D6 you're already
threatening the move E7 check King E8 97
let's just show that idea that white has
got plans off his own hair and this
would be game over so I think Bishop F6
only helps white as white advances with
the King forward
and it's really important to point out
that in this specific position before
the pawn reached A2 now if you play A3
Knight C6 is check and while the king
tries to run away the Knight comes to B4
stopping the pawn before it gets to the
other side so the Knight is in time it's
a slow moving piece but here it's just
fast enough to stop that Pawn's
promotion and then the Kings will stay
on the this side of the board on the
king side where the pawns are and it
should in fact be a draw and black would
have to prove it so really big missed
chance for Lavon and I think just to
show one more time with the King coming
back to stop this Pawn the biggest
difference in any of these variations is
there aren't multiple Avenues to attack
to threaten with earlier the King was
out on G5 threatening to come in to
infiltrate and win the g-pawn but now
the king is stuck at home and because
there aren't several Avenues to move
forward with the white king can actually
just go back and forth on the light
squares King A2 King B3 and so on you
don't need to do much of anything
because the rest of the pieces take care
of the situation and to go the other way
let's say we go King E8 and we you know
G6 we moved the king trying to get it to
F6 guess what you also don't have access
to F6 the night cover C7 E7 F6 the pawn
covers uh D7 F7 and if you try to get
your king up to the F5 Square E7 takes
takes it looks like well I've made some
serious progress now I should be winning
but it turns out that white can bring
this Knight back I mean this is just
unbelievable how it's all the last
second heroics that this Knight will get
this Pawn so if you try to win the G2
Pawn you lose G4 if you go back the
Knight can even go to F1 keeping the
king out just like it did on the other
side of the board the Knight and pawn
keep the king out before it gets in I
just can't handle any more awesome
instructive moments this is just
spectacular the whole end game has been
a mind-blowing play with so many
intricate ideas and possibility and
let's just go back uh to the live
position because the geometry that
you're pointing out about the Knight and
pawn really holding on and you know this
line with A4 King D4 A3 King C3 King
comes to B3 this position is so amazing
Robert because like you pointed out if
Black's King goes over to the king's
side comes to the F5 Square white
advances the pawn if black king comes to
B7 trying to get to C6 that isn't good
enough either because the moment you put
your King on B7 white will again push
the pawn from E6 to E7 and there's no
possibility of allowing a white to do
that and we see a move by Levon when I
look at Lev and I feel that he knows
that this is ending in a draw now and I
think he just offered a draw he just
offered a draw handshakes love on
realizing that the moment is past him
and what a game what an end game play by
both these players amazing stuff
yeah and when you see you know something
pop up and you blunder inaccuracy it
doesn't tell the full story it wasn't
inaccuracy in one move it's down the
line and some of these variations that
we just looked at are like 20 moves deep
with the black king running scrambling
up towards this Pawn in a G2 but not
quickly enough so look at Levon he does
seem quite disappointed
um you know I feel like he knows he had
chances there and he probably felt like
on a different day he might have won
this game but he also was facing such a
sturdy opponent Argent to this point he
had black in game one I guess prognanda
he held the draw with great preparation
and then he finished it off nicely
against Wesley so he looked like he was
in trouble when Wesley had a past Pawn
he managed to hold each and every move
now with the white pieces his first time
with the first move Advantage he was
worse throughout this entire game oh
when it came down to it Tanya he held
and look at that look at that Robert
they're analyzing the exact same
position that was winning for black king
to G6 was the move that we were
wondering if Levon can find it because
it's such a hard move to make if we can
just we will show that to our viewers
but this is the position and Levon now
realizes Archer realizes that this would
have been a zugz Wong for white with no
way to improve and this just shows how
aware they were of all these subtleties
King G6 we see that on their analysis
board this is amazing stuff this is the
moment uh that really makes chess what
it is a move that I really thought is
impossible for people to find we've got
the eval bar telling us but look at this
it's in their analysis
I'm watching them go and they were
looking at a line like this with the
King going to G5 but Knight D7 the
bishop slides up to E7 uh that's not
good enough so I see what they're
looking at here with the King blocking
this bishop with the bishop on f8 and
the King running back to E7 so I mean
yeah it's cool to see this I'm I'm glad
we have this on camera right now because
I'm just gonna follow uh the moves that
they're making so after King G6 Knight
D3 is what they're analyzing but Bishop
f8 is a great move
will they find it in their analysis
their analysis is amazing to watch and
it's incredible that after almost six
hours of gameplay the two players want
to sit and go through this end game
they have amazing intense respect for
each other they've played each other
several times also Lavon yes in his
heart he might be slightly disappointed
and there you have it Bishop f8 found by
them
but I see them look at King F6 Knight
takes G4 King G5 and it looks like this
would be good for black but right there
for a second Knight D7 it's a king E7
they were looking at this as well so so
many different variations that they are
trying to assess properly I mean chess
is I mean such a rich game here and it
looks like King G5 going up the board is
the way to go so instead of giving the
G4 Pawn that's what the engine is
spouting out as the best option but as
we see them looking at this position
here takes King G5 I think the Knight
went back into E5 here and then A4 so
this also is good for black
just incredible stuff and I was going to
say that you know Levon of course had
his opportunity and he was he had the
better hand throughout the game starting
from that dominating middle game but
Levon appreciates the beauty in chess
and I know that he's also appreciative
of the defensive resources his opponent
put out and we see him there uh
analyzing with a smile it's also
heartwarming to see that the players
don't just get up go back switch on
their engines and check the lines
instead they want to sit and calculate
with each other
yeah I would love to do that but I'm
told I have to have the engine on it all
time so uh you know everyone is
listening to me say that but uh it is
true and it is fun to just calculate you
know and be free of our engine overlords
but they're looking at these lines uh
with the Knight coming back to D3 Bishop
E7 this time 95 check King to F6 Knight
takes G4 and then King G5 which looks
accurately better for black so whoever
just suggests that between the two uh
this is a oh I guess Lavon doesn't like
it for some reason
or are you saying Knight takes G4 is not
right
so it is cool I'm actually really
enjoying this right now uh seeing the
two of them analyze this position
this is an amazing moment after an end
game that was such a massive fight and
it's truly a pleasure to see and get a
peek into their minds while they were
playing the variations that they were
looking at
it looks like they eliminated that line
thinking it was good for black so
they're trying to find something else
besides Knight C5 and King G6 but if
they do this analysis and lavon's like
I'm winning here he's gonna be even more
upset about the missed opportunity and
this was the moment when he didn't go
King to G5 and instead made the move
Bishop to E1
which was a slight in accuracy this was
the line that we had looked at and he
didn't find it during the game but here
they are looking at it afterwards uh
it's too little too late but what a
fight
look at Lavon the way he's analyzing the
position I think he understands that
this is a winning variation and he has
his head in his hands because he's upset
that he didn't find it while the game
was live and they do have great respect
for each other you said that it's
certainly true they played against one
another many times in the Champions
chess tour and in the rapid Chess
Championship you name an online event
they probably duked it out over the
board but right now live in Vikings
Lavon aronian thinking about what could
have been a full point to his name
jumping to the top of the leaderboard
and they did end up finding that line
which would have given Lev on a full
point and there we see disappointment in
lab's face shaking his head this was the
moment uh and it didn't happen in the
game but understandably because it was
such a tough line but it looks like
Levon and Arjun both had it in their
mind as they analyzed it and with that
jaw uh it means that Magnus Fabi Anish
thing and not the back are the five
players on two points currently
pragnananda still trying to win his game
that one's still on and if he manages to
do that after the marathon uh end game
that the two are playing right now he
will join the leaders at the top of the
leaderboard
for sure and probably don't know would
love that he would like to join Abdus
atar of his fellow teenager in a first
place tie these two players have had a
long day Lavon aronian Arjun eragisi and
they're getting up from their chairs out
of the playing Hall and as we go to the
one game remaining between Prague and
Vincent kheimer it looks like this is
now becoming a pretty straightforward
draw White's pawns on light squares
that's a light Square Bishop that can
attack them so just a few moves ago
Tanya we saw the Knight capture on F7
the king ran over towards the center
here
and then
this move G5 was played by Vincent so
he's trying to trade off pieces Prague
says no and now you have a long-term
issue with his Pawn being on the G4
Square
we were just talking
G6 same colored as the bishop so it
should be easier to defend but Winston
takes uh the middle decision to actually
put it on a dark Square to keep it there
for the rest of the game but what he's
saying is how are you going to get to
that pawn when you yourself have to
defend the G4 Pawn for the rest of the
game the F5 Square for the king is taken
so there's no idea of King E4 King F5
the King on G7 stops the white king from
coming to F6
it's only the night that can get to the
G5 pawn and let's say you go Knight F1
Knight G3 Knight E4 black will simply
place his own King on H6 defend that
pawn and there's no more progress to be
made King G3 Knight F3 the one trick
that black needs to watch out for is
let's say you go Knight F3 and black
decides to play King 86.
and after Knight E5 just be a little
careful because Knight F7 check is a
massive threat that would pick up the
pawn but Bishop E6 keeps the balance
right you cover the one threat that you
see and the Knight just can't operate
around well enough where is it going to
go F7 was the key Square not getting
there so let's see what's just happened
King G3 King 6 Knight F3 and Bishop E6
can be played here and now and if you
play 95 we'll just keep our Bishop in
line with F7 just go to D5 something
like this no progress is being made as
if this King by the way goes away you
put Bishop takes G4 and make an
immediate draw the Knight takes the
bishop the king takes the pawn and
you're not going to be able to win with
a lone Knight and a king against the
enemy King
that's a really nice key Point actually
that black always has this trick of
giving up the bishop on G4 and keeping
uh the possibility of taking the two
pawns Bishop E6 played and after Knight
E5 as you're pointing out he simply can
decide to keep the bishop on this
diagonal you can also make a move with
your king you can't go backing at seven
and come backing at six on the next move
that's right the knights loses contact
with the pawn you can just move the king
back and forth this bishop can likely
move non-stop the only way white could
potentially win is if the king got into
F6 but G4 is too loose we were just
talking about how the king ever runs
even this far or King F3 King D3 that
this Pawn will be captured and then H5
next so there is no progress Knight F5
check could be an idea but the problem
is if Knight F5 and you take the king
takes on H5 so you're just losing one of
your pawns uh by going Knight to five so
Tanya there's just not a single even
tactical try that I can find for
prognanda
well he decides not to play nine to five
Knight F5 would be a draw offer on the
spot instead he makes the move King F3
so first he's asking Winston to move the
bishop to a slightly less ideal position
Winston uh immediately plays Bishop to
see it Knight B5 on the board so what
Prague is trying to do is get the Knight
to D6 where he will eye the F7 and the
F5 Square so Black's Bishop on E6 will
only be able to defend one of them let's
just show that let's say you make the
move King at seven
Knight D6 and now you go Bishop E6
and white can go Knight F5 now so you
might have to be really careful there's
no King 86 anymore once the Knight lands
on F5 and if your king is not on 86 this
allows white skin to start marching up
the board
that's right so you'd have to keep the
king out and maybe it would require you
to bring your Bishop
to a square like D1 but let's actually
show that if King E4 Bishop D1 Knight E3
Bishop takes G4 doesn't work because
your King's not on H6 to take the pawn
and if you play Bishop E2 King F5 King
H6 apparently this is still a draw
somehow uh you you have to move for
white
King F6 looks good but then Bishop takes
G4 and you get this Pawn on H5 so you'd
have to move your knight first let's say
Knight D5 but after this check the king
moves up and the bishop goes back
threatening take this pawn and the pawn
on H5 behind it unbelievable
unbelievable stuff but Winston is on top
of his game he says I'm not going to
make my king passive and complicate
things further for myself goes Bishop B7
check because if the white king goes to
E3 Winston simply falls back with the
bishop to C8 putting pressure on the G4
Pawn no improvement there uh Prague
makes the move King F2 and I'm expecting
Bishop C8
it was played so quickly and we should
point out that Bishop takes H5 would be
another way to draw so if this bishop
could get to E8 and take over there uh
the game is just going to be a split
point
and looks like
for Vincent he's just double checking he
knows this to draw his body language is
like come on let's just end this game
I'm hungry it's late uh but he knows
with certainty that he will get a half
Point here
while he's taking his time to be as
precise as possible but I don't think
Precision is that important here black
has got has done everything right and
unless you blunder a one move blunder
every bishop move does hold he goes
Bishop D7 hitting that Knight if Knight
to D6 that's when he will play Bishop E6
uh controlling both squares we see
Prague jumping in with the Knight but it
doesn't really get him that far after
Bishop E6 both F5 and F7 are under
control Knight F5 check as we've pointed
out gets white nothing black trades and
picks up the H5 Bond
and King two after you can always be met
by Bishop D5 check if the King goes to
E3 back to E6 we go and the King goes to
G3 we've seen this position before so
Vincent has done everything correctly
it's moved 66 uh pragnanda still trying
for some Last Hope some mistake from his
opponent but the issue is it's too
simple of a position for Vincent there's
nowhere that he can go wrong he knows
the defensive posture he needs to take
and he's been doing just that
a really nice setup taken there by
Winston with the move G5 many players
might feel that you know you just keep
still you just keep tight keep your Pawn
on G6 but Winston calculated that there
is no way that white can actually
improve his position he fixed his own
Pawn on a dark Square uh on a dark
Square which might look like a weakness
but with the activity of Bishop
everything's under control and these two
prodigies
Prague from India Vincent from Germany
the two big talents I don't even want to
call them Rising Stars anymore or Robert
because they've already made their Mark
in the elite world of chess
it looks like the game between them is
going to end in a draw
I don't even remember how many times
pregnant beat Magnus you know online so
when you've defeated him not just one
time but a handful I think it's clear
that you are at the top of the game and
uh Vincent kymer he has struggled in
this tournament in round one he had a
great position he couldn't win it
against para maxulu in game two with the
white pieces he got a worse position
pretty early against Magnus Carlsen and
then lost in the end game and now here
in game three uh he's played quite
creatively I actually have been
impressed as his position according to
the uh engines the evaluation was such
that pragmata had a better position but
he was able to liquidate in a way that
left the advantage for his opponent but
made it so that many of the end games
would still have drawers tendencies
very nice resistance here by Vincent in
rounds that he's found it's so difficult
you we say that he's had a tough start
to the tournament but if you really
think about it he got a great game
against Parham in round one and then
that slight tactical inaccuracy which
really can happen to anyone he missed
out on that advantage and uh of course
Parham was on top of his game founded
immediately and it ended in a draw but
Winston was the one who was dominating
that game with the black pieces he
showed some great prep showed a
uncompromising play went in to sacrifice
an exchange but a tactical Miss just
gave up his Advantage meanwhile in game
two when you're playing against Magnus
just anything can happen you can't be
too disappointed he did put up as much
resistance as he could but Magnus won
that game and this one it's been a tough
tough day for Winston but he's really
held his own and now we see a different
structure the king from 86 has come on
to F6 but nothing's really changed
because is immediately threatening to
take on F5 if you make the move 8-6
black just needs to be careful at this
point don't grab the Knight Bishop takes
F5 G takes F5 and you can't pick up the
pawn on F5 because the H Pawn queens and
if you move your
and this is game over and instead if you
go King F7 white will come forward with
the King and will win the game so don't
take on F5 but after eight six just a
simple move King to G6 first put
pressure on this 86 pawn and the next
move you grab the Knight you grab the
pawn and shake hands
that's right so do not get Hasty because
haste makes waste King F6 now threatens
the Knight out of five after H6 you
first have to track it down capture that
pawn after captioning not enough five so
uh Vincent's doing everything right
because I think this is the most forcing
of variations if he had gone King to H7
he still has to triple check certain
things when the white king goes forward
he's saying you're not moving your king
your knight is under attack and if your
knight moves say to D4 the bishop can go
somewhere even back to C8 where it was
attacking this Pawn on G4 and no
progress has been made
and Winston there knows that he's got
everything under control gets up takes a
bit of a walk frog has tried everything
that he can but he just never it was
just never enough he did everything that
he could got a great position was up
ahead by two pawns but that opposite
color Bishop end game Winston always
within the jaw reach
yes and
and we've seen his facial expressions
he's just ready to call this one dude go
home get some food and prepare for uh
the fourth round and uh it's not too
late in if I can say the round starts in
the afternoon which is nice for the
players chess players always like waking
up late they don't like the early rounds
Tyler do you know a single chess player
who prefers to play in the morning
I think chess players are just not
mourning people in general whether
there's a round or not most chess
players really like waking up late uh
it's because we're so used to playing in
the afternoons and whenever there are
these double rounds that happen at
tournaments you know they usually happen
in the morning and then you have to play
in the evening it's an absolute torture
to wake up in the morning it's just not
something that is in chess player's DNA
we're just not mourning people
no we are not uh but it is good to be
young and these two players in their
teenage years they probably can play at
any time they have the energy they are
ready to square off no matter who the
opponent is no matter the location or
the occasion and you see both of them
looking like they're ready for a nap
because prognanda puts his head down he
understands he's not winning this game
Vincent's understood that for a while
and just wants to get it over with but
these two are going to be playing for a
long long time as they're not even yet
20 years old hey there's energy when you
need it
there is energy
so that's Vincent with his bar of Mars
I'm getting kind of hungry just looking
at it
what is your preferred source of energy
during a game Robert because that is
what is so special about Chess that it's
in classical chess you know you have to
make sure that in the third fourth hour
of play your brain is still at maximum
capacity to be able to play optimal
chess so what is it usually for you do
you do you usually munch on chocolates
or usually it's me not playing because I
don't often play chess uh but if I had
to choose something I feel like yeah a
little chocolate bar is what does the
trick I actually don't really eat much
during my games I drink a lot of water
though what about you
I I tend to forget and then um you know
I remember this was at the Olympiad and
this was after some game after a really
long game I think it was after game one
that my coach told me that you know you
just have this thing where you're not
drinking or eating anything and playing
these long rounds and I just tend to
forget about it so he would make sure
that you know into the third fourth hour
of play that there would be something on
my table kept there so that I would be
reminded to refresh myself and eat
something or drink a cup of tea and
otherwise I I think I'm like I'm like
you I just tend to just forget I'm so
involved in the game uh you would just
have a glass of water but it's kind of
hard to think about food when the game
is on
yeah what I'm thinking about right now
is when your last people in the playing
Hall which they literally are and I've
had that experience before where you
look around like where'd everybody go
how long has it really been and there
were people at every single chessboard
you see on the screen there and now it's
just Vincent and Prague and it looks
like Max vormanam in the background in
the challengers uh tournament so not
many people remain is that Max against
uh Alien Rovers over there
Elaine Roberts who had a brilliant game
against Urban Lamy uh yesterday and what
an attacking play that was I just loved
it the way she sacrificed her Queen
after Bishop takes E5 definitely a game
that you should watch everyone who's
watching should have a look at if you
haven't already uh but it looks like
yeah these are the only two boards on I
saw just a little a few a couple of
Spectators we can see them still sitting
and having a look at the game these are
true chess fans who in the sixth hour of
play as well are at the tournament Hall
and we've been talking about this that
uh it must be what around 7 P.M in
waikansea right now the players are
getting hungry they're getting tired but
we can even still see the spectators
hanging around till the very last game
uh doesn't and
so you know it's good to be young
because I remember the last tournament I
played in which was the Grand Swiss at
the Isle of Man I played against Ruslan
Panama in the first round and he had
rook and Bishop and I had a rook and I
was defending it accurately and at some
point he just offered me a drop because
he's like yeah I'm hungry I gotta go to
the restaurant like you know I don't
want to keep pressing you on this you
know how to do it but these two I mean
you see Prague he wants to play this
forever if he can he just wants uh to
play until the final move and a reminder
for people who are not so familiar with
the rules of Chess if you go 50 moves
without a pawn push or a peace capture
the game is declared a draw so the last
Pawn push that I see was on move 56
where I'm now I move 72. so if pragnana
wants to make Vincent suffer he can keep
this go game going for many more moves
he's going to do that I I can't imagine
a universe where Prague actually makes
life easy here and just offers a draw I
think he will play it down although he
is looking into the distance which makes
me feel he might just do it right now
and prove me completely wrong and that
would be hilarious but uh right now the
position that we have the one thing that
black needs to watch out for is a check
on e4 with the Knight because just
imagine Robert In This Very position if
white could give a check on e4 there
would be no good place for the king
where you can defend the G5 Pawn Till
There are threats alive frog will keep
on playing Bishop D5 played
it's a bit of a repetition right because
you go back with the king the bishop
falls back to E6
absolutely and I was going to ask you a
question uh Tanya if you're honest with
me and with everybody who's watching
when you play a position like this from
the black side are you annoyed at your
opponent like do you actively feel like
you dislike them a little bit because
they're making you play a dead drawn
position or are you like you know what
if I had the white piece in this game I
would play it out which is your mindset
the latter definitely the latter I don't
think that I would be thinking about how
annoying I am at the opponent it really
depends on my Hunger level at this
moment but I think in most cases for me
it would be realizing that if I was
white I would be doing the exact same
thing and uh yeah I would try to play it
out till as long as possible being on
the defense is never easy and I have
seen so many players mess up situations
like this it happens all the time in
chess it's inexplicable but it does
happen so you have to make the most of
your chances and it's not not over till
it's over so being on the defense I
would try and stay as alert as I could
for any tactics that I could miss out
like I was pointing out that check on e4
uh and yeah I would I would totally
believe that I need to still prove that
I'm holding this position no matter how
draw how much of a draw it looks what
about you you may you may believe that
I'm not sure I believe you you know I
mean everyone gets a bit annoyed at
their opponent when they have to pull
this out it's nothing about them as a
person but you're just kind of like I
you know I know that this game is a draw
but uh you are right though in all
seriousness like you should play it out
if there even is a sliver of hope that
you can win and if this Knight gets to
E4 with check that would give white a
second pawn and allow white to win the
game if the Knight as we previously were
look looking at if the Knight went to F7
would check you could win a pawn in that
manner so there is at least a winning
configuration of pieces and if you keep
that in mind then there is a point to
playing this out this isn't just like
Rook versus rook and nothing else going
on so I am with you on that front though
I do get annoyed for sure when I'm on
the worst side but when I'm on the
better side I'm like yeah I have no
sympathy for my opponent you're gonna
suffer exactly you do the exact same
thing but right now looking at what we
have and prague's Body Language it looks
like Prague has done and used up every
sliver of hope that he has in this end
game and he realizes that there really
isn't something to play for if he's
seeking F3 it would imply that he's done
trying this position and that would be a
draw for because it's essentially a
repetition but if not it's kind of hard
to see how he plans to uh continue this
position but you're right you know it is
true that I would understand my opponent
trying to make a winning attempt in this
and continuing to play well it wouldn't
stop me from just you know thinking that
can you just already offer a draw now
although I I you did call me out on it
yeah but I think of for also being
honest with ourselves I feel like I've
had games where I have that mindset and
then I lose because I'm thinking about
like how annoyed I am and I lose
concentration just that little bit and
that is what chess is all about you need
to be fully focused the entire time
because the moment you start thinking
subjectively or about how you want to go
eat and your opponent's stopping you
from doing that is the moment you
actually lose sight of the position and
make a mistake now Vincent is
confidently bringing his King back to F7
back to F6 to G7 to H6 he understands
that it's very difficult for him to go
wrong as long as he doesn't blunder a
night Fork but I'm gonna show that very
nightfork that Tanya was just talking
about is let's say we get this position
and you're King F6 suddenly there's
Knight E4 check and you lose the pawn on
G5 your king cannot go to F5 it cannot
go to G6 your King has to take a step
back and then you lose the pawn on G5
and then the white king helps the ponds
go on and promote so uh that's the one
square it's kind of a mine square and
then F7 if the king is on H6 or F6
you know what's the other mind square if
your king is on F6 Robert it's all the
way back at eight seven even a check
from eight seven it's just geometry that
you need to be aware of you know while
you're playing that Imagine a King on F6
a check from 87 would also end up
winning the G5 Pawn but right now
Winston says no checks just King to G7
if white goes in with Knight F5 super
important to not trade because in this
particular instance it would land up in
a lost King Pawn ending because white is
in time with the King coming into G4 you
can't really pick up either of the pawns
and let's just back up if after Knight
F5 all you have to do is move your king
uh back to F7 and you're good to go or
to F6 uh which also makes a lot more
sense now we've got a position which we
had a couple of moves ago where once
again Winston has transferred the king
to eight six so now the Mind Square as
you call it Robert is is F7
right gotta avoid allowing a knight to
that square but if the bishop gets the
F7 there could be Bishop takes H5 so he
goes King to E4 Bishop G4 Bishop G4
Bishop G4 is game over yeah he knows it
he's just uh making the draw without
offering it exactly and there the draw
is agreed to after Knight takes G4 King
takes H5 the last Pawn is gone so these
players split the point at long last
look at Vincent he finally allows
himself to crack a smile because he's
been defending for hours and hours
he's got reasons to be proud it wasn't
an easy position to be uh defending for
so long and there we see uh we see
Spectators and this is what is also the
beauty of Chess right you've got these
two young talents who are not even 20.
one is 18 one is 17 years old and then
you've got a bunch of Spectators across
age groups watching them play chess
truly breaks all barriers
and these are teenagers so I wouldn't be
surprised if their parents are you know
out there somewhere coming to pick them
up and take them to dinner but all seven
games are finished we see six draws on
the scoreboard for today's matches
Fabiano caruana the only winner Antonio
you were correct to point this out it's
more that Jordan Von Forrest lost the
game than Fabiano won the game I feel
like Jordan's blunder it was one of his
worst blunders in a long time
Robert you've been mentioning that
Jordan has been shaky in the first
couple of rounds I was arguing against
it but today I see your point that one
move blunder is definitely something
that's a big sign of somebody who is out
of shape your needs to get a check on
that it's a long tournament ahead and it
only gets tougher the only decisive game
Fabiano caruana ended with a win for the
white pieces the other six games were
all hard fought big battles that ended
in a draw we saw for me the big one was
Arjun against Levon such a great end
game this was a masterpiece uh in end
games I think one for the books
brilliantly played by both players in
the end Archer managed to survive that
with that just one decisive game and
that means for our leaderboard going
into round four this is what it looks
like we've got five players at the top
Robert
we do Magnus Carlson five unit carwana
joins the rest Anish giri dingly Wren
and nodir Beck abdusitar previously LED
Fabiano with the win jumps into that tie
and then right behind them we have a
bunch of players some former champions
of this event Wesley so and Levon
aronian and then we got some of the
young guard Arjun aragaisi Arham
muksudlu and prognanda with one and a
half out of three so uh from 8 10 on
this graphic here Argent Parham and
pragnanda they're hungry for their first
victories in the Masters Tournament in
total steel and let's see if they might
get them tomorrow because tomorrow's
matchups are going to be super
interesting we have more teenage battles
Tanya and then we also have
um Magnus Carlsen as per usual he's
gonna be a game to keep our eyes on but
he'll get the black pieces I'm also very
happy to see amongst the leader one of
the Young Guns nodded back with two
points he is of course with the with the
Young Generation here in this Narrative
of it being an established Elite but
versus the new generation of talents and
we see that this is the action that's
coming up for round four also a huge
storyline for tomorrow of course Robert
is that this is uh the final round
before the first rest day so the players
are very aware of that and usually what
happens then is that you don't want to
mess up too many things because going
into a rest there with a loss is always
really tricky it's going to be
interesting to see which player keeps up
the fighting spirit and goes all out in
the round before the first rest day of
the Tata Steel
and sometimes it is dangerous to go all
out it can backfire Jordan Von Forest he
kind of went all out with his
preparation today a temporary night
sacrifice then throwing his pawns up the
board but overlooking a tactic that he
should have seen But on that note it has
been a fun round three one win for
Fabiana carwana and he joins the leaders
the rest of the games were drawn it's
been a long day some very hard fought
end games that finish with some peace
but we'll get peaceful night ahead
tomorrow will be more fights in Vikings
a until then we'll see you have a good
one
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]